CALLING FOR MEMBERS THIS IS THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HEARING. A
TODAY ON APRIL TWENTY FIFTH.
JUST A FEW HOUSEKEEPING RULES
BEFORE WE GET STARTED MISTER
SPEAKER HAS APPOINTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARK STONE TO FILL IN THE
DEMOCRATIC VACANCY FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ONLY.
WE HAVE EIGHTEEN ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY. IN ORDER MOVE
THROUGH THE AGENDA INEXPERIENCED
MANNER PLEASE NOTE THAT WE WILL
ALLOW TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BEYOND THESE LIMITS PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION.
BREVITY IS APPRECIATED THANK
YOU.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARS
BILLS AND SIGN IN ORDER OUR
FIRST BILL THIS AFTERNOON WILL
BE I.
SEE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B.
THREE ONE SEVEN SEVEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHABAS PLEASE
JOIN IF.
AND WELCOME.
WELL I SHOULD SAY THAT WE ARE
STARTING OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I
APOLOGIZE.
THANK VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
FERTILE ALLOW ME TO PRESENT AB
THREE ONE SEVEN SEVEN.
THIS BRAILLE IS A DISTRICT BILL
WILL BRING NORTH COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT CAN BE PARITY WITH
OTHER LOCAL TRANSIT DISTRICTS.
PROVIDE THEM WITH CONSISTENT
PROCUREMENT OPTIONS IN ORDER TO
OBTAIN THE BEST VALUE OF THE
WRITER TO TAXPAYERS.
AB THREE ONE SEVEN SEVEN.
GIVES NC. ABILITY TO JOIN THE
CALIFORNIA UNIFORM CONSTRUCTION
COST ACCOUNTING ACT.
SIMILAR TO OTHER TRANSIT
DISTRICTS SO IT CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A STREAMLINED
CONTRACT ZING PROCESSES.
NEIGHBORING TRANSIT DISTRICT
CHARITY ENJOY THE UNIFORM
CONTRACTING AND PROCUREMENT
PROCESSES.
STEMMING FROM TWO THOUSAND FIVE
LEGISLATION AND THEY CAN BE
FOUND ELSEWHERE IN THE STATUTE.
WE'RE LOOKING TO BRING IN CT AND
INTO PARITY WITH OTHER
NEIGHBORING TRANSIT DISTRICTS TO
BENEFIT THE DISTRICT THE WRITERS
AND THE TAXPAYERS.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF AND FOR A BILL DOES NOT.
DOES EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO ACHIEVE. THIS BILL ENJOYS NO
OPPOSITION AND I'VE JENNIFER
TAYLOR FROM NORTH CALTRANS
DISTRICT HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE.
INCLUDE MY PRESENTATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND JENNIFER
TAYLOR CHIEF PROCUREMENT
CONTRACT ADMINISTRATION OFFICER
FOR THE NORTH COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
CHAVEZ STATED THIS PROVIDES
PARITY WITH.
TRANSIT AGENCIES AND REGIONAL
AGENCIES AND WITH PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTING STATUTES AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MOVE THE
BILL.
ONLY BEEN ABLE TAKE MUCH YET
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU THOUGH SO THE SOUNDS
LIKE YOU MIGHT HAVE. FIVE.
JUST A HEADS UP.
OKAY IS THERE ANY.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OTHER ANY IN OPPOSITION.
THINK WE HAVE ONE IN OPPOSITION.
A NO NO.
OKAY.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
NO COURSE OF THE CAN MINUTE. SO
WE WILL.
DIM CLOSING.
NO I JUST ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND BELIEVE IT SUPPORT SUPPORT
SO EVEN SHORT.
OKAY WE WILL TAKE A VOTE ONCE WE
GET A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
LIKE VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO SINCE WE ARE
LACKING SOME OTHER PRESENTERS
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON SPILL.
AND THAT IS.
NUMBER LET'S SEE HERE.
A NUMBER SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
SIXTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH WILL EXEMPT THE SALE
OR LEASE OF SPECIFIC FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROPERTIES FROM THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE STATE.
THAT THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
IS GIVEN THE FIRST RIGHT OF
REFUSAL A RULE THAT WAS CREATED
THREE SB FIFTY LAST YEAR.
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY PROVIDES A
VERY LIMITED EXEMPTION FROM
SPECIFIC FEDERAL MILITARY
INSTALLATIONS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
ARE PARTICIPATING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE BASE
REALIGNMENT AND CLOSURE. ACHEI
BRAK TRANSFER AND REDEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO
ONE OF THESE FORMER BASIS THE
CONCORD NAVAL WEAPONS STATION.
THE CITY OF CONCORD IS THE LOCAL
RE USE AUTHORITY FOR THIS FORMER
NAVAL BASE AND HAS BEEN WORKING
WITH THE U. S. NAVY FOR OVER
THIRTEEN YEARS ON THE BASIS
TRANSFERRED TO LOCAL CONTROL. A.
B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY WOULD EXEMPT
THIS FEDERAL PROPERTY FROM
RECENTLY ENACTED STATE LAW S. B.
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
WHICH WILL ENABLE THE CITY OF
CONCORD TO COMPLETE THE FEDERAL
TRANSFER PROCESS. AS PART OF THE
CITIES WE USE PROJECT THE BILL
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AND FOR THIS REASON I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I DO
HAVE GUEST.
.
WELL ALLOW YOU TO SO PRODUCE
COMETA PRIOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GUY PURITY.
AND THE DIRECTOR COMMUNITY WE
USE PLANNING FOR THE CITY OF
CONCORD.
A WE THINK THAT BRACH TRANSFERS
IN REDEVELOPMENT PROJECTS NOW
TAKING PLACE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ARE DISTINCTLY
DIFFERENT FROM THE TYPES OF
FEDERAL LAND TRANSFERS TO THIRD
PARTY SO LEGISLATURE. AND THE
GOVERNOR SOUGHT TO OVERSEE WHEN
YOU ENACTED S. B. FIFTY LAST
YEAR.
BARBARA TRANSFER IN
REDEVELOPMENT PROJECTS WILL NOT
THREATEN ANY NATIONAL FOREST
PARKS OR OTHER NATURAL RESOURCES
IN FACT OUR GOAL IS TO CREATE A
TRANSIT ORIENTED DEVELOPMENT.
AROUND THE NORTH CONCORD BART
STATION WHICH WILL PROVIDE JOBS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING HABITAT
CONSERVATION AREAS REGIONAL AND
LOCAL PARKS. AND A FUTURE SITE
FOR A UNIVERSITY CAMPUS.
WE THINK THIS.
EXEMPTION WHICH WOULD STILL
REQUIRE THE APPROVAL OF THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION IS
INAPPROPRIATE EXEMPTION WITHOUT
UNDERMINING VIA TED. OF SP FIFTY
AND WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
REJECT THIS GOD.
USUALLY ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
NO.
PANDA
AND ME.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO COUNTER.
ONE WE GO AHEAD THE STEPS THE
CORPSMAN THAT BE OKAY WITH YOU
WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM HERE COVER GYRO COOLEY.
COOLEY HERE GRAYSON HERE GRAYSON
HERE LACKEY LACKEY HERE STONE
VOCA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APOLOGIZE
FOR INTERRUPTING BUT FUN.
BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
WELL.
I'LL BE PATIENT.
EVERY PATIENT WITH THE MOTION
WAS TRYING TO FIGURE THINGS OUT
HERE YEAH. OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION SO FAR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES I WOULD A THIS BILL
AS WAS ALREADY STATED.
BY THE DIRECTOR.
I IS A BILL THAT IS UNIQUE TO
FABRIC OF PUBLIC LANDS.
THAT WERE NOT NECESSARILY
INTENDED FOR S. B. A FIFTY FROM
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
SO WITH THAT AND THE UNIQUENESS
OF THIS BILL AND HOW IT APPLIES
TO MILITARY BASES I WOULD SIMPLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND A SECOND
ON THEM. MOTION.
ALL SECOND THE BILL.
IS SERENA HAVE.
SECOND OF SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSING
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGAR CURRY I'VE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON AYE AYE
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
STONE VOEPEL.
BILLS UP FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
BUT DO LUDDEN FELLOW BUT MORE
HOUSEKEEPING RIGHT NOW WILL DO.
JUST THE ROLE.
IN IT WHOM WE NEED A MOTION.
AND A SECOND FOR A. B. THREE ONE
SEVEN SEVEN THAT WOULD BE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHABAS.
IT WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
COOLEY A SECOND BY MS.
MISTER LACKEY.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL EMOTION
IS DUE PASSING REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
WALDRON BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO COOLEY COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
STONE VOEPEL.
MEASURES OUT FIVE ZERO.
AGAIN WE ARE GOING TO GO OUT OF
ORDER HERE LITTLE BIT AND WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM SPILL AND THAT IS ITEM
NUMBER.
WHA ITEM NUMBER ONE OF SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. I DON'T THINK I
WITNESSED A FAIR BUT LET'S LET'S
WING IT.
SPEAK SLOWLY.
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO LET ME START OFF BY.
IT'S COMMITTEE HAVE AMENDMENTS
YEAH I'M LOOKING AT THEIR NOTES
FROM THE PRIOR COMMITTEE.
SO FORGET ABOUT THAT BUT I WAS
HAPPY TO TAKE AMENDMENTS IN THE
PRIOR COMPLETELY. AND HOW.
WE HAVE MAN ACCOMPLISHMENTS
LAST YEAR ON THE HOUSING ISSUE
INCLUDING AB THIRTEEN NINETY
SEVEN OF WHICH I WAS A JOINT
AUTHORED S. B. THIRTY FIVE OF
COURSE. AND SEVERAL OTHER BILLS
BUT THESE BILLS THAT MEAN VERY
LITTLE IF THE STATE RINA
ALLOCATIONS ARE NOT EQUITABLE
AND DATA DRIVEN BECAUSE THEY.
DEPEND ON OUR RINA PROCESS.
FAIR AND ACCURATE REALLOCATION
IS THAT ENSURE EVERY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PLAYING A PART IN
ADDRESSING THE HOUSING CRISIS IS
THE MAIN GOAL OF AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. THE EXISTING
PROCESS TOO OFTEN IGNORES THAT
DATA AND ALLOWS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO PUSH BACK TO WHAT
THEY'RE COMFORTABLE WITH. RATHER
THAN WHAT THEY COULD ACTUALLY
ACCOMMODATE WITH CHANGES IN
ZONING.
IN AN EFFORT TO ADD AN
INDEPENDENT VOICE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY ONE ADDS EIGHT CD TO THE
RAIN A PROCESS. THAT ALLOWS THEM
TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
DISTRIBUTION METHODOLOGY IS
CONSISTENT ITH THE LAW BEFORE
THE NUMBERS ARE EVEN RUN SO THAT
THE COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS TO
THE.
THE NEXT
STAGE OF THE PROCESS OR ONE
STAGE OF THE PROCESS CAN MAKE.
ANY NEEDED CHANGES.
THE EXISTING PROCESS PROVIDES A
LOOPHOLE THAT CAN ALLOW POLITICS
TO OVERRIDE PROCESS
UNFORTUNATELY BUYING CLUED IN
LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS FOR. A
COUNCIL GOVERNMENT TO ADD. A ANY
OTHER FACTORS TO THEIR
DISTRIBUTION METHODOLOGY
AT THIS BILL NARROWS THAT
DEFINITION SO THAT.
ANY OTHER FACTORS WELCOME.
A AYE KHAGARIA AT A REQUIRES
THAT ALL FACTORS BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOALS OF THE STATUTE SO
THAT CONSISTENCY REQUIREMENT
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL.
A THIS BILL ALLOWS ORGANIZATIONS
TO CHALLENGE RAIN IN NUMBERS AS
WELL AS SURROUNDING
JURISDICTIONS EXISTING GREEN
ALLOCATIONS CAN ONLY BE
CHALLENGED BY GUESS WHO THE
JURISDICTION THAT ASSIGNED THE
RENUMBER THE FIRST PLACE.
IT'S A SYSTEM THAT HASN'T QUITE
WORKED FOR US
OF THE WAY IT SHOULD IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
RENOWNED SETS A AND HOUSING
ALLOCATION FLOOR NOT A CEILING.
AND RINA AS A PLANNING TOOL
THAT'S CRITICAL TO SETTING THE
STAGE FOR HOUSING PRODUCTION OF
THE PROCESS ITSELF IS FLAWED.
THEN WE DON'T GET HOUSING IN THE
PLACES WHERE IT'S MOST NEEDED IN
SOME CITIES.
DO NOT HAVE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
ADDRESSING REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS AND THAT'S SIMPLY WRONG
WHEN JOB RICH JURISDICTIONS
DON'T HAVE TO PLAN FOR HOUSING
IT COMPROMISES OUR ABILITY TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE CALLS AS WELL.
SO THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON
GETTING AN EQUITABLE RINA
DISTRIBUTION WITHIN REGIONS THAT
INSURERS EVERY JURISDICTION IS
DOING ITS FAIR SHARE. AND BY A.
AND HAPPY TO INTRODUCE TO YOU ON
YOUR LAWLER. ON WHO'S JUST
ARRIVED FROM THE WINNER WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY SHE
MAY BE OUT OF BREATH.
THE ELEVATORS NO WELL HOW. TODAY
IS THEY ARE A. GOOD AFTERNOON
THEM TURN MEMBERS ON YELLOW ON
BEHALF THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY ONE OF THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL. I'M SO THERE'S NO
QUESTION THE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
PRODUCE FARMER HOUSING THAN WE
HAVE THEN AND PARTICULARLY
HOUSING AFFORDABLE TO LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WHERE THE
CURRENT SHORTAGE IS BY FAR THE
MOST ACUTE.
BUT AS MISS ROOMS THAT IN
ADDITION TO PAVING THE WAY FOR
MORE PRODUCTION GENERALLY WE
NEED TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
WHERE THE HOUSING IS ACTUALLY
NEEDED AND ENSURE THAT THOSE
PLACES ARE PROVIDING AMPLE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THAT
DEVELOPMENT TO OCCUR.
A HOW THE RING TO GET ALLOCATED
WITHIN A REVIEW A REGION IS
CRUCIAL TO SETTING THE STAGE FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IN PREPARING
THEIR HOUSING ELEMENT CITIES AND
COUNTIES HAVE TO SHOW THAT THEY
HAVE ENOUGH SITES ON FOR HOUSING
TO ACCOMMODATE THEIR ENTIRE
SHARE THE RENOWNED.
AND IN PARTICULAR TO SO THEY CAN
ACCOMMODATE THEIR LOWER INCOME
SHARE THEY HAVE HAVE MULTI
FAMILY. DANCE SITES.
.
THE LAW RECOGNIZES THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES GENERALLY AREN'T IN
THE BUSINESS OF HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT BUT THEY DO PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE THROUGH THEIR
SENDING POWERS AND SETTING THE
STAGE FOR DEVELOPMENT TO HAPPEN.
I THE LAW PROVIDES A LOT OF
PROTECTIONS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
BOTH HURDLE IN MARKET RATE THAT
ARE PROPOSED ON SITES THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DONE FOR HOUSING.
THOSE PROTECTIONS WERE ENHANCE
QUIT LAST YEAR THROUGH A NUMBER
OF BILLS ON HOUSING PACKAGE
ESSENTIALLY IF A DEVELOPER
PROPOSES A HOUSING PROJECT
PROJECT IN A LOCATION THAT IS
ZONED FOR HOUSING ALREADY.
VERY DIFFICULT FOR THAT PROJECT
TO GET TONIGHT HOWEVER NO THESE
LAWS CAN COMPEL PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING A PLACE IS WHERE THERE
IS LITTLE OR NO LEON SOUND FOR
HOUSING IF A JURISDICTION GETS A
LORENA NUMBER THAT EFFECTIVELY
CAN MEAN THAT THE JURISDICTION
CAN SHUT THE DOOR. FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT FOR THE NEXT DECADE
EVEN IF IT'S AN IDEAL LOCATION
FOR NEW HOUSING.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO CRITICAL TO
GET THE REALLOCATION RIGHT.
THE RENO SUPPOSED TO BE
DISTRIBUTED OF A DATA DRIVEN WAY
THAT MEANS A VARIETY OF
STATUTORY GOALS UNFORTUNATELY
REGIONAL POLITICS TAKE OVER
RESULTING IN LOWALLOCATIONS TO
JURISDICTIONS THAT COULD AND
NEED TO ACCOMMODATE MORE
HOUSING.
AND OFTEN OVERLY HIGH
ALLOCATIONS TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS WHERE THAT
DEVELOPMENT REALLY DOESN'T MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE AND IS UNLIKELY
TO OCCUR BECAUSE OF MARKET
CONDITIONS LACK OF JOBS A WHOLE
BUNCH OF OTHER FACTORS.
IF WE'RE GONNA START LOOKING AT
HOW CLOSE PRODUCTION COMES IN
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO MATCHING
THEIR RENO SHARE AND USE THAT AS
A. GAUGE FOR DEFINING SUCCESS
AND FAILURE. AS WE DID LAST YEAR
WITH SB THIRTY FIVE THAT WE HAVE
TO START BY ENSURING THAT THE
REALLOCATION MAKES SENSE.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO
CREATE MORE WORK FOR THE
BECAUSE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE RINA
PROCESS IS ALREADY RATHER TIME
CONSUMING FOR THE COGS.
AND WE DON'T CREATE ANY MORE
WORK FOR THEM BUT.
THE GOAL IS TO TAKE POLITICS
OUT ENSURE THEY'RE PLANNING FOR
HOUSING IN THE RIGHT PLACES AND
THE COMMUNITIES WHERE MORE
HOUSING MAKES SENSE ARE ASKED TO
DO THEIR FAIR SHARE. WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE CARDS MAY FOR THE BILL
DOESN'T ADD TIME AND MORE WORK
AND DOESN'T CREATE CONFLICT
BETWEEN CLIMATE GOALS AN EQUABLE
THE. EQUITABLE DEVELOPMENT GOALS
IN FACT WE THINK THAT IF WE GET
THE REAL ALLOCATIONS RATE IT
WILL HAVE AN OVERALL BENEFIT IN
TERMS OF MEETING CHICHI
REDUCTION TARGETS.
WELL I UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS
FROM BOTH STAKEHOLDERS AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT
CHANGES TO THE PROCESS FOR
APPEALING A REALLOCATION. AND A
PARTICULAR OPENING UP THAT
PROCESS TO CHALLENGES FROM
ENTITIES OTHER THAN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
WHILE WE DO THINK EXISTING
APPEAL PROCESS IS FLAWED WERE
DEATHLY OPENED OTHER APPROACHES
AND IN FACT HOPE THAT IN THE END
WE CAN COME UP WITH A PROCESS
THAT'S BOTH LESS TIME CONSUMING
THAN THE ONE THAT EXISTS NOW AND
MORE FAIR.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT BY PLACING
MORE SCRUTINY ON THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE READ A METHODOLOGY ITSELF
THERE'LL BE LESS NEED FOR
APPEALS AT THE END OF THE
PROCESS.
OTHERS CLEARLY MARKED COME ON
THIS BILL AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE CONVERSATIONS WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO GET THIS
RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WELCOME BRING
ALONG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BELL WHICH WILL OPEN
UP IN PARTICULAR AREAS OF HIGH
OPPORTUNITY TO FORTY HOUSING
DEVELOPERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SEAN BEHALF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE AS WE BELIEVE IT
WILL RESULT IN MORE EQUITABLE
READ ALLOCATIONS. AND ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS HAULING
MICHON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL A WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION ON THE
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
SENATE GEORGIA THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION I'M WE HAVE
X. ACTUALLY HAVE A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED BUT ONLY SO WE CAN BE
PART OF THE CONTINUING
DISCUSSION BUT WE DO SUPPORT IT.
THINKING.
I ASSISTANCE AND ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE AUTHOR STAFF
AND THE SPONSORS A TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS AND WITH THE FUTURE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE GOING TO
TRIAL.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OF THOSE OF THAT
OPPOSE THE BILL.
UP BILL HIGGINS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNCILS
OF GOVERNMENT AND WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
LARGELY BECAUSE OF ALL THE
POINTS THAT.
REPRESENTED FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER RAISED ARE BASICALLY ARE
POINTS THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON
SO SHE ANTICIPATED MY TALK VERY
MUCH.
.
I WOULD SAY THAT I WORK OKAY
YEAH.
TOOK THAT THAT THAT A CLASSIC
SHE TOOK ALL MY LINES.
BUT DO A COUPLE THINGS BECAUSE
OUR MANY OF BECAUSE ARE ALSO THE
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE CHARGED
WITH.
DEVELOPING THEIR PLANS UNDER S.
B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE MY CLIMATE
REDUCTION PLANS.
AND SO THAT RECONCILIATION POINT
BETWEEN THE TWO IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US BECAUSE.
IF CHARGED AS THE LEGISLATURE A
OR B. WITH THE PRETTY AGGRESSIVE
TARGET TO REDUCE GHGS BY TWENTY
FIFTY AND THEY'RE ON IT THEY'RE
DOING THAT NOW HOLDING OUR FEET
TO THE FIRE. AND YOU'RE รณ WITH
BILLS LIKE THIS YEAR OLD
CHARGING US ALSO TO DO IN EQUITY
DISTRIBUTION. AND EIGHT CITIES
GOING TO BE ON IT. AND WE THINK
THAT THOSE ARE APPROVED THINGS
COULD CONFLICTS SOMETIMES IN
TERMS OF HOW WE CAN ACHIEVE OUR
TARGET AND WE DO NEED A WAY TO
FIGURE THAT OUT. WOULD ALSO
POINT OUT THAT.
CLOGS.
DO NOT RECEIVE ANY FUNDING SO WE
APPRECIATE FOR THE RING UP SO WE
APPRECIATE THE THE.
NOT MAKING THIS MORE DIFFICULT
BUT WE ARE PROHIBITED BY THE
COMMISSION STATE MANDATES PER
GETTING ANY KIND OF MANDATE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THE WORK THAT
WE DO.
AND SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
FINALLY ON THIS COMMITTEE IN
THIS ISSUE IS IT'S POINTED OUT
IN THE ANALYSIS. UP WE WOULD
LOOK FORWARD TO A COMMITMENT TO
WORK TO AN ALTERNATIVE TO IN
INTRODUCING THIRD PARTIES INTO
THE PROCESS OF APPEALING AND
FINDING A NARROWER RANGE TO
ADDRESS THE PRINCIPLES.
THAT THAT I THINK THEY'RE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
BECAUSE THE RTP TIMELINE IT YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO ADOPT THE RESULT
TRANSPORTATION PLAN IN A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF TIME IF GOING TO
DELIVER THE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS. CRITICALLY WITH S. B.
ONE AROUND. SO WOULD THAT TIME
WHEN IT'S REALLY TIGHT IN
COORDINATED.
AND ADDING TIME AND DELAY TO
THAT PROCESS COULD DELAY THE OUT
COME OF THAT'S WE NEED TO FIGURE
THAT OUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SHE'S
FRIENDLY CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
WHICH YOU DON'T HAVE A POSITION
YOU KNOW IF IT'S AN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
SPONSORED.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH A COUPLE
THINGS THAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT A WE CERTAINLY MAKE SURE
THE ALLOCATION IS CORRECT. AND
WE THINK THE PROCESS NOW IT MAY
BE ISN'T ISN'T THE BEST AND IS
AND ALWAYS BASED IN REALITY MOST
IMPORTANTLY DEMAND IN THAT
COMMUNITY. SO I THINK YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES THAT WILL BE KEY
UMBELS AFFLECK FOR THE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND AND AND MAKE
IT INTO A BILL THAT WE CAN
POTENTIALLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NOT OTHER
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE. ACT
AND ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AYE.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY APPLAUD YOU AND
YOUR EFFORT TO WORK WITH A BILL
WITH RING THAT IN ITSELF. AND
THAT TO TRY TO MAKE IT A BIT
MORE PRODUCTIVE IN A TOOL THAT
ACTUALLY GET SOMETHING DONE.
EYES รณ WITH THAT JUST WOULD
ALSO EXPRESS MY MY CONCERN OR
CAUTION OVER THE ISSUE OF THIRD
PARTY.
.
ONLY FOR THE SAKE THAT WE HAVE
ANOTHER ACTING CALIFORNIA THAT
IS USED QUITE OFTEN. BY THIRD
PARTIES THAT DOES ADD.
EXTENSIVE TIME ONTO A PROJECT
OR COMPLETELY TAKES IT OUT OF
THE REALM OF PENCILING OUT.
SO.
WOULD EXPRESS MY CONCERN ABOUT
THAT I SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND.
LOOK FOR TO SEEING HOW A TIE
INS UP AS OPPOSED TO THE
PROCESS.
YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE NEED A MOTION.
MONTEBELLO FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON.
I'LL SECOND THE BILL.
OKAY.
DIFFICULT IN STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
OF MAKE A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITHOUT. THE OF
OPPONENTS TO THE BILL.
I AM I.
TOTALLY SUPPORT YOUR BILL THE
DAY AND I THINK WE NEED TO YOU
KNOW WORK WITH WIENER A LETTER
BETTER EFFORT BECAUSE SOME
PEOPLE DON'T THINK THAT'S
WORKING SO WELL AS I'VE SEEN IN
MY COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR SAYING YOUR WORK
WITH EVERYONE ON THE APPEALS
PROCESS FOR THIS. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT YOU GUYS
COME UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY WITHOUT.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
EMOTION IS DUE PASSED IN REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM. BLOOM I HAVE
THE ARROW COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY KNOWS
STONE VOEPEL.
IT'S ON KALRA YOU WAY FOR OTHERS
TO COME IN TODAY
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY NINE IT
A TWO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERSOF THE COMMITTEE HERE
PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
TWO WHICH WOULD AT A NON VOTING
MEMBER TO THE NORTH COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT'S BOARD.
NOTHING IT'S ET BECAUSE ALL
THOUSAND HOURS IN CT. ARE AT THE
TIME OF IN CD'S CREATION BY THIS
A LEGISLATURE IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE THE AGENCY DID NOT
SERVICE THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
AND THEREFORE THERE WAS NO NEED
TO INCLUDE REPRESENTATION FROM
THAT JURISDICTION ON ITS BOARD.
HOWEVER IN CT NOW SERVICES THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO THROUGH THE.
IT'S COASTER SERVICE A TRAIN OF
SERVICE. AS WELL AS BUS SERVICE
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO TO HAVE A DIRECT LINE
OF COMMUNICATION FOR THE
HAPPENINGS OF THIS AT THIS
AGENCY. BUT BY ADDING.
THAT BY ADDING A NON VOTING
MEMBER FOR THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WE HOPE TO ENGAGE FURTHER OF
THIS ORGANIZATION WITH REGARD TO
ISSUES LIKE STATION MAINTENANCE
EXPANSION PLANS AND OTHER
OPERATING PRACTICES. ON THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO STREETS IN IN ITS
IN THAT ENVIRONMENT WITH HIS
JURISDICTION WITH ME TODAY HAVE
ONE WITNESS OUT CONSTITUENT
JANET ROGERS SHE IS A MEMBER THE
TRAIN COALITION OF OF THE STATE
AT SANTA FE DEPOT. THIS
COALITION REPRESENTS RESIDENTS
WHO LIVE ADJACENT TO ONE OF THE
STATIONS OPERATED OR THAT IS
UTILIZED US I SHOULD SAY
UTILIZED BY NCT.
ROCKMAN JANET.
WHO WHO THANK YOU?
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
TURN COALITION OF SANTA FE DEPOT
THANK YOU FOR HEARING AB TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY TWO. AND THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
WHEN NORTH COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT NCT DE WAS CREATED.
BOARD MEMBERSHIP REFLECTED THE
JURISDICTION OF THE TRANSIT
AGENCY. IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
WHEN THE COASTER TRAINS STARTED
OPERATING IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. THE BOARD MEMBERSHIP WAS
NOT AMENDED TO REFLECT THE
EXTENDED JURISDICTION.
THIS PROPOSAL ADJUST VERY
LEGISLATION CREATES A MATCH
BETWEEN WHERE NCT DE OPERATES
AND REPRESENTATION ON THIS
BOARD.
WE SUPPORT AND INA NON VOTING
MEMBER TO NCT DE.
WE SEE THIS LEGISLATION AS A WIN
WIN SITUATION.
THE ADDITION OF A NON VOTING
BOARD MEMBER GIPSON CTD A
SUPPORTER FOR EXPANSION PLANS IN
SAN DIEGO AND FOR STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING REQUEST
SPECIALLY FOR NEW EQUIPMENT.
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO GAINS
KNOWLEDGE IN INPUT OPPORTUNITIES
INTO THE COASTERS OPERATIONS IN
SAN DIEGO. AND MORE INSIGHT INTO
MCT DAYS MAINTENANCE BUDGET
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THREE OF THE A COASTER STATIONS
ARE IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
AND NCT DE HAS MAINTENANCE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR EACH OF THE
STATIONS IN FACT NCT DE HAS SOLE
RESPONSIBILITY. FOR MAINTAINING
THE COASTER AN AMTRAK TRANSIT
COURTYARD IT'S AN OF A DEPOT IN
AREAS CONSIDER REGIONAL ASSET
THE LINEAR PARK. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THE BABY TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY TWO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NEW WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU.
MISTER GLORIA FOR YOUR STAFF
WAS VERY RESPONSIVE TO SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE HAD AND.
.
I'M JUST WONDERING.
WHY OF TO TWENTY THREE YEARS?
BEING REQUESTED.
I WOULD BE HAPPY AND SET. UP WAS
BECAUSE THE EXPAND THE INSIDIOUS
EXPANDED SERVICES WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. I'M I DON'T RESPECT THE
FACT HE SERVED ON THIS BOARD.
AWHILE BACK.
AND I THINK SOME OF THE
OPERATION TO HAPPEN AT THAT TIME
THESE OPERATIONS INCREASINGLY AS
YOU MIGHT IMAGINE YOU KNOW
RAISES CONCERNS AND OF
CONSTITUENTS AND OF STAKEHOLDERS
WITHIN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
YOU KNOW I WILL SAY I HAVE A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH THE STAFF
IN CT BY THINK THIS HAS OF THIS
REQUIRES MORE FORMAL
RELATIONSHIP WHICH THE CREATURE
THAT'S OFFICIO SEAT WILL ALLOW.
OUT FOR THE ADDRESS DE DRESSING
OF THESE CONSTITUENT LEVEL
CONCERNED THINGS ABOUT
OPERATIONS NOISE OF MY.
BUT ALSO AS JANET WAS GETTING
TO ABOUT THE PLANS FOR EXPANSION
OF THE POTENTIAL SERVICES.
THROUGHOUT THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO AND THAT KIND OF COOPER OF
ELATION SHOULD COME ONLY HELP IN
CITY CARRY OUT ITS MISSION OF
TRANSPORTING SAN DIEGANS AROUND
THE REGION.
BECAUSE ONE I I SPEAK WITH NORTH
COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT. YOU
KNOW WHEN I WAS ON THE HAVE
EXTENDED PLANNING BUT. I HAVEN'T
REALLY LOOKED TO INCREASE
SERVICE.
ON THE COASTER ANYMORE THAN THEY
HAVE MEAN IT'S WAY OUT IN THE
FUTURE.
WHAT I WOULD?
IS YOU KNOW I SERVE ON THE CITY
COUNCIL AND CITY SAN DIEGO FOR
EIGHT YEARS A DURING THAT TIME
WAS APPROACH MULTIPLE TIMES BY
IN CT TO BUILD AN ADDITIONAL OF.
A TRAIN PLATFORM AT THE
CONVENTION CENTER BY THAT WOULD
BE AN EXPANSION OF SERVICES
DEEPER INTO THE HEART OF
DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO BUT IS NOT
WITHOUT IMPACTS BY AND IS NOT A
PRODUCT OF THE EASILY EXECUTE IT
WITHOUT THE. I THINK DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE CITY
AND THIS AGENCY AGAIN I'M NOT
REPRESENTED THERE'S A BAD
RELATIONSHIP THAT THERE BUT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS HAVE A
DEEPER RELATIONSHIP ONE THAT
ALLOWS FOR MORE FREQUENT
COMMUNICATION. NOT THE AD HOC
INFORMAL NATURE THAT WE HAVE NOW
THAT FRANKLY.
ALMOST IS PUBLIC FIND ON
CERTAIN DAYS DOESN'T REALLY HELP
AND JANET HER NEIGHBORS ARE
PROBABLY A PRETTY GOOD EXAMPLE
OF THAT A GIVEN SOME OF THE.
I THINK QUALITY BY CONCERNS IF
THEY EXPERIENCE DALY TODAY IN
DOWNTOWN SAN DIEGO. THIS ONE I
SERVED ON THE BOARD WAS AT THAT
TIME WHEN THE DISTRICTS WOULD
CHANGE MT DB AT THE TIME AND
NORTH COUNTY TRANSIT DISTRICT.
ARE THERE PLANNING BASICALLY WAS
TAKEN AWAY AND PUT UNDER.
YOU KNOW THE THE REGIONAL
ENTITY.
AND IT'S AND I TOOK OVER.
A LOT OF THE PLANNING SO AS FAR
AS THE SERVICE IN THE PLANNING
AND ALL THAT IT'S ALREADY
REGIONAL.
SO I'M WONDERING WHY YOU'RE
BRINGING SOMEONE ON A BOARD THAT
WE ALREADY HAVE THAT REGIONAL
PLANNING. THAT WAS TAKEN AWAY
FROM THE AND.
SO YOU ARE CORRECT THERE FROM OF
FROM A PLANNING PERSPECTIVE
STANDOUT DOES DO. THAT WORK
ABOUT FROM A SERVICEMAN
OPERATIONS STANDPOINT A THAT IS
IN CT.
AND WHETHER YOU ARE A
CONSTITUENT THAT LIVES NEAR THE
WESTFIELD UTC MALL AND YOU'RE
DEALING A WITH THE BUS IN THE
BREEZE OF VEHICLES IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD OR IF YOU'RE
DOWNTOWN RESIDENT YOU'RE DEALING
WITH COASTER. A VEHICLES IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD EITHER WAY ITS
OPERATIONAL CONCERNS WERE
TALKING ABOUT AND THAT IS A
PLACE FOR THE CITY'S INDIGO HAS
CURRENTLY NO FORMAL VOICE. ON
ADDITION IF I CAN JUST MAYBE
ANTICIPATED FUTURE QUESTION OF
YOU WE EIGHT YOU MAY BE ARGUING
OR ONE COULD ARGUE FOR THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSIT SERVICE IN
THE NORTH COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT.
AND THAT IS NOT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL OBVIOUSLY WE COULD
HAVE WRITTEN A BILL THAT DID
THAT ON BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT IN
TTT WANTS IN SO THAT'S NOT
WHAT'S IN THIS BILL.
BUT EVEN IF THAT'S A SUGGESTION
YOU DON'T HAVE TO CONSOLIDATE
OPERATIONS THAT WAS CONSIDERED
AND REJECTED IN PART OUT OF
RESPECT FOR THE INSIDIOUS
ORGANIZATION.
I MEAN IS THERE CONSIDERATION
FOR HAVING A NORTH COUNTY
ROTATING NONVOTING MEMBER ON
MTS.
MEAN IS THAT SO I'M AWARE OF A
SIMILAR PHENOMENON FOR MTS.
I I DON'T BELIEVE I BELIEVE IT
THE CITIES THERE IT NOT COUNTY
RELATED I GUESS THAT'S PROBABLY
ONLY POWER WAY ON DOES HAVE A
VOTING SEAT ON MTS IS BORED.
AGAIN THIS BILL DOESN'T SPEAK TO
THAT WE'RE TIME EX OFFICIO NOT A
NON VOTING MEMBER.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE BUT YOU
KNOW I I'M NOT AWARE OF INTENSE
BUSES THAT ARE OPERATING IN
ESCONDIDO OR.
TROLLEYS ARE RUNNING IN
OCEANSIDE A THAT THAT ACROSS
JURISDICTIONAL ISSUE DOESN'T
OCCUR THAT IN THAT DIRECTION BUT
IT DOES FROM IN TTT OPERATING ON
CITY STREETS AND ON CITY RIGHT
AWAY INSTEAD DATA. BECAUSE HOW
IS NON IN NORTH COUNTY TRANSIT
DISTRICT AREA SO I DON'T KNOW
WHY I'M JUST. I'M SPEAKING
REGIONALLY FROM I MEAN.
I KNOW THAT WAS OUT OF EIGHT OF
POWAY SOMETHING ACCOUNT
IMMEDIATELY NOT SO MUCH TO YOU
BUT.
AGAIN I'M NOT AWARE OF OF MTS
VEHICLES ARE OPERATIONS
HAPPENING WITHIN IN CITIES A.
AREA.
BUT THEY CERTAINLY DO IN MTS IS
WELL I'M I'M NOT CAN BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE. AND I
JUST DON'T FEEL THAT THERE'S AN.
URGENT NEED.
FOR THIS SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
MIGHT NOT.
EXCUSE ME.
.
AS SOMEONE WHO LIVES NEXT TO
SANTA FE DEPOT. ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE THIS
MAINTENANCE AND WE WENT FOR
QUITE A FEW YEARS WHERE THAT
MAINTENANCE WILL SUBMIT SLACK IS
WHAT I UNDERSTAND I DID IVE
THERE THE TIME. RECENTLY AND HAS
IMPROVED SO ONE OF THE THINGS I
MEAN WE ARE LOOKING THEN IS TO
MAKING SURE THAT LIKE THE BUDGET
IS MAINTAINED IN THAT
MAINTENANCE IS MAINTAINED.
BECAUSE THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL
STATION AND IT IS CONSIDERED
REGIONAL ASSET
AND IF THE BOARD JOB AT THE LAST
BOARD MEETING. THEY JUST
PRESENTED TO THE BOARD MEMBERS
THEIR EXPANSION PLANS AGAIN FOR.
THE CONVENTION CENTER.
EXTENSION SO THEY'RE VERY
ACTIVELY PURSUING THEM AT THIS
POINT IN TIME. AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE GOOD FOR NCT DE TO
HELP.
GET THAT BY HAVING A SUPPORTER
FROM THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO ON
THAT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
COMMENTS YES.
SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON TAKE YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I.
SOME REMEMBER GLORIA. AT THIS
IS OUT OF MY DISTRICT I'M FROM
THE BAY AREA BUT IF I MAY.
I'M MY ATTEMPT IS NOT TO MARCH
LIES YOUR BILL BY
OVERSIMPLIFYING
BUT IF I MAY JUST FOR MY OWN
UNDERSTANDING FOR. THE ATTEMPT
OF THIS BILL IS TO SIMPLY ADD
AVOID A DIRECT VOICE FOR INPUT
ONLY WITHOUT THE POWERS OF
VOTING JUST SIMPLY SO THAT THE
COMMUNICATION CAN BE A BIT MORE
DIRECT. WITH A DEEPER
RELATIONSHIP RATHER THAN GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS IS A
BUREAUCRACY THAT GOVERNMENT CAN
CREATE SOMETIMES.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT MR OKAY
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE.
OKAY I HAVE A MOTION I NEED A
SECOND.
OKAY RIVER SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE
SUSPECT WE ASK YOU AYE VOTE AND
CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY.
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW IT'S KIND GETS
TOUCHY SOMETIMES BUT YOU GOTTA
HAVE.
EVERYBODY IN LINE MAKING SURE
YOUR AREA KEYS KIDS KEPT UP SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CUBBY ARROW COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY NO
STONE VOEPEL.
IT WE NEED ONE MORE VOTE AND
WE'LL GET THE OTHER MEMBERS BACK
HERE HOPEFULLY SOONER THAN
LATER.
THINK OF AND CHECK YOUR VERY
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
COMING UP.
LET'S SEE WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB TWO SEVEN FIVE THREE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN FOLLOWED
BY. FREEING US FROM THEM
FRIEDMAN AB TWO NINE ONE ONE SO
WHAT YOU DO BACK TO BACK SAYS
THAT SOUNDS PERFECT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR DEDICATED
WORK ON THIS MEASURE ON THEIR
HARD WORK THIS BILL RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING. WEAVER DID DILIGENTLY
WITH THE OPPOSITION AND REPORT
TO WORKING WITH OTHERS WHO COME
INTO SUPPORT AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL BRINGS US DOWN THE ROAD TO
A MAKING IT CLEARER. ABOUT HOW
LOCALITIES PROCESS AND SEE BONUS
APPLICATIONS IN A CONSISTENT
TIMELY WAY. THE DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATION PROCESS HAS BECOME
IN MANY PLACES LONG THAT ARE
JEWISH AND CAN LEAD TO PROJECT
DELAYS AND ULTIMATELY CATALYZE A
PROJECT'S DEMISE. AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE GIVES
ASSURANCES THE DEVELOPERS ON THE
STATUS OF THEIR DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATION BY REQUIRING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO REPORT BACK TO
DEVELOPERS.
A TIME THEIR APPLICATION IS
INCOMPLETE THE INCENTIVES THAT
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR. A LOCAL
AGENCY WILL INFORM THE DEVELOPER
OF THEIR ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE UNITS THE
PARKING RATIO.
INCENTIVES
SESSIONS WAIVERS ARE REDUCTIONS
IN DEVELOPMENT STANDARDS AND
WHETHER THE APPLICANT IS PROVIDE
ADEQUATE INFORMATION TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION.
SHOULD THE PROJECT DRASTICALLY
CHANGE AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE ALLOWS FLEXIBILITY FOR
LOCALS TO ADJUST THE AMOUNT OF
THE DENSITY BONUS PARKING RATIO
IS WAY RISEN CONCESSIONS. DEEMED
ELIGIBLE BASED ON THE CHANGES
DURING THE COURSE OF THE
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS BUILDS ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOMS EXCELLENT BILL AB TWENTY
FIVE OH ONE.
REQUIRED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
IDENTIFY A DENSITY BONUS
APPLICANT IF THEIR APPLICATION
IS COMPLETE WITHIN THIRTY DAYS.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR CERTAINTY
FOR THE DEVELOPER AND
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WHEN PROCESSING A DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATION.
THE BILL ALSO DECLARES A
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT OF
ESTABLISHING A UNIFORM PROCESS
FOR THE REVIEW OF DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATIONS
INCLUDING THE RESEARCH REQUEST
FOR INCENTIVES.
YADA YADA I IS A MATTER OF
STATEWIDE CONCERN AND APPLIES TO
ALL CITIES INCLUDING CHARTER
CITIES THE LEGISLATURE ETHICAL
SIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS A
PRIORITY AND TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE GIVE DEVELOPERS A
CERTAINTY AND INSURANCE OF
INCENTIVE TO DO SO. THIS BILL
HAD NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION AS
OF TODAY WE HAVE HEARD FROM ONE
CITY. ABOUT WE WORK ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THEM I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY MICHAEL
CUSUMANO A LOCAL DEVELOPER IN
BURBANK TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
TO TELL YOU WHY THIS BILL IS
NECESSARY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS MICHAEL CUSUMANO.
AS WE ALL KNOW OUR STATE IS IN A
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND WE ARE ESPECIALLY DEFICIENT
THE AVAILABILITY OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OUR STATE.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS CRISIS
YOU'VE BEEN ACTIVE LAWS SUCH AS
THE DENSITY BONUS LIE THAT
PROVIDE A PATHWAY TO THE
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY.
TO CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT NO ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COST.
MANY CITIES HOWEVER ESPECIALLY
THOSE CITIES THAT HAVE NOT MET
THEIR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
OBLIGATIONS.
FREQUENTLY DELAYED OR SIMPLY
REFUSED TO PROCESS HOUSING
PROJECTS.
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT WANT YOU
HOUSING BUILT THEIR CITY. AND
THEY CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
SACRAMENTO DICTATING TO THEM
THAT THEY MUST ALLOW FOR
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
TAKE THE CITY OF BURBANK FOR
EXAMPLE.
THE CITY OF BURBANK IS AT OVER
THIRTEEN THOUSAND NEW JOBS IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS.
IN ONLY FIFTY FIVE HOUSING
UNITS.
THE RESULT IS AN ACUTE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THAT CITY.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
CREATED LAW SPECIFICALLY TO
ALLOW FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IN COMMUNITIES LIKE BURBANK THAT
FALL SHORT OF MEETING THEIR
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT ALLOCATIONS.
BUT CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
PROVIDE.
DEFINED SUBMISSION REQUIREMENTS
OR TIME FRAMES FOR CITIES TO
PROCESS THESE APPLICATIONS.
AND IN REAL ESTATE DEVELOPMENT.
THE EASIEST WAY TO STOP A
PROJECT IS NOT TO DENY IT.
BUT JUST TO DELAY IT UNTIL IT
DIES ON ITS OWN.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE WILL
PROVIDE SPECIFIC GUIDELINES AND
REASONABLE TIME FRAMES FOR
CITIES TO REVIEW DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATIONS.
NOTE THAT THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES
TO PROJECTS SUBMITTED AS DENSITY
BONUS APPLICATIONS.
TO QUALIFY UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
HIGH.
HOUSING GUIDELINES.
IT IS NOT APPLY TO LUXURY
PROJECTS OFFICE BUILDING
PROJECTS OR OTHER PROJECTS THAT
DON'T HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
COMPONENT OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITHIN THEM.
AND ALL OF THESE DENSITY BONUS
APPLICATION PROJECTS ARE STILL
SUBJECT TO FULL ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW UNDER SEEK WHAT.
IF THE LEGISLATURE IS SERIOUS
ABOUT HAVING A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON THE HOUSING A BALANCED THAT'S
EVIDENCE IN OUR STATE.
IT MUST TAKE FURTHER ACTION TO
PROVIDE A MEANS FOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO PLAY A ROLE IN
CREATING A SOLUTION.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS THAT ARE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
JENNIFER SPECK ABOVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
SANDY GEORGE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE NOW IN FULL
SUPPORT.
ASSISTANCE AND I'LL BE OFF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INITIATE
ASSOCIATION AND.
REBECCA MARQUESS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
IF THEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION.
AND THOSE MONDAY FOR CALIFORNIA
BE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
SINGING NUN WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM.
THANK YOU YOUR FLATTERY
NOTWITHSTANDING MY.
.
CITY OF SANTA MONICA HAS OF
WITHIN THE LAST HOUR OR SO
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS OVER THE
ADMINISTRATIVE UC COSTS THAT
CITIES MIGHT. HAVE TO BEAR AS A
RESULT OF THIS LEGISLATION DATA.
WHEN I BROUGHT UP WITH YOU YOU
MAY BE UGLY SAID I'M HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE CITY ON THAT I
JUST WANNA SAY APPRECIATE THAT.
AND TO HOPE THEY'RE LISTENING.
SO THAT THEY KNOW I DID MY JOB
HERE AND I THINK I'M A YOU.
YOU.
HE YOU YOU MIGHT WANT TO
ADDRESS.
THE AUDI OUT IN YOUR CLOSING.
AND.
RICK RECALLING THAT.
THE.
AUTHOR OF THOSE LIES DEATH
WITHIN MY DISTRICT.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
THEN THE SECOND. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AND SECOND RACE SUMMER
COOLEY PROJECT CLOSE.
JUST THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT I
WOULD THINK CLEAN UP BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS EXCELLENT
BILL THAT RICHARD BLOOM.
HAD A FEW GO AUTHORED YOU.
IS ABLE TO BE FULLY IMPLEMENTED
AND SANTA MONICA HAS BEEN A WAS
FAR AS I KNOW A VERY GOOD
OPERATOR WHEN IT COMES TO
BUILDING HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SOME CITIES HAVE NOT.
AND THEY BUT FORTUNATELY I'M TRY
TO USE WHATEVER TOOLS THEY HAVE
BEEN LOOPHOLES THAT THEY HAVE TO
STOP HOUSING AND WE NEED THE
HOUSING AND THAT'S THE MODE GOT
TO BE OUR MOST IMPORTANT. A GOAL
SO I WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND.
THANKS FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
AND THANK YOU FOR.
ACKNOWLEDGING A SOME EVER
BLOOM'S BILL AND MAKE IT EVEN
BETTER.
SO I WILL BE THE.
ALSO BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY WITHOUT.
PLEASE SECRETARY TAKE ROLLED.
MOTION IS DO PASSING REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I WALDRON WALDRON
AYE BLOOM AYE AYE BLOOM AYE COPY
ARROW COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
STONE VOEPEL.
BILLS AT SIX ZERO THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO YOUR OTHER
BILL WHICH IS TWENTY NINE
ELEVEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
IT'S BEEN INCREASING WILL CLEAR
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WHILE FILES FIRE
SEASON IS NOW A YEAR ROUND
BATTLE AND THAT OUR CURRENT
POLICIES NEED TO BE REEVALUATED
AND UPDATED.
AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN.
TWENTY NINE ELEVEN IS AN EFFORT
TO ENSURE THAT CITIES FOUND
WITHIN HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES AND STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREAS HAVE THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO PREVENT AND REDUCE. THE
THREAT OF WILDFIRE AB TWENTY
NINE ELEVEN SEEKS TO PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR FIRE SAFETY
PLANNING EFFORTS AND LOCAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES STRENGTHENED
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS
AND CLARIFY A VEGETATION
CLEARANCE REQUIREMENT AROUND
UTILITY LINES. ALL ARE PROMOTING
HABITAT RESTORATION
GIVEN THE DEVASTATION OF THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WILDFIRE
SEASON IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
REEVALUATE AND UPDATE OUR
CURRENT FIRE SAFETY MEASURES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IN MY DISTRICT WAS LIKE MANY OF
YEARS FIRE IMPACTED OUGHT NOT IS
HORRIBLY IS A LOT OF YEARS BUT
THESE WILDFIRES HAVE SHOWN US
THAT WE DO HAVE GAPS. AND THAT
HOW WE DO OUR PLANNING DOES
IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO FIGHT
FIRES SO I'VE WE'VE BEEN TAKING
A LOOK AT A LOT OF THAT AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE REALLY
COMMON SENSE MEASURES. THAT WILL
HELP A LOT IN THE FUTURE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYWAY IT.
WELL.
MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY.
WHERE TWEENER ON THIS BILL WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US ON
OUR PROPOSED WEEKS WE OBVIOUSLY
TAKE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO?
HOPEFULLY GETTING TO SUPPORT
POSITION SAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF ANY AND QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
A SECOND MY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WE ARE.
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH OTHER
PARTICULARLY UTILITIES HAVE
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS WORKABLE
ENJOYABLE FOR THEM AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD I'D TO A SAW FIRST HAND
OF THE DEVASTATION FROM THE
FIRES THIS PAST YEAR. AND I AM
PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
SECRETARY CALDERON. THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM I HAVE THE ARROW COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
STONE VOEPEL.
BILLS.
BILLS UP FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME ON UP.
BUT COME IN YOU'LL BE PRESENTING
A. B. NINETEEN NINETY NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
WOULD EXPAND THE AUTHORITY OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
TO DEVELOPMENT PUBLIC BROADBAND
SERVICES WHILE PRESERVING NET
NEUTRALITY.
TO ENSURE THE INTERNET REMAINS
OPEN AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
BROADBAND ACCESS IS OF VITAL
IMPORTANCE TO THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AS WELL AS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE AN
IMPORTANT PARTNER IN ENSURING
THAT ITS BENEFITS ARE PAID
AVAILABLE TO EVERYONE.
CALIFORNIA LAW CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZES MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICTS AND PUBLIC UTILITY
DISTRICTS TO OPERATE THEIR OWN.
A BROADBAND NETWORKS BUT OTHER
FORMS OF INDEPENDENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HEALTH LIMITED
AUTHORITY TO DO SO. FOR EXAMPLE
COMMUNITY SERVICE DIVERT A
DISTRICT CST.
CAN INITIALLY PROVIDE THE
SERVICE BUT HAVE TO SEED OVER
THE AUTHORITY ONCE A PRIVATE AND
IF HE IS WILLING TO DEPLOY THE
SERVICE.
RESTRICTING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM BUILDING OUT THEIR OWN HIGH
SPEED NETWORKS IS THERE ARE
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
A CLOSING CALIFORNIA'S DIGITAL
DIVIDE.
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS TO
WORK ONLY THROUGH FORTY THREE
PERCENT OF THE POPULATION HAS
ACCESS TO BROADBAND IN THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS. OR IN AREAS THAT
ONLY HAVE ACCESS TO ONE PROVIDER
WILL WOULD THERE'S A LACK OF
ONGOING INVESTMENT.
NOW THE IDEA THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OUGHT TO PLAY A MORE
ACTIVE ROLE IN BUILDING OUT
LOCALLY OWNED BROADBAND NETWORKS
HAS ALSO BEEN WRITTEN THOUGH BY.
THE FACT THAT THEY EL FCC THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION A RECENTLY A TOOK
ACTION TO REPEAL THE NET
NEUTRALITY RUSE.
ON THE FORMER NET NEUTRALITY
ROUGE REQUIRED INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO OFFER EQUAL ACCESS
TO ALL WEB CONTENT WITHOUT
CHARGING CUSTOMERS FOR HIGHER
QUALITY DELIVERY. WHAT GIVING
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT TO
CERTAIN WEBSITES?
ACCORDING TO A RECENT SURVEY
CONDUCTED BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
MARYLAND MORE THAN EIGHTY
PERCENT OF VOTERS OPPOSED THE
FCC'S PLAN TO REPEAL ITS NET
NEUTRALITY ROUGE.
IT SHOULD BE THE STATE POLICY TO
TO UPHOLD THE TENETS OF AN OPEN
AT INTERNET BY REQUIRING
ADHERENCE.
THE CORE PRINCIPLES OF NET
NEUTRALITY THIS BILL IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE WITH A FIRM
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. AND
COMPETITION AFTER THE REPEAL OF
NET NEUTRALITY WHILE AUTHORIZING
THE EXPANSION OF PUBLIC
BROADBAND SERVICES. WELL WITH
THAT I A I LIKE TO TURN OVER TO
MY WITNESSES
RIGHT WELCOME.
THANK YOU AJ ERIC YOUR CURRY
ADVICE SHARE WALDRON.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S ERNESTO FALCONE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
ARE ALSO KNOWN AS EFF.
WHERE A CIVIL LIBERTIES LOOK
ORGANIZATION THE CHAMPIONS OF
FREE EXPRESSION PRIVACY AND
INNOVATION THROUGH OUR
LITIGATION PRACTICE?
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVELOPMENT AND.
GRASSROOTS ACTIVISM.
WE WERE WE WERE FOUND IN
NINETEEN NINETY AND AND
CURRENTLY FUNDED BY MORE THAN
FORTY ONE THOUSAND DUES PAYING
MEMBERS AND HAVE A FOLLOWING
THAT WOULD MILLION.
FOLLOWERS ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
OUR MISSION IS TO ENSURE THAT
THE RIGHTS AND FREEDOMS THAT WE
ENJOY OUR ENHANCES OUR USE OF
TECHNOLOGY GROWS.
I WANT TO THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHALL FOR MOVIE FOR LEGISLATION
THAT WILL PROMOTE THE ENTRY OF
COMMUNITY BROADBAND IN
CALIFORNIA WHILE HAVING THEM IN
HERE TO NETWORK NEUTRALITY.
I WANT TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
THE CONSUMER BENEFITS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
ENGAGING INTO THE BROADBAND
MARKET AND WHAT THAT WILL YIELD.
IN SHORT IT WILL INJECT
DESPERATELY NEEDED COMPETITION
IN THE HIGH SPEED INTERNET
MARKETPLACE.
TODAY MORE THAN HALF OF
AMERICANS HAVE ONE CHOICE
WHEN IT COMES BROADBAND EXCEEDS
TWENTY FIVE MEGABITS PER SECOND.
YEAH FIFTY FIVE COMMUNITIES IN
AMERICA ENJOY FIBER TO THE HOME
SERVICES THAT EXCEED THAT SPEED
BY A FACTOR OF FORTY.
AND AND THOSE ARE ALL COMMUNITY
BROADBAND PROJECTS.
IN FACT THE WORLD'S FASTEST
BROADBAND COMPANY
IS IN CHATTANOOGA TENNESSEE AND
IS RUN BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF VISITING
THAT FACILITY MYSELF EARLIER
THIS YEAR AND IT'S TRULY
REMARKABLE WHAT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WAS ABLE TO DO. AYE
AND TO LEARN THE HISTORY AS TO
WHY THE THE ENGAGED IN THAT
PROCESS ALTOGETHER.
AND SOMETHING I LEARNED FROM
THAT TRIP ARE FROM THE
LEADERSHIP TEAM THEIR.
PARTICULAR EXECUTIVE WHO WAS A
FORMER EIGHTEEN T. EXECUTIVE WAS
THAT CHATTANOOGA WAS CLASSIFIED
FROM HER OLD COMPANY AS A TIER
THREE CITY.
WHAT WAS THAT I'VE NEVER HEARD
OF THAT TIER THREE WOULD THAT
MEAN? IT SIMPLY MEANT THAT IT
WAS ONE OF THE CITIES THAT WAS
NEVER LIKELY TO RECEIVE ANSWER
PROPERTY INVESTMENT IN ORDER TO
UPGRADE THEIR NETWORK.
IN FACT TO CHATTANOOGA IF YOU
THINK ABOUT THAT THE POPULATIONS
OF POPULATION HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE OVER MEDIAN
INCOME OF FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
DOZENS OF LOCAL TOWNSHIPS AND
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA I SUSPECT
ARE IN THE SAME TIER THREE
STATUS AS CHATTANOOGA.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST PEOPLE A BIT THE LACK OF
HIGH SPEED BROADBAND COMPETITION
WE HAVE TODAY.
MARKETS WERE COMMUNITY BROUGHT
INTO FIGHTERS YOU'LL A SECOND
CHOICE RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
PRICE COMPETITION FOR THE
AVERAGE CONSUMER PAYS AROUND
SEVENTY DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
WORLD CLASS TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
SERVICE.
FOR DECADES ARE TELECOM POLICIES
A FOCUS ON WHAT'S CALLED
FACILITIES BASED COMPETITION
WERE NETWORKS COMPETE WITH OTHER
NETWORKS.
HOWEVER THE REALITY IS IS IT'S
BEEN YEARS SINCE BOTH GOOGLE AND
VERIZON WHICH ARE THE TWO MAJOR
PLAYERS COMMITTING TO FIREBIRD
FIBER TO THE HOME DEPLOYMENT.
HAVE TERMINATED THEIR
EXPANSIONS.
AND EIGHTEEN YEARS NEVER FULLY
COMMITTED TO A FIBRE HOME BUILT.
THESE WERE THE MAJOR PLAYERS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE THE DIRECT
COMPETITORS TO THE INCUMBENT
CABLE. COMPANIES LIKE COMCAST
AND CHARTER.
WITHOUT THOSE MAJOR PLAYERS WHAT
WE'RE LEFT WITH NOW ARE REGIONAL
ACTORS SUCH AS SONIC IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS GOING TO
FIVE REBUILT. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BUILDING EITHER
PUBLIC NETWORKS OR ENGAGING IN
SOME SORT OF PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP.
SO I ASK THE COMMITTEE FOR AYE
BILL FOR A BI NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. OUGHT TO FURTHER
INCENTIVIZE LOCAL COMPETITION BY
LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
IT'S TIME WE GIVE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE MATTERS IN
THEIR OWN HANDS SO THAT YOU IF
SHOULD THEY WISH TO PURSUE
OCCUPIED OF ALTERNATIVE THANK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JACK TO
SPEAK.
EDU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANTHONY
TANNER HOA THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
WERE IN FULL SUPPORT. JUST WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR IN A SNAP FROZE
HARD WORK ON THIS.
HOW SPECIAL DISTRICTS ARE?
CURRENTLY.
HAMPERED BY THE BY THE CURRENT
LAW. WHERE IF ANY OTHER PRIVATE
PROVIDER WANTS TO? GET EVEN
EXPRESS IS A WILLINGNESS TO SOME
POINT IN THE FUTURE.
PROVIDE THIS IMPORTANT SERVICE.
OUR OUR MEMBERS ARE HAMSTRUNG.
LOTS OF THIS WOULD WOULD BROADEN
THEIR THEIR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
THESE IMPORTANT SERVICES.
IT LOCALLY IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITY BOB WE THINK IT'S.
PRETTY SIMPLE PRETTY OBVIOUS
MEASURE AND WE THINK YOU.
AND AS FOR SPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SING NONE ARE THERE NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SOME MINERAL WALDRON. A FEW.
.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
HIGH I DON'T KNOW THE TECHNICAL
OF YOU SAYING TWENTY FIVE M.. P.
S. YEAH I'VE GOT TWENTY FIVE
MEGABITS PER SECOND THAT THE
DOWNLOAD SPEED.
YES WE WERE IN MY DISTRICT WHERE
I LIVE IS A MATTER OF FACT AND
THE WHOLE.
MY I HAVE A HUGE SECTION
PROBABLY EIGHTY PERCENT OF MY
DISTRICT IS RURAL.
MY SON TOOK IT TOOK HIM TWO
DAYS TO TRY TO DOWNLOAD AND NO
ONE ELSE COULD GET ON BECAUSE WE
HAD ONE POINT FIVE M.. YES.
NOW WE'VE TRIED UPGRADE TO THEY
CLAIMED FIFTEEN BUT I DON'T
THINK IT'LL BE.
THAT HIGH.
SO HOW DOES THAT AFFECT THE
DISTRICT LIKE THAT LET'S VERY
RURAL.
ARM AND SO.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST AYE AGNEW.
THE BASE SUCCESS STORIES IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ENGAGE IN THIS
OUR RULE COMMUNITIES ARE BRISTOL
VIRGINIA FOR EXAMPLE THE
POPULATION OF SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE. THEY HAVE GIGABIT
INTERNET SERVICE RIGHT THEY THEY
HAVE SERVICE SAID THAT DWARFS I
WILL WE HAVE BEEN IN MANY
METROPOLITAN AREAS.
IT'S IT'S PURELY A MATTER OF OF
YOU POLITICAL WILL I WILL IN
CAPABILITY OF OF YOUR HIRING
EXPERTISE NECESSARY. AND IT DOES
TAKE AN INVESTMENT AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY AYE THERE ARE LOTS OF
WILL COMMUNITIES OF IT INC FACE
WHAT YOU WOULD YOU TALK A KIND
OF FEELING DAY.
BEING LEFT IN THE STONE AGE
ALMOST AYE AND IN OR WILLING TO
TAX THEMSELVES AND WILLING TO TO
TAKE YOU TAKE MATTERS IN OUR OWN
HANDS.
SO I THINK THE REALITY IS
OUTSIDE OF OF OF HEAVY
SUBSIDIZATION SUBSIDIZATION FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND STATE
GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENGAGEMENT IN
THE SPACES IS THE LIKELY RESULT
A A THE LIKELY ONLY SALUTE
AND FOR FOR THEM.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS YES
SELECTED.
AMONG THE QUESTION OF CURIOSITY.
YOUR YOUR EXAMPLES OF RURAL
SUCCESS ARE OUT OF STATE GIVEN
THE CALIFORNIA ONES.
I KNOW I AND THAT MAY SPEAK TO
THE THE SOLUTION THAT THE BILL
IS AN ATTEMPT TO RESOLVE AYE IN
THOSE. IN FOR LIKE PERSON FOR
EXAMPLE THERE WASN'T ANY THIRD
SITUATION WHERE.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO SELL
SELL THE THE PROJECT OR OR LEASE
ACCESS TO A PRIVATE PARTY OR
SEEK PERMISSION EARNED SHERMAN
THERE A NEW PRIME PARTY WAS
GOING TO TO ENGAGE IN THAT
PLACE.
THEY ALREADY KNEW THAT WAS THE
SITUATION AND THEY GOT TO IT TO
TO BUILD OUT DIRECTLY BUT I
DON'T HAVE ANY. A SMALL RULE
CALIFORNIA CITIES THAT BEING
SAID THE.
THERE'S NOTHING MAGICALLY
DIFFERENT ABOUT BRISTOL VIRGINIA
VERSES LIKE A CALIFORNIA ROLL
CITY IN TERMS OF.
DEPLOYMENT AND AND BUILDING UP
THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
.
IT IS REALLY ABOUT WHETHER IT
WILL COMMUNITY WANTS IT TO TAKE
MATTERS IN THEIR OWN HANDS AND
ARE WILLING TO TO TAKE
ADVANCEMENT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT I BELIEVE I HAVE A
MOTION FROM SOME NO AND I'M
WASHING IT.
THE EMOTIONS THAT WERE BILL
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
A SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON.
WHICH I TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
DID THE INTENT OF THE BILL IS
NOT ESSENTIALLY TO ALLOW MORE
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENGAGE IN THIS
ACTIVITY. AND OUR AND OB. I
THINK ONE EXAMPLE THAT I WANT TO
CITED SAN FRANCISCO WHICH IS AN
ACTUAL IN THE PROCESS OF
BUILDING A. PUBLIC APART A
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP IN ORDER TO
BUILD OUT THEIR OWN UP.
BROADBAND NETWORK AND DIAL THE
DOT PROJECT ALSO MANDATES THAT
THEY COMPLY WITH THE NET
NEUTRALITY RULES SO THAT'S ONE
EXAMPLE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT.
DOT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
OF THAT GETTING ENGAGED IN THIS
IN THIS PROCESS
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AS YOU KNOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHILD THIS IS NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART.
FOR REAL BROADBAND AS MATTER OF
FACT.
MISTER LUCKY I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT OF CITY OF DAVIS
WHICH IS NOT FAR FROM HERE IS
LOOKING INTO THIS ALREADY AND
THEY WOULD LIKE I'M SURE THEY'LL
BE. VERY HAPPY WITH THIS BILL
GETS THROUGH.
I SUPPORT THIS BILLS OBJECTIVE
TO PROVIDE ANOTHER OPTION FOR
AND AND UNDERSERVED AREAS AND TO
BRIDGE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. ALSO
SUPPORT NET NEUTRALITY RULES
FOR BOTH THE PRODUCT PRIVATE
PROVIDERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PROVIDERS.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO. TO.
ENSURE THAT THE RULES OF FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE IN LINE WITH
THE RULES OF PRIVATE ISPS AND
THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY SECRETARY OF COLORADO
MUNICH HAITIANS AND CONVEYANCE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY KNOWS
STONE HUPO.
THE BILL'S UP FIVE TWO ONE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH EVERY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
IT LOOKS LIKE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR MISTER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU AS WELL AS
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B.
THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN. FOR
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR. WOULD
ALLOW IMMIGRANTS TO START AND
RUN BUSINESSES BY REQUIRING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ISSUE.
LICENCES TO BUSINESSES ARE TO
ALLOW THEM TO ACCEPT A
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
INDIVIDUAL TAX ID OR A MUNICIPAL
ID.
I KNOW EVERYONE IN OUR
LEGISLATURE KNOWS HOW MUCH THE
ECONOMIC SUCCESS OUR STATE IS
DEPENDENT ON AND HAS BEEN THE
RESULT OF OUR. IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES WHO CONTRIBUTE
THIRTY TWO PERCENT OF OUR
STATE'S GDP. ARE WHO MAKE UP ONE
OUT OF THREE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF
ALL NEW BUSINESS FOUNDERS.
UNFORTUNATELY ABOUT HALF OF THE
CITIES IN OUR STATE REQUIRE AN
APPLICANT FOR A LOCAL BUSINESS
LICENSE.
TO PROVIDE A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER THIS IS BEN A SIGNIFICANT
BARRIER TO MANY CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE SEEKING OPPORTUNITY. TO
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP.
THIS BILL WOULD BENEFIT BUSINESS
OWNERS SOLE PROPRIETORS
INCLUDING.
CAFES AND SMALL RETAIL OWNERS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN THOSE
IN PROFESSIONAL SERVICES. THIS
BILL BUILT ON PREVIOUS STATE
LAWS THAT ALLOW APPLICANTS FOR
PROFESSIONAL LICENSES TO PROVIDE
A FEDERAL ID NUMBER.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
LAW WHICH AUTHORIZES STATES TO
MAKE PROFESSIONAL AND COMMERCIAL
LICENSES AVAILABLE TO IMMIGRANTS
REGARDLESS OF STATUS. ALSO JUST
NOTE THE BILL PROTECTS THE
NUMBERS COLLECTED BY A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FROM DISCLOSURE
EXCEPT AS REQUIRED TO ADMINISTER
THE PROGRAM OR TO COMPLY. WITH
STATE LAW OR A FEDERAL COURT
ORDER AND SO WITH THAT LIKE TURN
IT OVER TO OUR SPONSORS.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU AND CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS MICHELLE
JACOB AND I'M AND STAFF ATTORNEY
AT LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA. WHICH IS A CO SPONSOR OF
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR.
THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE IS
COMMITTED TO ENSURING CIVIL
RIGHTS IN THE ECONOMY.
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
EXPANDING ACCESS
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL AROSE
FROM OUR WORK WITH IMMIGRANT
BUSINESS OWNER CLIENTS.
AND FROM PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
WHERE WE LEARNED THAT MANY
LOCALITIES REQUIRE SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS ON LOCAL
BUSINESS LICENSE APPLICATIONS?
IMMIGRANTS BRING INNOVATION AND
CULTURAL DIVERSITY TO OUR
ECONOMY THROUGH LOCAL
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
HOWEVER THE CURRENT RIGHT LOCAL
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT CREATES A
CONFUSING INCONSISTENT PATCHWORK
FOR IMMIGRANT BUSINESS OWNERS.
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
GO A LONG WAY TO REMOVING
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS FOR HIM AGAIN
CALIFORNIANS.
WILL LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR LONG
TERM ECONOMIC INCLUSION AND WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR STATES
CONTINUED ECONOMIC RECOVERY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JEANETTE THIS
OF I'M THE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER. AYE
WE'RE PROUD TO GO SPONSOR THESE
EFFORTS TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO
BUSINESS OWNERSHIP FOR
IMMIGRANTS OF THIS BILL REFLECTS
CALIFORNIA'S OPPORTUNITY TO
ADVANCE POLICIES THAT ARE
INCLUSIVE ARE IMMIGRANT
WORKFORCE AND REFLECT THE STRONG
ENTREPRENEURIAL SPIRIT. OF
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL AND STATE
LAWS THAT FULLY INTEGRATE
IMMIGRANTS INTO OUR ECONOMY AND
OUR PUBLIC LIFE WHILE ALSO
SUPPORTING REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE.
IT'S ALSO CONSISTENT WITH
EFFORTS TO PROTECT THE PRIVACY
OF OUR RESIDENTS IN MAKING SURE
THAT WE CONTINUE. TO SUPPORT
RESIDENTS AGAINST EFFORTS TO
PROTECT THAT TO. BREAK UP
FAMILIES EXCUSE ME AND DEPORT
CALIFORNIANS WORK CRITICAL PART
OF OUR SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
FABRIC WE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHIU FOR HIS CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP AND HEARD YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS EFFORT WHICH
JUSTICE. INCLUSION AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND OTHER OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE A DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SING NINE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL.
HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM.
THE SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON.
OKAY.
WHICH I CLOSE RESPECT WE ASK
FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY WELL I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
EVERY RESIDENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
HAVE A BUSINESS SON I'M.
.
HAPPY THAT YOU'RE BRINGING THIS
HEART AND I WILL SUPPORT A BILL
TODAY THANK YOU. SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ADWARE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE CABALLERO
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE STONE VOEPEL O..
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR MUCH OKAY
MISTER CHIU.
LET'S GO WITH THIRTY THIRTY
SEVEN HOW'S THAT SOUND. GREAT
SUBSTRATE FIRST TIME GONNA START
BY. BY ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN THE ANNOUNCES.
ONE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
CHAIR ARE AND YOUR STAFF ON THIS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES.
RAISED BY THE OPPOSITION.
AS WELL AS TO ENSURE AS I KNOW
THE CHAIR.
WOULD WANNA MAKE SURE THAT OF
THIS BILL IS ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE.
.
WE ALL KNOW THAT CALIFORNIANS IN
THE MIDST OF THE WORST HOUSING
CRISIS IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP TO RECREATE
REDEVELOPMENT AS A TOOL TO FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ON A SMALLER SCALE AND
WITH SIGNIFICANT STATE OVERSIGHT
COMPARED TO FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT.
AFTER PROP THIRTEEN FORMER
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
WERE A FUNDAMENTAL FUNDING TOOL
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE HOUSING. A AT
THE TIME OF THEIR LIMITATION
RDAS REQUIRED TO SPEND A BILLION
DOLLARS TO FUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING STATEWIDE EVERY YEAR.
THIS BILL WLL ALLOW THE CITY
TOOK RECREATE REDEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOUSING
AGENCIES WITH THIRTY PERCENT OF
THE MONIES. GENERATED IN THE
PROJECT AREA TO GO TO FIND HUNT
DOT TO TO FIND HOUSING.
WHILE ALL TAXING ENTITIES THAT
RECEIVE PROPERTY TAXES CITIES
COUNTIES AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ARE REQUIRED UNDER A
CONSTITUTION TO PARTICIPATE. THE
BILL WOULD MAKE THE COUNTY AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS HOLE THROUGH
PASS THROUGH PAYMENTS.
WHILE THE STATE WOULD BACK FILL
FUNDS DIVERTED THROUGH SCHOOLS
UNDER PROP NINETY EIGHT
OBLIGATIONS.
A NEW AGENCY.
WOULD BE ABLE TO APPLY TO THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL FOR
REVIEW OF WHETHER IT'S ACTIVITY
SUPPORT STATE GOALS.
ARE THE SGC WOULD MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WHO WOULD DETERMINE
THE FINAL APPROVAL.
AND SPECIFICALLY WHETHER.
THE EXPENDITURES OF A NEW
DISTRICT ARE IS UNDER A CAP ON
HOW MUCH THE STATE COULD
CONTRIBUTE EVERY YEAR TO ENSURE
SOME PATROLS ON THE SIZE OF NEW
REDEVELOPMENT.
TO AVOID THE AGREE JUST ABUSES
OF SOME FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES
A NUMBER OF SAFEGUARDS.
INCLUDING ROBUST ANTI
DISPLACEMENT POLICIES RECORD
KEEPING REQUIREMENTS INDEPENDENT
ANNUAL AUDITS AND HARSH
FINANCIAL PENALTIES.
WANT TO THANK OF THE WORKING
GROUP THAT REFLECTED A LOT OF
THE DIVERSITY OF OUR LEGISLATURE
OF WHO ARE THE JOINT AUTHORS OF
THIS BILL. AND DATA FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE WORK HARD TO
BRING A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
REESTABLISH REDEVELOPMENT. OF
BUT DO IT IN A WAY THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE AND A MORE LIMITED
SKILL FOCUSED ON OUR STATES
PRIORITIES AT THIS TIME.
A WITH THAT LIKE TO TURN IT OVER
TO.
MY JOINT AUTHORS MR BLUE.
THANK YOU FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I'M HONORED TO BE.
I JOIN AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
THANK MISTER CHIU SEARLE
ALLOWING. ME TO BE IN THAT
POSITION I CANNOT STRESS HOW
IMPORTANT THIS BILL IS TO
HELPING US REBUILD OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING STOCK.
THE LOSS OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES HAS DIRECTLY
CONTRIBUTED. TO OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SHORTAGE AND THE GROWING
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN OUR
CITIES THAT. TRULY GROWS WORSE
EVERYDAY.
LIKE YOU I SERVED IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SAW THE IMPACT
THAT REDEVELOPMENT DOLLARS HAD
ON MY COMMUNITY AND OTHER CITIES
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME TALKING
ABOUT PUSHING CITIES TO BUILD
HOUSING. AND ESPECIALLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SIMPLY CAN'T BILL BE
BUILT WITHOUT GOVERNMENT'S HELP
AT THE SAME TIME IF THE CITY'S
MOTIVATED TO BUILD THAT HOUSING.
THEY CAN'T DO IT IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDING AB THREE OH
THREE SEVEN WILL RESTORE SOME OF
THOSE FUNDS.
AND HELP LOCAL SPILLED THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WE ALL
NEED. AND AVOID THE PITFALLS OF
THE FORMER REDEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT.
OF OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN MAGNAT LIGHTHOUSE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU KEITH ON THE BEHALF
CALIFORNIA PURPOSES HAITIANS
PORT.
NICCOLO DELUCA HERE WE HAVE THE
CITY OF EVERY VILLAIN SUPPORT.
MADISON DRY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
TIFFANY PHANTOM HALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING SUPPORT.
AND THE OTHER SUPPORT.
OF.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TACK
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF.
TODAY WITH THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION BUT ALSO.
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF BOB NAY
OR AND REPRESENTING FEEL STAT
AND COMPANY AS WELL HE COULDN'T
BE HERE WITH US TODAY.
.
MEMBERS THE VOTER APPROVAL
REQUIREMENT IS PROBABLY ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
WITH REDEVELOPMENT AS IS NOT A
SURPRISE. EITHER TO THE AUTHOR
OR REGARDING ANY OF THE BILLS.
PERTAINING TO REDEVELOPMENT
THAT HAVE COME UP BAD BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
HOUSING COMMITTEE THIS YEAR.
.
THE BUSINESS MODEL OF
REDEVELOPMENT PART FRANKLY IS TO
FLOAT BONDS AGAINST FUTURE
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE AND USE
THAT MONEY TO BUY A PROPERTY
USUALLY THROUGH EMINENT DOMAIN.
WE'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT BOTH
TESTS AS WELL AS TACK IT'S TAX
INCREMENT FINANCE IN GENERAL
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO VOTER
APPROVAL. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT POTENTIALLY TAKING
TAX REVENUE FROM OTHER LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
THOSE ARE TAXPAYER DOLLARS ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND.
YOU KNOW HOW.
BUT BEFORE YOU ISSUE BONDS THE
COULD LAST
YOU KNOW ANYWHERE FROM THIRTY TO
FORTY FIVE YEARS IS
PARDON AND AN IMPERATIVE WE
WOULD ARGUE CELL WITHOUT THAT
BEING IN THE BASQUE FOR AND
ABOUT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TERRY BURDEN
ON BEHALF OF S. HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA LET ME START BY
SAYING I APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHORS.
AMENDMENTS AND THE DIRECTION
THIS BILL IS HEADED WE.
WERE OPPOSED TO THE ORIGINAL
VERSION THE BILL.
WE THINK IT'S MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
PRINCIPALLY A COUPLE OF CONCERNS
WE HAVE IS IS ENSURING THAT THE
LOCAL AGENCIES.
WHO AREN'T NECESSARILY PART OF
THE PLANNING PROCESS OR
RECIPIENTS OF THE BENEFIT OF
THIS BILL ARE HELD HARMLESS?
AND ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
MUCH LARGER.
REQUIREMENT ON LOW AND MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING.
TO AVOID SOME OF THE PRIOR
SITUATIONS WE GOT IN WITH
REDEVELOPMENT.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS TO SPILL MY
FOUR THINK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANTHONY TANNER
HELL CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
HOW VERY ENCOURAGED AND?
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR.
A BRING FORTH THESE AMENDMENTS
HOW ONCE HE OWN IMPRINT. ON MY
ORGANIZATIONAL BE REVIEWING THEM
AND GOING FORWARD LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING IN GOOD
FAITH WORKED THE AUTHORING A
STAFF.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS START THE JOBS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALIGN MY COMMENTS
LARGELY BUT THE AND OTHER POST
MUST AMENDED POSITIONS ALREADY
STATED. A DEAFENING APPRECIATE
BUT WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
LANGUAGE I THINK WE'RE GETTING
REALLY CLOSE WE NEED YOU A FINE
TOOTH COMB REVEAL I MET ALSO THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS POINTING OUT.
AMENDMENTS A THROUGH E. THINK
THOSE ARE ALL APPROPRIATE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO GO AND THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DOUG SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THE DO APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS IN THE ONGOING
WORK AND AS WE WILL LOOK THROUGH
THOSE WHO LOOK FOR TO WORK ON
AUTHOR AND STEAM. THANK YOU.
HAS LARGER MEMBERS JOINED OF
ARSON PATH URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO HOFFA OPPOSE US
AMENDED POSITION. LIKE THE OTHER
WAY BILL'S GOING AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS AND HOPEFULLY GET TO
A POINT OF THE MOVIE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
RATTING ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY THE.
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR AND THE
WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE ON
AMENDMENT SO FAR THAT WE. NEED
TO SEE THE FINAL LANGUAGE WE
HAVE A FEW REMAINING TECHNICAL
CONCERNS BUT WE'RE HOPEFUL
CONFIDENT WE CAN NOW WE CAN GET
THERE. THANK YOU.
THE CHRISTIE FOR A WITH A THREE
VALLEY'S MISCIBLE WATER DISTRICT
WE ALSO HAVE OPPOSE LESS THE
MINUTE POSITION. AND WE HAVE
SIMILAR CONCERNS AS THE AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
THE WILL HONOR WITH THEIR
COMMENTS BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RE OF
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
CHIU THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL AS
WELL AS ALL OF THE NUMEROUS
JOINT AUTHORS.
OTHER PART OF IT QUESTION.
HOW WILL SPECIAL DISTRICTS BE
AFFECTED BY BY YOUR BILL?
FOR SAID THIS BILL SO THE INTENT
OF A BILL WAS TO.
MAKE SURE THE SPECIAL TO SIX OR
HAVE HOPE ARE HELD HOLD.
AND THE I WANT TO JUST TAKE THIS
MOMENT TO CLARIFY I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING THAT I'M ACCEPTING THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. ARE
WHICH ADDRESS A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY FOLKS
WHO WERE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED
AND SPECIFICALLY UP WHAT WE ARE
DOING ANY AMENDMENTS THE
INITIAL.
LANGUAGE THAT WE HAD HAD MADE IT
OPTIONAL ABOUT WHETHER A LOCAL
JURISDICTION.
WOULD BE ALLOWED.
TO HAVE PASTORS FOR THE OTHER
TAXING ENTITIES THAT COULD
INCLUDE THE SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THE AMENDMENTS ARE THAT THE
CHAIR HAS ASKED FOR.
THAT WERE HAPPY TO ACCEPT WOULD
REQUIRE THE NEW ENTITY.
PROVIDE PASSERS FOR COUNTIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS SO IT'S JUST
NOT OPTIONAL IT WILL HAPPEN AND
UP HOPEFULLY WITH THAT.
AFTER EVERYONE HAS A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE IT WILL
ADDRESS IT ONCE CONCERNS SO THAT
WE CAN PUT.
THESE CONCERNS TO BED BUT THAT
IS INTO YOU ANSWERED MY SECOND
QUESTION IS WELL SO FANTASTIC A
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT IT APPEARS AS
THOUGH YOU'VEBEEN WORKING. AND
GOODWILL WITH OPPOSITION AND BY
THEIR EXPRESSION OF OPTIMISM
ABOUT CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU.
IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH THEY'RE
WELCOMING AT THAT THIS BILL
WOULD MEAN FOR NICE SUPPORT. BY
THIS BILL TODAY
APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOUR OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SO.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY
COUNCILMEMBER GRAYSON.
HAVE A SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
A AGAIN WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND YOUR STAFF FOR.
YOU'RE REALLY GOOD FEEDBACK ON
THIS AND THAT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION WE KNOW
THAT OUR. OUR CITY CENTER
LOCALITIES LOST AN IMPORTANT
TOOL WHEN REDEVELOPMENT WENT
AWAY AND I'VE SPOKEN TO ALMOST
EVERY MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
BRING BACK OF SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD. PAULA AND FOR
ANY MEMBERS PARTICULARLY ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE WHO MAY
HAVE QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS LOOK
FOR TO ENGAGE IN YOU THROUGH THE
PROCESS BUT I DO HOPE WE CAN
MOVE THIS FORWARD. OUGHT TO TO
TIP TO BUILD A CONSENSUS VEHICLE
TO BRING BACK A A MUCH NEEDED
TOOL FOR OUR CITIES.
THANK YOU.
IN THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE I KNOW THIS WAS A
ROUGH ROAD.
BUT I THINK WE ALL DILIGENTLY
WORKED ON IT AND I APPRECIATE MY
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS YOUR STAFF
ON GETTING THIS. AUTHORED
THROUGH BECAUSE SOME.
THIS IS REALLY NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART SO. SO RUDE TO REQUIRE
SGC TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ANY CITY OR COUNTY
THAT WANTS TO SEPARATE.
RIA AND TO SEACM AND TO REQUIRE
SGC TO APPROVE PROJECTS THAT
EQUITABLY REPRESENT RURAL.
SUBURBAN AND URBAN COMMUNITIES
AS WELL AS ENSURE EQUITABLE
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION I WANTED
SURE THAT THE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES WHO LONG.
WHO LONGER HAVE COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT STAFF WHO NO LONGER
HAVE COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT STAFF
WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF CREATING RIA? IF THEY CHOOSE
TO DO SO MANY OF OUR STAFF IN
SMALL COMMUNITIES ARE GONE AND
SO IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
KINDA GET. UP TO SPEED AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING TO US
ON THAT AND I'LL BE OF
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU.
SECRETARY CALDERON.
THE MOTION AS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WE ARE CURRY
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO COOLEY. COOLEY AYE
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO STONE VOEPEL.
THE BILL NEEDS ONE VOTE AND WE
HAVE MANY MISSING AS YOU CAN
TELL THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER.
WELCOME MR HARPER.
WELL THANK YOU WELL MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY. THIS BIPARTISAN
MEASURE WILL AUTHORIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE CONTRACT WITH
THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION. COMMONLY REFERRED TO
THE YET IT HAS THE YET PPC. FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF LOCAL CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND
GOVERNMENT ETHICS LAWS
THE EPIC BE SEE AND FORCE THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT IN IS THE
MAIN LAW THE GOVERNOR'S THAT
STATE ELECTION CAMPAIGNS AND
GOVERNMENT ETHICS.
THE MAY IMPOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
FINES AGAINST THOSE WHO VIOLATE
THE ACT LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION
COLLECTED MORE THAN ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN FINES.
FOR ELECTED OFFICIALS LOBBYIST
POLITICAL DONORS AND OTHERS IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
EVEN THOUGH THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ADOPT THEIR OWN ORDINANCES TO
GOVERN CAMPAIGNS FOR LOCAL
POLITICAL OFFICE.
THE F. SEE CURRENTLY HAS NO
AUTHORITY OVER THOSE ELECTIONS
INSTEAD AND FORSMAN OF THESE
ORDINANCES TYPICALLY LEFT TO THE
CITY ATTORNEY OR. THE COUNTY
DID.
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
SINCE MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LACK THE EXPERIENCE IN
INVESTIGATING OR PROSECUTING
CAMPAIGN VIOLATIONS THERE IS
LITTLE TO NO ENFORCEMENT
SOMETIMES THE QUESTION IS
MOTIVATION.
IN RECENT YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED FOR BILLS EXTENDING
AUTHORIZATION A IN A FEW CASES
TWO DIFFERENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE CONTRACT WITH THE I. PPC.
FOR ENFORCEMENT OF THEIR
CAMPAIGN FINANCE ORDINANCES
EACH BILL HAS RECEIVED NEAR
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THIS BILL GIVES GOVERNMENTS THE
ABILITY TO BRING A COST
EFFECTIVE EXPERIENCED
INDEPENDENT AND IMPARTIAL ENTITY
TO INVESTIGATE CAMPAIGN FIND
FINANCES. WERE GOVERNMENT ETHICS
VIOLATIONS AND BRING ACTION
AGAINST THESE VIOLATORS IN HIS
COURSE COMPLETELY VOLUNTARY FOR
THOSE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT
COME TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY IS JACK WAGNER FROM
COMMON CAUSE.
WELCOME JACK รณ GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND MY
NAME IS JACK WAGNER.
OF COMMON CAUSES PROUD SPONSOR
OF AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY WHICH
PROVIDE PROVIDE AN EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT OPTION FOR LOCAL
CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND ETHICS
ORDINANCES AT NO COST THE STATE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THERE NO
CAMPAIGN FINANCE REGULATIONS
OTHER THAN DISCLOSURES THAT
APPLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
HOWEVER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DO
HAVE THE POWER TO ENACT THEIR
OWN CAMPAIGN FINANCE ORDINANCES.
MANY DO SO AS MORE THAN A
HUNDRED LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
ADOPTED THEIR OWN LOCAL CAMPAIGN
FINANCE ORDINANCES WHICH
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
APPLAUDS.
OF THESE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MANY
OF THE LARGEST SUCH AS ORANGE
COUNTY IN THE CITIES OF LOS
ANGELES IN OAKLAND.
HAVE CREATED ETHICS COMMISSIONS
TO EFFECTIVELY ENFORCE THEIR
ORDINANCES.
MOST JURISDICTIONS HOWEVER
CANNOT AFFORD TO FUND AND STAFF
THEIR OWN ETHICS CAN.
FOR THE SMALL AND MID SIZE
CITIES AND COUNTIES LOCAL
CAMPAIGN ORDINANCE ENFORCEMENT
FALLS TO THE CITY ATTORNEY OR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY RESPECTIVELY.
AS A RESULT LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
TENDS TO BE RARE AS ASSEMBLYMAN
HARPER MENTIONED.
CITY ATTORNEY'S INDIA IS DO NOT
TYPICALLY HAVE MUCH EXPERTISE
ENFORCING CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS
AND THEY HAVE OTHER PRIORITIES
COMPETING FOR THEIR ATTENTION.
FOR EXAMPLE A CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT VIOLATION IS
UNLIKELY TO MERIT DE A RESOURCES
FOR PROSECUTION WHEN COMPARED TO
A VIOLENT CRIME.
ADDITIONALLY THERE IS ALSO A
RISK OF APPARENT POLITICAL BIAS
IF AN APPOINTED CITY ATTORNEY
BRINGS A SUIT AGAINST A NON
INCUMBENT OR IF ELECTED DISTRICT
ATTORNEY BRINGS CHARGES AGAINST
A POLITICAL RIVAL.
AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ALLOWS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT A
BETTER MODEL FOR LOCAL CAMPAIGN
ORDINANCE ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE THE I PP C. SPECIALIZES
IN CAMPAIGN ENFORCEMENT AND USES
AN ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS
AB PPC ENFORCEMENT PROVIDE
STREAMLINED AND EFFICIENT
EDUCATION ENFORCEMENT AT A
FRACTION OF THE COST OF SETTING
UP AN INDEPENDENT ETHICS CAN.
MOREOVER THEFT PPC IS RESPECTED
AS AN IMPARTIAL BODY MAKING
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS LESS
CONTROVERSIAL MOVE THE BILL.
IN CONCLUSION AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY PROVIDES AN IMPORTANT
FORCE AN OPTION TO MAKE LOCAL
CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND ETHICS
ORDINANCES MORE EASILY AND
EFFECTIVELY ENFORCEABLE.
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE IS PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND WE
STRONGLY URGE AND I BOTH THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RETAIN
HUTCHINGS ITALY CALIFORNIA
CITIES ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THERE IS
SOME SOMEWHAT OF AN INHERENT.
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IN YOU DO
HAVE A D. A. THAT.
ALSO ACTS AS THE POLITICAL
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER WE THINK
THIS IS A.
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
ALLOWS.
CITIES TO CONTRACT REFUGEES
SERVICES COST NEUTRAL WHEN WHEN.
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SING NONE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WALDRON THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WOULD TRY TO CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN OUR FAVOR THIS MEASURE
THAT THAT HELPS A BRING FORWARD
I'VE GOOD ENFORCEMENT PRACTICES
SAID THAT ARE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALL SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY
THANK YOU OKAY US SECRETARY TAKE
THE ROLE IN A MOTION IS TO PASS
AND WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS ACT WE ARE
CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE BLOOM AYE
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO COOLEY
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
LACKEY I'VE LACKEY AYE STONE
PHOTO.
BILLS UP FIVE ZERO GRADUATIONS
LET'S MOVE ON TO SOMEWHERE
DAILY.
A ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B.
THREE ZERO SIX EIGHT.
KARMA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THIS BILL HAS TO DO WITH.
THE ABILITY OF COUNTY AUDITOR'S.
TO HIRE ATTORNEYS TO HIRE THEIR
OWN LEGAL COUNSEL.
COUNTY AUDITOR CONTROLLERS PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN PROTECTING
TAXPAYERS.
IN EVALUATING THE FINANCIAL
DECISIONS AND SPENDING WITHIN
THEIR COUNTIES.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME MONITOR
CONTROLLERS HAVE FACED
RETALIATION AND INTIMIDATION
FROM COUNTY OFFICIALS AFTER THEY
QUESTIONED THE LEGALITY OF
CERTAIN PAYMENTS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES AUDITOR
CONTROLLER IS THE ABILITY TO
SEEK OUTSIDE COUNSEL.
WHEN A CONFLICT OF OPINION AND
OR CONFLICT OF INTEREST BETWEEN
THE AUDITOR CONTROLLER AND
COUNTY COUNCIL ARISES.
IN ADDITION THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS
TO SUPPORT AUDITOR CONTROLLERS
AS THEY PROVIDE OBJECTIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THE FINANCIAL
DECISIONS WITHIN THEIR COUNTIES.
FREE FROM FEAR AND INTIMIDATION.
WITH ME TODAY AS THE BILL'S
SPONSOR ORANGE COUNTY'S ELECTED
AUDITOR CONTROLLER MISTER ERIC
WOOLERY.
AGAIN THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR MADAM VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ERIC WOOLERY AND I AM A
SPONSOR OF AB THREE ZERO SIX
SAY.
HAS THE INDEPENDENTLY ELECTED
AUDITOR CONTROLLER OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
MY OFFICE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVALUATING ALL CLAIMS AND
CHARGES SUBMITTED TO THE COUNTY
AND FOR ISSUING ALL COUNTY
PAYMENTS.
IN THIS ROLE I HAVE FOUND
INCIDENTS WERE HAVING ACCESS TO
OUTSIDE COUNSEL WOULD HAVE
EITHER SERVED AS A DETRIMENT.
A DETERRENT.
TO QUESTIONABLE ACTIONS OR ALLOW
ME TO BETTER CHALLENGE
QUESTIONABLE ACTIONS.
FOR INSTANCE MY OFFICE DELAYED
PAYMENT UP ON HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER
FUNDED MAILERS. THAT TO MEMBERS
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WANTED TO SEND TO
VOTER SHORTLY BEFORE THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN ELECTIONS.
I WANTED CLEARANCE FROM THE APP
PPC BUT WAS INSTEAD COERCED BY
THE COUNTY COUNCIL TO MAKE THE
MAKE PAYMENT ON THESE PRE
ELECTION MAILERS.
THESE MAILERS WERE SO EGREGIOUS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE UNANIMOUSLY
PASSED S. B. FORTY FIVE WHICH
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW
LAST YEAR.
TO SEVERELY RESTRICT THESE
MAILERS.
AND ANOTHER INCIDENTS MY OFFICE
ATTEMPTED TO WITHHOLD A FOUR
YEAR RETROACTIVE PENSION PAYMENT
FOR A THIRD MEMBER OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
WHILE WE SOUGHT INFORMATION ON
THE LEGALITY OF THIS PAYMENT.
WHEN THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
INVESTIGATORS CAME TO MY OFFICE
TO DEMAND THAT MY STAFF MAKE THE
PENSION PAYMENT WHILE I WAS OUT
FOR A SCHEDULED MEDICAL
PROCEDURE.
THE COUNTY COUNCIL REFUSED TO
OFFER ANY ADVICE TO MY
EMPLOYEES.
AB THREE ZERO SIX EIGHT FIXES A
CATCH TWENTY TWO FOR COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLERS THAT RESULTS
IN A GAP IN STATE LAW.
THE GOVERNMENT CODE SPECIFICALLY
SAYS THAT COUNTY COUNCIL IS THE
LEGAL ADVISER TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT CODE DOES NOT
ALLOW ME TO HIRE OUTSIDE COUNSEL
WITHOUT THE CONSENT OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE COUNTY ASSESSOR AND THE
COUNTY SHERIFF HAVE A REMEDY FOR
THIS PROBLEM.
THAT IS NOT AVAILABLE TO MY
OFFICE
AB THREE ZERO SIX EIGHT WOULD
ALLOW ME ACCESS TO THE SAME
PROCESS THAT IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO THE ASSESSOR AND
SHARE OF.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL ALLOWS
THE COUNTY AUDITOR CONTROLLERS
TO GO TO COURT. TO OBTAIN
OUTSIDE COUNSEL WHEN EIGHT WE
BELIEVE THERE IS A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST WITH COUNTY COUNCIL.
ADDITIONALLY AB THREE ZERO SIX
EIGHT IMPROVES THE EXISTING
PROCESS BY HAVING THE PRESIDING
JUDGE SELECT SPECIFIC COUNCIL.
RATHER THAN THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SELECTING THE
COUNCIL. WHEN THE PRESIDING
JUDGE RULES THERE IS A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTY AUDITOR'S IS A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THE ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AUDITOR'S.
THE AUDITOR CONTROLLERS OF FORTY
SIX COUNTIES AND SEVERAL
SHERIFF'S SUPPORT AB SIX ZERO OR
THREE ZERO SIX EIGHT.
COAUTHORS OF AB THREE ZERO SIX
EIGHT INCLUDE MEMBERS OF BOTH
PARTIES AND BOTH LEGISLATIVE
HOUSES.
I HOPE WE WILL BE ABLE TO USE AB
THREE ZERO SIX SAY TO TRY TO
ALLEVIATE THE CATCH TWENTY TWO
AND STATE LAW.
AT FOUR OUR ABILITY TO OBTAIN
LINGLE LEGAL COUNSEL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BIPARTISAN GOOD
GOVERNMENTS.
PROGRAM AB THREE ZERO SIX A.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
PEOPLE.
PART OF THE BILL.
WHAT'S.
YES.
.
I'M.
ROBERTS.
DARK.
AND.
IN THE IN TWO.
THOUSAND FORD.
TINA IRA.
REALLY TIRED.
AFTER ALL.
MOST.
THIRTY.
YEARS AND AS A.
OUR IS.
TERROR IN.
SUTTER COUNTY.
AND MY.
INTERESTED IN THIS.
BILL.
STEMS FROM MY EXPERIENCE AND
SUTTER COUNTY.
TRYING.
TO GET.
LEGAL.
SO.
CORD IN.
TO.
IF THOUSAND FOUR AFTER THE
COUNTY.
BOARD OF.
SUPER.
VISORS.
APPROVED.
PENSION ANNIE AND.
PRES.
WITH.
NO.
FINANCIAL. ANALYSIS HAS THREE.
ACQUIRED.
BY COUNTY. RULES.
I BECAME A CONFLICT WITH.
THE.
FORD AND
TO.
THOUSAND.
FIVE THE DISTRICT.
.
TURNING.
CHARGED.
ME TOO.
WITH.
IF TEN ACCU VARIATIONS AND
FURTHER SWAY THE GRAND.
JERRY TO CHARGE THIRTY.
IN.
DIED.
BUT AS AS LONG AS WELL.
AS.
TRIED YOU MY. OF ASSISTANT.
RHONDA HAD.
NEITHER LIVE TO.
ACCU.
STATIONS.
AFTER.
SPENDING.
APPROXIMATELY.
LEE FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY.
THOUSAND.
DOLLARS AND MY ASSISTANT
SPENDING SIXTY.
THOUSAND.
DOLLARS.
THE.
WITH
SOME FURTHER SUASION BY THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT TELLING
AND. HALF
TO.
PROVE CRIMINAL IN TAX.
TO CONVICT.
A HE HE. DROPPED.
FOR THE.
CHARGES.
AND LATER HE WAS QUOTED IN.
THE NEWS.
PAPER AS.
SAYING HE HE ONLY.
DID.
TO IT TO BREAK ME.
WHY? NATURAL.
LI. MADAM CHAIR I'M IN A SUGGEST
I THINK THE.
THE LEVEL OF DETAIL THOUGH I
CERTAINLY RESPECT THE LEVEL OF
DETAIL YOU'RE GOING INTO IT'S
OBVIOUSLY VERY PERSONAL FOR YOU
SIR BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
HOWEVER. THE INTENT OF THE BILL
IS SIMPLY TO ALLOW COUNTY
AUDITOR'S TO.
BUT TO HIRE THEIR OWN COUNSEL
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE.
WHAT WE NEED TO HEAR IN TERMS OF
TESTIMONY AND OTHER OBVIOUSLY
HAVE BEEN SOME EGREGIOUS A? A
EPISODES IN PAST YEARS GOING
FORWARD WE LIKE.
ELECTED.
COUNTY AUDITOR CONTROLLERS TO BE
ABLE TO HIRE THEIR OWN COUNSEL.
EXCUSE ME FOR INTERRUPTING SIR
BUT THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY AS ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
I A NAY BLACK SUTTER COUNTY
AUDITOR CONTROLLER SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SURE MEMBERS
NOT YOU SITE REALLY ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
AUDITORS WERE CO SPONSORED THE
BILL. AND THANK MISTER KELLY
BECAUSE HARD WORK.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MIKE MILLER
THE MONTEREY COUNTY AUBURN
CONTROLLER FORTY YEARS WORTH OF
EXPERIENCE IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.-TWENTY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TWENTY
MONTEREY COUNTY MY EXPERIENCE
TELLS ME THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND IT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORTED THANK YOU.
THE MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS RICHARD EVERLY ANY OTHER
CONTROL PHOEBE COUNTY AND ALSO
SAID IS THE LEGISLATURE OF THE
LEGISLATING OUNCES COMMITTEE FOR
THE. CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
CONTROLLERS ASSOCIATION AND WE
STANDS FOR THIS BILL AS WELL
THANK YOU NOTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF BERG
INTERCOUNTY UNDER CONTROL AND I
SUPPORT BILL THINKING.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR THE JOHNSON
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE WERE IN OPPOSITION
WE HAVE SINCE REMOVED IT BASED
ON THE AMENDMENTS I REALLY WHEN
I THINK THE AUTHOR TO STOP FOR
THE EXCELLENT WORK DONE TO. AND
REMOVE ALL OF OUR CONCERNS WITH
DROPPED IT THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MOVE THE BELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
SECOND.
SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
COUNTY AUDITORS HAVE A DIFFICULT
JOB AND THAT THEY DESERVE THAT
THE OPTION OF A.
ABUSING OF THEIR OWN COUNSEL IF
THERE'S
THE DISAGREEMENT WITHIN COUNTY
GOVERNMENT SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I TOO
WILL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO. COME AYE COOLEY AYE
AYE COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE STONE
VOEPEL.
BILLS OUT SIX ZERO THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH YOUR BOTTOM. ALRIGHT
LET'S GO ON WITH ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER NAZARIAN
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
ONE WOULD REQUIRE BUILDING
DEPARTMENTS AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO CREATE AN
INVENTORY OF POTENTIALLY
SEISMICALLY VULNERABLE.
BUILDINGS WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTION AND SUBMITTED TO
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
TO CREATE A STATEWIDE INVENTORY.
OUR STATE HAS THOUSANDS OF
BUILDINGS THAT ARE KNOWN TO
PRESENT A HEIGHTENED EARTHQUAKE
RISK OF DEATH INJURY AND DAMAGE.
BASED ON THEIR AGE STRUCTURAL
SYSTEM SIZE AND LOCATION THE
MOST RECENT CALIFORNIA SHAKEOUT
STUDY ESTIMATES THAT A MAJOR
QUAKE ALONG THE. SAN ANDREAS
FAULT COULD CAUSE MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED BILLION AND PHYSICAL AND
ECONOMIC DAMAGE. AND EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED OR MORE DEATHS.
THE CHRONIC LABOR AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SHORTAGES OF.
MOST OF CALIFORNIAN CITIES
ALREADY SUFFER WOULD TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE FOR YEARS
TO COME FOLLOWING A MAJOR
SEISMIC EVENT.
WHILE SOME CITIES MOST NOTABLY
LA AND SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
IDENTIFIED VULNERABLE BUILDINGS
AND SANTA MONICA AS WELL.
.
IDENTIFIED VULNERABLE BUILDINGS
AND IMPLEMENTED MANDATORY
RETROFITS LARGE PARTS OF THE
STATE HAVE NOT.
AND ACCURATE STATEWIDE BUILDING.
BALL A VULNERABILITY MAPPED. IS
AN ESSENTIAL FIRST STEP IN
DEVELOPING LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS
TO MITIGATE THE EFFECTS.
OF A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS.
OF THIS BILL AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND.
I THINK I'VE ALREADY ALSO
CONVEYED THAT IN ONE ON ONE
MEETINGS WITH SOME OF THE
MEMBERS AS WELL.
I'M JOINED BY.
EVAN REESE ON BEHALF OF THE
SAME IT SEISMIC RESILIENCY
INITIATIVE AS WELL AS ALICIA
WILKINS WITH THE FAIR HOUSING
COUNCIL OF RIVERSIDE. COUNTY
BOARD MEMBER.
WELCOME TO.
HELLO I AM I AM THAT MY NAME IS
SEVEN RECENT I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE U. S. RESILIENCY
COUNCIL.
I LAST MONDAY THE WASHINGTON
POST'S KNOW THAT THERE'S TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CARS STILL ON THE
ROAD WITH EXPLOSIVE AIRBAGS.
I IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TENS OR
EVEN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
OLDER VULNERABLE BUILDINGS THAT
ARE STILL ON THE ROAD. WE CAN'T
RECALL.
CAR.
BUT AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ONE
PROVIDES CRITICAL INFORMATION TO
LOCAL COMMITTEES ARE AMONG THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ABOUT THEIR
EARTHQUAKE RISKS.
SO THAT THEY CAN MAKE BETTER
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT THE
BUILDINGS IN WHICH THERE
RESIDENTS LIVE AND WORK.
IT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP IN MAKING MORE RESILIENT AT
THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND
THE ECONOMIC FABRIC OF OUR
CITIES.
THEREFORE THE U. S. RESILIENCY
COUNCIL URGES AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MADE MEMBERS I AM
ALICIA WILKINS BOARD MEMBER FOR
THE FAIR HOUSING COUNCIL OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. AND A RESIDENT
OF THE CITY OF TO MATCH TO
MACULA.
WHEN IT COMES TO EARTHQUAKE
SAFETY CALIFORNIANS WEALTHIEST
COMMUNITIES FAR OUT. RANK ARE
STATES.
WORKING CLASS NEIGHBORHOODS
MANY OF THEM ARE INCLUDING
BEVERLY HILLS SANTA MARK I'M
SANTA MONICA AND SAN FRANCISCO.
HAVE MAPPED OUT BUILDINGS THAT
ARE PROVEN TO BE VULNERABLE TO
FAILURE AND A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE.
AND ARE REQUIRING RETROFIT TO
PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
IN.
THOSE AREAS.
WE DON'T SEE THIS HAPPENING IN
OUR WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES BE
CITIES DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO MAP OUT AND ASSESS.
THE POTENTIAL DESTRUCTION THEIR
COMMUNITIES FACE SHOULD THE BIG
ONE STRIKE.
WHILE IT MAY SEEM FAR FETCHED
THE BIG ONE STRIKING ON WE HAVE
TO. YOU KNOW BEAR IN MIND THE
FACT THAT THE NORTHRIDGE
EARTHQUAKE HAPPENED NEARLY TWO
DECADES AGO.
SO SCIENTISTS NOW PREDICT THAT A
MAJOR EARTHQUAKE COULD BRING UP
TO FORTY FIVE TIMES THAT THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE NORTH UMBRAGE
EARTHQUAKE.
SURPASSING HURRICANE KATRINA AS
THE NATION'S MOST EXPENSIVE AND
NATURAL DISASTER IN HISTORY. AND
THAT'S WHY I AM HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER. NOW
KNOWS ARYAN.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL WILL
HELP CITIES NOT JUST THE RICH
ONES ASSESSED THE
VULNERABILITIES WITH DATA THAT'S
NEEDED TO PERFORM. I'M A RISK
ASSESSMENT SO I ASK FOR YOUR YES
VOTE ON AB TWENTY SIX.
THANKS VERY MUCH EIGHT OTHERS
AND OFTEN SUPPORT.
NICHOLAS DELUCA HERE WE HAVE THE
CITY OF OAKLAND IN SUPPORT WHEN
I THINK THE SILLY MEMORIES AND A
LOT FOR SEISMIC SAFETY OVER THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT SO THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANDREW AND
WE WOULD SHOW YOU OVER AND WE
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
WE'VE PUT TOGETHER A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE SUSTAINABILITY
PLAN HAVING A REAL. AND A TRUE
ASSESSMENT OF OUR RISK AND
AVAILABILITY IN COMING UP WITH
THAT EARLY PLAN THE START
CHIPPING AWAY AT THE EXPOSURE.
IS A BIG PART OF OUR STRATEGY
AND WE THINK THIS BILL IS
CONSISTENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DON XIN SKIN HERE ON
BEHALF THE STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
MISTRESS AARON'S LEADERSHIP. ARE
ON THIS BILL AND OTHERS.
.
WE'RE A LITTLE BIT OF A TWEENER
OUT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INVENTORY ASPECT OF THE BILL.
WEEKS WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INVENTORY IS BOTH LOGISTICALLY
FEASIBLE AND ACTUALLY FUND OF
ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I'M HEIDI TRAMAINE I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
EARTHQUAKE ENGINEERING RESEARCH
INSTITUTE WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WE ARE WORKING TUNING TO WORK
WITH NAZARIAN ON ON FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL.
ALLOW IT TO BE A STREAMLINED
PROCESS FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND BUILDING OWNERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER OTHERS I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
SING THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION ANYONE THAT'S IS IN
OPPOSITION.
WELCOME. A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS.
CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS A WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSING WAS AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL.
SPECIFICALLY WERE OPPOSED THE
BILL UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO
ENSURE THAT ONEROUS STANDARDS
ARE NOT PLACED ON SMALL PROPERTY
OWNERS AS WELL AS ENSURING THAT
BOTH SELLERS AND BROKERS.
INVOLVED IN TRANSACTIONS ARE
REGARDING POTENTIAL POTENTIAL
VULNERABLE BUILDINGS I CAN
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO
PERSPECTIVE BUYERS
THROUGH THE.
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OWNERS
GUIDE FOR EARTHQUAKE SAFETY I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR EXPRESSING A WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH US AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE AUTHORS
OFFICE.
OF AN UNFORTUNATE WE HAVE YET TO
REACH AN AGREEMENT SO TODAY I
MUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
COMMENTS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SOME REMEMBER WALDRON.
THE.
THANK YOU MISTER THIS AREA AND I
HAVE WE HAD SPOKEN AND I WENT
BACK TO LOOK BECAUSE I HAD VOTED
NO ON THIS BILL AND. SHE ALSO I
WANTED TO SEE WHY. SO I.
MADE SOME NOTES.
.
OKAY SO THE OTHER ANY EXEMPTIONS
IN THE BILL.
FOR THINGS LIKE.
HISTORIC BUILDING.
MY CITY HAS A HUGE AREA OF THE
YOU KNOW. THE PROPERTIES THAT
ARE LISTED ON. THE. VOTE AND
REGISTER LIST OF HISTORIC
PLACES.
AND I KNOW THERE ISN'T AN
EXEMPTION WELL YES THERE'S THERE
ARE EXEMPTIONS TO TO CERTAIN
BUILDINGS.
HISTORIC NO.
BUT I WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT HIGH I
I'M NOT A NEXT STRUCTURAL
ENGINEER EXPERT.
SO I'D I'D LEAVE IT TO THE
EXPERTS TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT THE PARAMETERS OF THAT
SHOULD BE IF YOU'RE COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT?
BUT.
THAT I THINK THAT WAS MORE OF
AN OVERSIGHT IF ANYTHING. A.
AND AND THE EXEMPTIONS ALSO ARE
ON NOW.
YEAH SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES OF
COURSE UP UNTIL FOUR UNITS.
AND.
ALSO HOSPITALS AND.
FEDERAL AND STATE BUILDINGS AND.
SCHOOL FACILITIES BECAUSE ALL
OF THOSE ALSO HAVE OTHER
STANDARDS AND OTHER THE
OVERSIGHT FORGET ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE OVERSIGHT OVER THEM.
SO THERE ARE EXEMPTIONS.
BUT HISTORICAL. NOT NOT IN THE
BILL.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW HOW I COULD FEEL ENOUGH
THAT. ASSEMBLYMAN OF MANY OF THE
HISTORICAL BUILDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE UNREINFORCED
MASONRY AND THEY WERE ALREADY
ADDRESSED BY A PREVIOUS.
LEGISLATION THIS LEGISLATION
DOESN'T FOCUS ON UNREINFORCED
MASONRY BUILDINGS
SO SOME OF THOSE AREN'T SO SOME
OF THOSE HISTORIC BUILDINGS
WOULD NOT BE INCLUDED IN THIS
LETTER.
OKAY.
SO THEN ANOTHER ONE OF MY
REASONS FOR NOT SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
WHEN I'VE THAT'S WHY ONE OF LET
YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE HAD TALKED
ABOUT.
THE YOU KNOW OLDER CITIES MANY
OF WHICH YOU KNOW CLOSING THE
CITY OF ESCONDIDO AS ONE OF
THEM.
INCORPORATED IN EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THE WHOLE URBAN CORE.
AS FAR AS THEM THE DEATH
HISTORIC DOWNTOWN AND THAT WHOLE
AREA HAS BUILDINGS THAT WERE
BUILT.
YOU KNOW AND EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
FIFTIES IN FACT THE BUILDING
WHERE MY BUSINESS WAS SIDES WAS
BUILT IN EIGHTEEN SEVENTY.
.
THERE'S BEEN.
YOU KNOW NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS TO
AREA THE SEWER SYSTEMS
EVERYTHING IS OUTDATED BUT.
TO BE ABLE TO I MEAN LITERALLY
THE WHOLE URBAN FOR WOULD BE
PART OF CONSIDERED VULNERABLE
AND I THINK THAT.
IT THIS INCLUDING THE FACT THAT.
PARSEE. HAS. A LARGE.
SEGMENT OF LOW INCOME
POPULATION.
HERE THIS WOULD IMPACT.
THEM FINANCIALLY AS WELL BECAUSE
NOT ONLY IS YOU KNOW YOUR BILL
AS TRYING TO GET THE LIST PUT
TOGETHER ONCE THAT'S THERE IT
ALMOST CREATES A STIGMA OF SORTS
ONTO THE VALUE OF THE PROPERTY.
I COULD NEVER SELL IT UNLESS IT
GETS FIXED EVEN THOUGH IT MAY
END UP NOT REALLY NEEDING TO BE
RETROFITTED SO.
THOSE WERE MY CONCERNS AND Y. I
HAD VOTED LOW CHAIR OKAY.
BUT HE WON.
THAT THAT'S A VERY FAIR
CONCERNED AND I THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THAT HIGH OBVIOUSLY THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO
PUT ANY ONE LOCAL JURISDICTION.
UNDER SUCH
DIRE CIRCUMSTANCES TO NOT MAKE
THE MEET CERTAIN GOALS. IN FACT
IDEA. HAVE WANTED TO.
LOOK AT MAYBE A AT AND THIS IS
WHY MAYBE IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
TIME TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE.
CONCERNS OF THE REALTORS.
AT THE THE BILL ITSELF HAS
THREE COMPONENTS IT'S THE
INVENTORY IT'S THE EVALUATION
AND THE MITIGATION THE
MEDICATION OBVIOUSLY BEING THE
MOST COSTLY. THE EVALUATION
HAVING COST TO IT BECAUSE OF
HAVING TWO. OF THE FOUR PROPERTY
OWNER TO ATTAIN A STRUCTURAL.
ENGINEER AND GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
GIVEN THE INVENTORY IS.
THE RELATIVELY MOST COST
EFFECTIVE PORTION OF THE BILL
AND ONE OF THE.
HEARING SOME OF THESE CONCERNS
HEARING THE CONCERN FROM THE
REALTORS ALSO.
INSTEAD OF JUST TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS WHAT WHAT TO OF THE
AMENDMENTS ARE FINE. BUT.
INSTEAD OF TAKING THE THIRD
AMENDMENT MY GOAL WAS MAYBE EVEN
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN SPLIT THE
BILL INTO TWO BILLS.
PASS ONE PORTION THIS YEAR.
THAT AT LEAST CREATES AN
INVENTORY OF THE BUILDINGS AND
THEN THINK ABOUT THE EVALUATION
AND THE MITIGATION.
AND IN THE FUTURE HERE
ESPECIALLY ONCE WE'VE
ESTABLISHED THE DATABASE OF THE
BUILDINGS AS WELL SO. YEAH I AM
SHARING THIS SO THAT YOU KNOW
THAT THERE'S.
A LOT OF.
AND WAYS OF APPROACHING THIS AND
TRYING TO ADDRESS
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS.
BUT BUT BOTTOM.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT GOAL
IS TO ENSURE THAT. A INVENTORY
LIST ALSO.
IS MOVED FORWARD WITH SO THAT WE
AT LEAST KNOW WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH THEN AND I WON ALSO
MENTIONED THAT ONCE AND
INVENTORY IS DONE. IT DOESN'T
BRING ABOUT.
.
A LIABILITY FOR THE BUILDING
OWNERS
WHEN THE BUILDING OWNERS.
PURCHASED THE BUILDING THEY
ALREADY.
JUST THE LIABILITY WITH IT.
SO I I I THAT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S NOT A
CONCERN.
IF IF IT WAS IN THE BACK OF YOUR
MIND.
OKAY THIS WITH YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A LOT OF FOLKS DON'T SPEAK
ENGLISH.
SO THEY WOULD BE IMPACTED.
AS WELL AS ONCE.
IF PROPERTY LISTED.
AS A VULNERABLE BUILDING.
THEN WOULD THE INSURANCE COMPANY
THE HAND SURE IS THAT WOULD BE
NOTIFIED. THAT IT WAS NOW ON THE
VULNERABLE LIST I MEAN THAT
COULD BE AN ISSUE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW.
I'M I'M TALKING ABOUT FOLKS IN A
WHO CAN AFFORD TO HAVE A
STRUCTURAL ENGINEER WHO ARE NOT
GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN A LOT OF
THE GOVERNMENT THINGS GOING ON.
DO YOU KNOW THAT THAT I NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THIS TO JUST MENTION
IT BUT YOU KNOW NOW WHERE DOES
THAT SAY WE COME IN WITH%
INSURANCE COMPANIES NOW WHO. ARE
ENSURING THAT PROPERTY. OKAY
THIS IS ONE OF ONLY LIST THEY
MAY SAY ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE
IN A HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS IT IS
A HEN HAS CANDEAL. OKAY HANDS
OFF THAT PROPERTY CAN'T BE LIVED
IN AND TOLD WHEN INSURANCES OR
THAT STRUCTURES.
TAKING CARE WHETHER IT'S
VULNERABLE ON NOT ULTIMATELY. I
CAN RESPOND TO THAT ASSEMBLYMAN
AND.
I'VE DONE A LOT OF WORK WITH THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES NGUYEN DAY
ENSURE A BUILDING THEY ACTUALLY
GET MORE DETAILED INFORMATION ON
THE BUILDING THEN
IT'S BILL WOULD EVEN REQUIRE A
COURSE THAT INFORMATION ISN'T
PUBLIC SO.
STATE IS NEVER ACCESS TO IT BUT
INSURANCE COMPANIES UNDERSTAND
THE AGE OF THE BUILDING THE
MATERIAL WAS MADE OUT OF AND
GENERALLY WHETHER IT'S ON THEIR
REVIEW OF A BOOK VULNERABLE LEST
AND THAT CERTAINLY GOES TOWARDS
WHERE THEY GET THEIR QUICK
INSURANCE CANNOT AFFORD IT.
SO I THINK THAT ISSUE IS SORT
OF ALREADY IMBEDDED INTO WHAT
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES GET A IN
TERMS OF THE COST OF THE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEER. AYE IN
WORKING WITH THE VARIOUS
INTEREST GROUPS THAT ARE
INTERESTED MAKING SURE THERE'S
NOT A LARGE BURDEN ON THE OWNER.
AS THE ASSEMBLYMAN SAID THIS
BILL IS PRIMARY EIGHT PRIMARILY
IN INVENTORY WITH A VERY SHORT
IT'S REALLY LITTLE IT TWO PAGE
DOCUMENT THAT FEMA PRODUCES.
THAT WOULD BE FILLED OUT BY AN
ENGINEER THAT TAKES MAYBE
FIFTEEN MINUTES TO A HALF AN
HOUR TO COMPLETE.
AND THAT WOULD BE THE INTENDED
SORT OF ASSESSMENT OR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION OF THE BUILDING THAT
WOULD BE GATHERED THAT WOULD
HELP. PROVIDE A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND HOW
THE THAT THE CITY IN THE STATE
IS GOING TO PERFORM YOU KNOW IN
A HOLE OUT WITH AN EARTHQUAKE.
SO I HOPE THAT ADDRESSES AT
LEAST LIMIT THE COST FOR THE
ENGINEER.
ASSEMBLY CABALLERO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR. WE HAD A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS OF BILL
I HAVE MANY OF THE SAME CONCERNS
THAT MISS WALDRON HAS.
.
HAVING GONE THROUGH THE.
UNREINFORCED MASONRY.
.
REQUIREMENTS IN A CITY THAT WAS
BUILT IN THE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS
WITH A LOT OF UNREINFORCED
MASONRY.
.
AT WORK.
AND IT TOOK THE CITY OF SALINAS
MANY YEARS TO GET COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE OUR DOWNTOWN WAS
SUFFERING.
.
AS OLD DOWNTOWNS TEND TO WITH
VACANCIES AND.
SO WAS A REAL CHALLENGE IN THE
ONLY WAY WE EVER GOT COMPLIANCE
WAS TO PONY UP MONEY.
AND TO MAKE MONEY AVAILABLE IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE FOR IT FOR
THAT. PROPERTY OWNER SO.
I'M VERY HESITANT TO START.
CREATING NEW OBLIGATIONS I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE RISK AND
PART OF THAT IS IS IS IT'S A
RISK ANALYSIS YOU HOPE NOTHING
BAD HAPPENS IN.
AND THE REASON THAT AND
REINFORCED MASONRY BECAME UP
PRIORITY IS BECAUSE SOMETHING
BAD DID HAPPEN THAT I LOOKED BY
I'M WITH YOU ON THE INVENTORY
THE REST OF IT HAS ME CONCERNED
JUST BECAUSE ON. ANYTHING THAT
COST.
THAT STARTS TO COST MONEY
BECOMES A CONCERN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO PUT MONEY IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE IT ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE SO I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY.
I'M WILL RESERVE.
KIND OF JUDGMENT AS YOU MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS YOU'RE
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR US TO
KNOW WHAT BUILDINGS ARE AT RISK
IN PARTICULAR.
MY MY CONCERN IS.
ARE THESE.
OLDER.
APARTMENT BUILDINGS
THAT WERE BUILT SO THAT YOU CAN
PARK UNDERNEATH AND THEN YOU.
MAY LIVE ABOVE IT THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THIS STRUCTURAL
INTEGRITY THAT YOU'D WANT HAVE
NOWADAYS. AND THOSE ARE SOME OF
OUR POOREST IN OUR POOREST
NEIGHBORHOOD SO TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION I THINK WOULD BE
GOOD.
BUT THEN WE'RE GONNA NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW ARE WE GONNA FIND
ANY RETROFITS.
AND HOW HOW CAN WE MAKE IT
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE SO THEN
WE'RE NOT PUSHING OUT ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THOSE
APARTMENTS. EITHER YOU GOT A RED
TAG THEM OR YOU GOTTA BRING THEM
UP AND IF THE BRING HIM UP MEANS
THEY CAN'T AFFORD IT ANYMORE IN
IN IN A MARKET RIGHT NOW THAT IS
ALREADY AND AFFORDABLE. THEN
WE'RE GONNA BE IN TROUBLE SO I I
JUST.
I I LOOK AT THAT IN IN RURAL
RURAL COMMUNITIES IT'S PROBABLY
LESS OF AN ISSUE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE AS MANY MORE TAKE
STORY STRUCTURES. BUT.
BUT.
I MEAN YOU KNOW WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND I THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE CONCERNS
I HAVE.
WITH THAT I AM PURPOSE I'LL
SUPPORT OF TODAY.
THANK YOU I DO I DO UNDERSTAND
AND I SHARE. MOST OF THE
SENTIMENT ALSO.
S. ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
VERY SAME BILL I.
.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT
TODAY.
I THINK.
BECAUSE I STILL ON THE STATE'S
SEISMIC SAFETY COMMISSION IS MY
SECOND TENURE THERE I WAS FIRST
APPOINTED MARSH WERE STATE WAS A
CITY OFFICIAL.
I ACTUALLY FIRST TOUCHY ISSUE
OVER OF QUAKE IS A SENIOR AT CAL
WORK WITH A BAG DOING A BAY AREA
INVENTORY OF. EARTHQUAKE
VULNERABILITY IN THE YEARS AFTER
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
EARTHQUAKE NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE.
I WAS CHIEF COUNSEL IN THIS
HOUSE TO THE EFFORT I COMMITTEE
DURING THE TIME THE LOMA PRIETA
AT OUR RESPONSE TO LOMA PRIETA.
ARM.
IN GENERAL I THINK WHEN I LOOK
AT THIS THIS IS AN INVENTORY.
SINCE.
THE NORTHRIDGE EARTHQUAKE SINCE
THE LOWER PAID EARTHQUAKES
A SENSE OF STANDING THAT SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. THERE ARE SO
MANY GUIDES THE STATE'S ISAAC
STATE TO COMMISSION HAS PRODUCED
DEALING WITH.
TYPICAL CONSTRUCTION ISSUES WHAT
YOU NEED TO DO SAFE COURTHOUSE.
THE INVENTORY JUST FORMALIZING A
LEVEL OF INFORMATION IS BROADLY
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
IN ALL MANNER CITIES IS HOW SOFT
STORY CONSTRUCTION GARAGE
UNDERNEATH.
HUGE PROBLEM IT AND IN THE WAKE
OF NORTHRIDGE THERE'S TREMENDOUS
PUBLICITY ALL OF CALIFORNIA
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES.
IRREGULAR CONSTRUCTION SO IF YOU
HAVE A HOME THAT HAS A. NOT NOT
A RECTILINEAR DESIGN THAT'S A
VULNERABILITY
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES I WAS
EIGHTEEN YEARS IN HOUSE COUNSEL
STATE FARM INSURANCE. THEY ALL
KNOW WHEN THE BUILDING WAS BUILT
THEY KNOW WHEN THE WHEN.
THE FOUNDATION TO BE BOLTED TO
THE STRUCTURE.
THEY KNOW ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION IS OUT THERE.
I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
POSITION OF THE REALTORS.
ARE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOR THE EASTERN
VERSUS TRASH BURGER DECISION WAS
THE MAIN DECISION IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND INCREASE
THE POTENTIAL EXPOSURE. OF
REALTORS.
TO KNOWING FACTS ABOUT A HOUSE
OF THEIR CHAU ON SOMEONE'S
RESPONSE TO THAT WAS A LAND
MOVEMENT CASE.
ARE WE HAVE AN ARE CIVIL CODE TO
TRANSFER DISCLOSURE STATEMENT
THAT WAS ADDED AS A CONSEQUENCE
THE EASTERN DECISION. TO SORT OF
ESTABLISH JUST.
WE JUST.
ADDRESS OUR LIABILITY BY
INFORMING YOU OF WHAT THE FACTS
ARE CONSTRUED PROPERTY.
REALTORS DON'T HAVE TO THORNY
SWITCHES ARE DOING WORK THAT YOU
JUST PROVIDED DISCLOSURE
STATEMENT.
THAT WAS SUBSEQUENTLY AMENDED
ADD THE ALL ALQUIST PRIOLO
SIZING. ZONES DISCLOSURE WHICH
IS ALSO PART OF THAT.
SO THE GENERAL ISSUES OF
LIABILITY THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS YOU DON'T OVER THE YEARS
TO COME TO EASE THE BURDEN ON
REALTORS.
THEY ALL STEM FROM THE EAST
EASTON DECISION THERE SO MUCH
INFORMATION OUT THERE FOR
PROPERTY OWNERS BUT PEOPLE DO
NEED TO RECOGNIZE WHAT.
THE RISKS ARE.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL THIS
INVENTORY IS A GOOD IDEA.
I THINK THE NOTION OF EVALUATION
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
CONVERSATION AROUND HOW YOU DO
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S AN AWFUL
LOT OF GUIDES.
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY OR
RESIDENTIAL PROBABLY ONE OF THE
FIXES IT YOU NEED.
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME WAYS TO
MASSAGE THAT. SO THEN YOU GET
DOWN TO HOW YOU HANDLE THE
MITIGATION.
AND AND THAT IS A VITAL ISSUE
BUT IT'S SORT OF ON THE BACK
INTO THIS.
INFORMATION BECOMES VERY
IMPORTANT TO TO ALLOW US TO
START WORKING THROUGH THESE
ISSUES.
ON.
SO.
I I'VE ENJOYED READING THE BILL
AND OBVIOUSLY IT BRINGS UP.
I GOT TOO MUCH ROOM IN MY HEAD
FOR YOUR IDEAL. YA BUT I DO
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT I THINK IS
IS A PART OF A LONG HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA GOES BACK DECADES.
AND IT'S.
.
IT'S A VITAL CALIFORNIA
CONVERSATION.
I THINK YOU SOME REMEMBER COOLEY
THAT ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUICK
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
US OLYMPIC COOLEY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
POLITICS MISTER COOLEY
STATEMENTS AS MY CLOTHES.
BUT NO.
HELLO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AT
VOTE THANK YOU SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I HAVE
SOME MINOR CONCERNS AS WELL
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE BILL ON
MY RURAL CITIES AND WHETHER THEY
HAVE THE STAFFING RESOURCES TO
COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL. AYE ANDERSON AT THE
BILL REQUIRES THE IDENTIFICATION
OF FUNDING SOURCES FOR THE
REQUIREMENTS ON LOCAL.
GOVERNMENTS.
I'M ALL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THIS
CLEANED UP BEFORE GOES ANY
FARTHER.
IF YOU.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON NO BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO. COVER HERO AYE COOLEY
AYE COOLEY AYE GRAYSON LACKEY.
LACKEY KNOWS STONE FO PARA.
THE BILL NEEDS ONE WARM SO HOPE
TO HAVE SOME MORE PEOPLE FILL
THE SEATS. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE ON TO MY ITEM
NUMBER NINE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING A. B. TWO
EIGHT NINE ZERO WELCOME MISTER
TING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LET ME
FIRST BY THINKING YOU YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF. VIA ALSO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING TOGETHER
IN A VERY TIGHT TIMEFRAME ON A.
VERY COMPLEX BILL THAT WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR GUIDANCE
AND LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH. ARMED I DO
WANT TO.
IT KNOWLEDGE THAT WE ARE.
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS ON
PAGE'S SIDE WHAT'S UP IN THE
COMMITMENTS TO IT ADDRESSED
ISSUES RAISED IN THE NLCS ON
PAGES NINE AND TEN. IN
PARTICULAR WE ARE REMOVING ALL.
OF THE FEE PROVISIONS THAT WORD
NOTICE WE DO WANT TO MAKE THAT
VERY CLEAR MUCH OF THE
OPPOSITION. REALLY SURROUNDED.
THE FEE PROVISIONS THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKING SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REMOVE MOST OF THE CONCERNS OF.
THE OPPOSITION I'M HAVING SAID
THIS LET ME LET ME JUST SORT OF
QUICKLY STATE WHAT THE BILL IS
GOING TO HAVE IN IT.
ON ONE IT'S GOING TO ALLOW EACH
CD TO SUBMIT WRITTEN FINDINGS TO
LOCAL AGENCY AS TO WHETHER THE
ORDINANCE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW.
SPECIFIES THAT IF A LOCAL WHICH
IF YOU THE NOT ADOPTED A LOCAL
ORDINANCE PURSUANT TO A JUNIOR
EXCEPT WE DON'T UNIT LAW. IT
MUST APPLY THE STANDARDS IN
JUNIOR EXCEPT FOR GROWING UNIT
LAW FOR THE PROOF OF THE PERMIT
TO CONSTRUCT A JUNIOR ACCESSORY.
DWELLING UNIT REQUIRES EACH CD
TO CREATE SMALL HOMEBUILDING
STANDARDS TO APPLY THE E. D.
USED BY DURING YOUR FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY. REQUIRES PERMITS TO BE
ISSUED BY EIGHTY USE OR JT USED
TO SIXTY DAYS RATHER THAN
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS.
PROHIBITS A LOCAL AGENCY FROM
ENACTING ORDINANCE TO APPLIED LA
COVERAGE LOTS SITES WERE FLOOR.
AREA RATIO REQUIREMENTS TO
EIGHTY USE. THAT PROVIDES THAT
IF A LOCAL AGENCY HAS AN OWNER
OCCUPIED REQUIREMENT THAT THE
DEPARTMENT SHOULD NOT BE
MONITORED. MORE THAN ONCE
ANNUALLY AND CREATE AN EXEMPTION
FOR TRUSTS FOR SENIORS DISABLED
AND NON PROFITS ARE IN ALLOWS
MINISTER WITH APPROVAL OF THE
BELOW EIGHT JUNIOR EIGHTY YOU.
AND EIGHTY YOU IN IN EXISTING
SPACE OR THAT IS NEW
CONSTRUCTION OF UP TO EIGHT
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET NO TALLER
THAN SIXTEEN FEET WITH AT LEAST
FOUR FEET OF SETBACKS.
UPON AS WELL AS THE EIGHTY USING
MULTI FAMILYBUILDING AREAS THAT
ARE NOT USED AS LIVABLE SPACE
HAS LONG WITH A SPACES MEET
BUILDING CODES.
I IT ALSO PROHIBITS LOCAL
AGENCIES FROM ACQUIRING A
CORRECTION OF EXISTING ZONING
NONCONFORMING IMPROVEMENT AS A
CONDITION OF GRANTING MINISTER
APPROVAL. AND PROHIBITS MINISTER
ONLY APPROVED EIGHTY USE FROM
BEING USED AS SHORT TERM
RENTALS.
BY AS YOU KNOW WE'RE FACING A
CRISIS TOO MUCH OF A CALIFORNIA
WE BELIEVE ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNITS IS A FAST WAY TO GET. ON
SOME OF THE NEEDED TO HOUSING
SUPPLY AYE IN A QUICK AND
AFFORDABLE MANNER WE'VE SEEN
THIS. UP TO BE USED IT IN MY
CITY SAN FRANCISCO BUT ALSO INTO
MANY CITIES AROUND CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE ON TWO WITNESSES THAT'LL ON
MUCH MORE ELOQUENTLY TALK ABOUT
THE THE NEED AND.
GOT MECHANICS OF PUBLIC TRYING
TO ACHIEVE.
YOU DID A FINE JOB THING
WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS DENISE PING STAN.
I'M A FORMER CURRENT PLANNING
CHIEF AND I IT CURRENTLY IN MY A
VOLUNTEER CAPACITY I'M A MEMBER
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL HOUSING
COMMITTEE THE COMMITTEE TO HOUSE
THE BAY AREA OF THE SPUR HOUSING
COMMITTEE. AND I'VE BEEN HERE
FOR A COUPLE DAYS IS A VOLUNTEER
TALKING TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
AND I SWEAR TO NOTE THE IRONY
THAT FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
PLANNING COMMUNITY TO COME OUT
FULL THROATED LEE AND ENDORSE
AYE DIFFICULT HOUSING POLICY
REQUIRES THAT WE NOT BE
PERSONALLY ANY LONGER AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICE. SO TO THE
PEOPLE SITTING HERE TODAY ARE
FORMER CURRENT PLANNING CHIEFS
WE KNOW INTIMATELY WHAT HAPPENS
IN A LOCAL GOVERNMENT PLANNING
OFFICE WE WROTE THE STAFF
REPORTS WE DENIED EIGHTY YEARS
BACK WHEN THEY WERE COMPLAINT
WAS OWNING. IT AND WE'RE HERE
TODAY IN A COALITION A BROAD
COALITION OF FORMER AND CURRENT
PLANNING STAFF PEOPLE IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TODAY. ARE
ENVIRONMENTALISTS LABOR BUSINESS
HAUSER'S PROFESSIONAL PLANNERS
REALTORS ARE BECAUSE WE ALL
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE NOT UNDER
THE PRESSURE OF THE FIFTY PEOPLE
ON THE PUBLIC HEARING YOU DON'T
WANT US TO DO SOMETHING. HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS FOR THE STATE TO
PROVIDE LEADERSHIP?
CONTINUITY AND CLARITY SO THAT
HOMEOWNERS WHO WANT TO HELP ON
THE HOUSING CRISIS CAN GET THE
BUILDING PERMITS THAT STATE LAW
TODAY SAYS THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GET MINISTERIAL A.
THIS BILL PROVIDES CERTAINTY FOR
OWNERS
YOU KNOW IF THIS BILL PASSES
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO GET AT LEAST
AN EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE FOOT
EIGHTY YOU ON YOUR PROPERTY WITH
A BUILDING PERMIT. WITH FIX SET
BACKS AND THE REASONABLE HEIGHT
LIMIT REGARDLESS OF THE LOT
STANDARD OR THE OTHER.
ZONING BARRIERS THAT TYPICALLY
CITIES USE WHEN THEY WANT TO
DISCOURAGE EIGHTY USE TO KEEP
ANYONE FROM GETTING ONE THERE IF
THERE COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT SET THEIR MINIMUM LOT SIZE
SO HIGH FOR EXAMPLE. THAT
VIRTUALLY NONE OF THE LOTS IN
THE CITY ARE ELIGIBLE TO EVER
HAVE BEEN EIGHTY YOU.
AND AND THESE CHANGES WERE
ADOPTED AFTER THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN LAWS WERE
CHANGED.
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME
VOLUNTEERING TO HELP HOMEOWNERS
DO THIS WORK.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH TO YOU
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSITIES NORTH
AND SOUTH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY AND THEIR
FOLKS WERE STUDYING EIGHTY YOU
ADOPTION AND ABSORPTION AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AS WELL AS
UCLA CITY ALLOWED WHO HAVE BEEN
REALLY THE EIGHTY YOU LEADERS
ALONG WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM IN IN
LEADING THE STATE ON THESE
EIGHTY YOU POLICIES AND YOU
DON'T SEE THE PROBLEMS TO YOUR
KINDA IN THE WEEDS OF A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PLANNING OFFICE AND
THAT'S WHERE WE'VE BEEN.
SO WE'RE HERE TO SHARE WITH YOU
THE LESSONS OF THE WEEDS FOR
WE'VE LEARNED THE BARRIERS STILL
EXIST WEEK WE THOUGHT WE FIX
THEM WITH COUPLE STATE WAS WE
DIDN'T.
AND THIS WALL WILL REMOVE THOSE
BARRIERS TO PROVIDE HOMEOWNER
CERTAINTY. TO MAKE SAFETY THE
PRIORITY INSTEAD OF UP CONCERNED
ABOUT. MEETING THE LETTER A
EVERY ZONING POSSIBLE BARRIER
THAT'S POSSIBLE SO THAT
HOMEOWNERS WHO WANTED BUILDING
EIGHTY YOU. CAN GET A BUILDING
PERMIT BECAUSE IF THEY CAN'T
EASILY GET A BUILDING PERMIT.
LIKE IT'S NOT THEY'RE GOING TO
BUILD AN ILLEGALLY.
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ILLEGAL AB USING CALIFORNIA
TODAY CITIES OF A BELL IN LOS
ANGELES HAVE MORE THAN FIFTY
PERCENT OF ALL NEW HOUSING
BUILT.
AS ILLEGAL EIGHTY USE
AND THOSE HOMEOWNERS CAN'T GET A
BUILDING PERMIT IF THEY CAN'T
MEET THE ZONING STANDARDS WHICH
ARE ON OFTENTIMES SET TO PREVENT
THEM FROM GETTING THE BUILDING
PERMIT FOR AN EIGHTY YEAR THAT
STATE LAW SAYS THEY SHOULD HAVE.
FINALLY THIS BLOG NOW PROMOTES
BEST PRACTICES TO ENCOURAGE
EIGHTY ADOPTION IN EVERY
COMMUNITY INCLUDING ALLOWING
EIGHTY USE IT AND AND GENERATE
USE THAT HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
EFFECTIVE IN CALIFORNIA'S FIRE
ZONES IN THIS BEEN STRONGLY
ENDORSED BY PROFESSIONAL
PLANNERS IN THE FIRE ZONES. AS A
WAY TO QUICKLY GET MORE OF THESE
ADOPTED.
AND TO ALLOW EIGHTY USE IN THE
I'M YOU SPACES
LIKE IS NOT IN SOME PLACES A
BUILDING OWNER MIGHT TRY TO
ILLEGALLY PUT SOMEBODY DOWN
THERE. IF YOU ALLOW THEM TO DO
IT LEGALLY THEN THE PERSON WHO
LIVES DOWN THERE WILL BE SAFE.
AND SO THE PRIORITY OF THIS BILL
IS CERTAINTY SAFETY AND BEST
PRACTICES AND WITHOUT THE STATE
STEPPING IN TO CREATE EVENHANDED
RULES BETTER. ADOPTED BY EVERY
CITY INCLUDING THE CITIES WHO
MAYBE WISH THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO
DO THIS.
YOU WILL HAVE UNEVEN ADOPTION
AND YOU HAVE A LOT OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS WHICH CREATE A HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROBLEMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE'S WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DAVID
GARCIA I'M THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AT UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING INNOVATION WHICH HAS
UNDERTAKEN A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF RESEARCH. IN THE AREA OF
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS AND
THIS BILL.
INCORPORATE SEVERAL OF OUR
EVIDENCE BASED RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR INCREASING EIGHTY YOU
PRODUCTION
ACROSS THE STATE'S
ATTORNEYS CENTER CONSIDERS.
ACCESSORY GOING IN IS TO BE AND
THE CENTRAL PIECE OF A BROADER
HOUSING SOLUTION FOR CALIFORNIA
AS A SERVICE AN EFFICIENT AND
COST EFFECTIVE.
FORM OF HOUSING SPECIFICALLY
EIGHTY USE CAN BE BUILT WITHOUT
SUBSIDY FOR A FRACTION OF THE
TIME AND COST IT TAKES TO BUILD
TRADITIONAL HOUSING AND AS OUR
OFTENTIMES RENTED AT BELOW
MARKET RATES.
AND TO INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
EXISTING RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PROPERTY OWNERS SO AGING
RELATIVES.
THE CARETAKERS OF THE LIKE
SO GIVEN THESE BENEFITS TERMS
CENTER RECOMMENDS THAT POLICIES
THAT REMOVE BARRIERS A
DEVELOPMENT SHOULD BE PRIORITIZE
IN THIS BILL CERTAINLY DOES A
GREAT DEAL. TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
BY.
CREATING A REASONABLE DESIGN
STANDARDS AND.
THE CREATION OF A A SMALL
STRUCTURES OF BUILDING CODE AYE
THAT TOGETHER WILL.
.
REMOVE COMPLEXITY AND.
CREATE MORE INTEREST AND
BUILDING PERMITS FORZEST
WITHDRAWING ITSELF GIVEN THE
MOMENTUM WE'VE SEEN FROM REFORMS
IN PREVIOUS YEARS WE KNOW THAT'S
REMOVING THESE BARRIERS ARE AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR CREATING. A
HOUSING UNITS.
QUICKLY AND VARIOUS AREAS OF
THE STATE SO I'M WITH THAT I
WOULD SAY THAT.
IF YOU DE UM THE POLICIES IN
THIS BILL ARE CONSISTENT WITH A
MUCH OF OUR RESEARCH AND
FINDINGS.
THANK YOU OTHERS THAN IN SUPPORT
NAME ORGANIZATION.
POSITION.
MICHAEL AND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OR THE
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SPEC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
SO AS A MATTER THAT LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA'S WEALTH CALIFORNIA
BE IN SUPPORT.
IF THE FAMILY OF THE BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
AB BACKER IN GI WITH A WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS U. S. SAYING SAN
JOSE AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY ARE
REPRESENTING OUR UNITE HERE
LOCAL NINETEEN AND AB T. TRONG
COUNCIL SEVEN. I IN SUPPORT IF
AMENDED.
TO INCLUDE RESTRICTIONS ON
SHORT TERM RENTALS
BUT YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
THOSE WITNESSESIN OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NANCY TRIED
ASSIST BEEN ALSO HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
NEARLY ONE THOUSAND OF SCHOOL
AND COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
GOVERNING BOARDS.
WHEN I'M NOT REPRESENTING FIVE
THOUSAND ELECTED OFFICIALS I'M
ALSO SCHOOL BOARD PRESIDENT HERE
IN ELK GROVE UNIFIED SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND I DON'T KNOW IF IT.
BOLSTERS THE ARGUMENT THAT WAS
MADE BUT I'M ALSO A FORMER
PLANNING COMMISSIONER SO I DON'T
KNOW WHICH WAY THAT THAT SWAYS
ME.
UP FIRST OF ALL I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT THAT REMOVE THE FEE
PROVISIONS.
SO I WILL BE VERY BRIEF ON THAT
NOTE AND SAY THAT.
WE IN THE EDUCATION COMMUNITY
LIVE THE HOUSING CRISIS EVERY
SINGLE DAY STUDENTS WHO ARE
HOMELESS EXPERIENCE HOUSING
INSTABILITY OR LIVE IN
SUBSTANDARD HOUSING WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE IMPEDIMENTS TO
THEIR EDUCATION SO WE APPRECIATE
BEING A PART OF THIS DISCUSSION.
AND IT IS OUR HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER FROM A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION THAT DOES
NOT.
AMELIORATE THE HOUSING CRISIS
AT THE EXPENSE OF.
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION SO.
OUT WHEN WE SEE THOSE AMENDMENT
TEMPERATE I ANTICIPATE CSPA
WARMER THE TOP POSITION AND I
WILL YIELD THE REMAINDER OF MY
TIME.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES A RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
TO THE MEASURE OUR OVERARCHING
CONCERN IS ESSENTIALLY ONE THAT
PROPONENTS ACTUALLY OUTLINED
WITCHES WE JUST HAD A MAJOR
OVERHAUL OF A DO YOU LIE IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN. THE BILL'S
BECAME EFFECTIVE ON JANUARY ONE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND NOW LOCAL
AGENCIES ARE NEARING THE END OF
THE PROCESS OR HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED ORDINANCES THAT. I LEAST
THE ORDINANCES THAT I'VE
REVIEWED
STANSHALL LIBERALIZE THE ABILITY
TO ADDICTS THAT'S REDRAWING
UNITS TO YOUR PROPERTY SO.
THAT'S JUST A FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERN WITH CHANGING THE
STANDARDS ONCE AGAIN AFTER FOLKS
HAVE ALREADY DONE ALL THE WORK
TO TO UPDATE THEIR ORDINANCES
AND WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT TO REMOVE THE FEE
PROVISIONS I THINK THAT'LL GO A
LONG WAY TOWARDS. ADDRESSING A
LOT OF OUR CONCERNS WITH THIS
ISSUE BUT WE DO HAVE A REMAINING
CONCERNS WITH SOME OF THE LAND
USE PROVISIONS ON ONE IS THAT
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW YOU TO USE
AND NON RESIDENTIAL ZONES. AND
WE THINK THERE'S A PUBLIC POLICY
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT IF
YOU ARE ON AN INDUSTRIAL ZONE
PARCEL AND YOU HAVE A
PREEXISTING. LEGAL NONCONFORMING
RESIDENTS THEN WHY WOULD WE WANT
TO AND MORE RESIDENTIAL USES AND
INTENSIFY THE RESIDENTIAL USE.
AND INCREASE THE POTENTIAL FOR
CONFLICTS WITH SURROUNDING
INDUSTRIAL OR COMMERCIAL OR
AGRICULTURAL LANDS AND WE THINK
THAT THIS BILL PRECLUDES
LEGITIMATE RESTRICTIONS ON
PARCEL SIZES IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREA.
AS EVERYONE HERE PROBABLY KNOWS
A LOT OF UNINCORPORATED AREAS
DON'T HAVE COMMUNITY WATER OR
SEWER SO. PARCEL SIZE IS AN
IMPORTANT SCREENING CRITERIA TO
DETERMINE IF THERE'S LIKELY TO
BE ROOM FOR THE SEPTIC AND WELL
THAT WILL BE NECESSARY
ESPECIALLY FOR ADDING. AS LOTS
OF RURAL COUNTIES ALLOW VERY
LARGE ACCEPTS REDRAWING UNITS
PLASTER COUNTY'S ORDINANCE
ACTUALLY IF YOU HAVE A PARCEL
OVER FIVE ACRES IN SIZE HAS NO
RESTRICTION ON THE AMOUNT OF
ACCESSORY. RESIDENTIAL USES THAT
CAN BE ADDED TO THE PROPERTY SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ESSENTIALLY
ADDING A SECOND HOME IN THAT
CONTEXT.
AND WE ALSO THINK THAT THIS
BILLS INCLUSION OF LANGUAGE
THAT'S POPPED UP IN OTHER PLACES
THAT ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. TO ADOPT GUIDELINES
AND FOR THE REVIEW OF THESE
LOCAL ORDINANCES WITHOUT GOING
THROUGH A FORMAL RULE MAKING
PROCESS I'M IS INAPPROPRIATE AND
WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE
STANDARD WE THINK IT'LL BE VERY
DIFFICULT. FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO
MAKE PUBLIC POLICY DECISIONS
SUCH AS RESTRICTING ACCEPTS
REDRAWING UNITS IN HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITY AREAS WHERE WE
LIKELY DON'T WANT TO ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL RESIDENTIAL
INTENSITY.
AND ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO MEET
THAT STANDARD I'M FINALLY WE ARE
LITTLE BITCONFUSED WITH THE
ADDITION OF THE JUNIOR ACCEPTS
REDRAWING UNIT LANGUAGE WHICH UP
TO THIS POINT HAS BEEN OPTIONAL.
ESPECIALLY SINCE I'M YOU ARE
ALLOWED TO DO UNDER EXISTING LAW
CONVERSIONS OF EXISTING
RESIDENTIAL SPACE OR NOT
NECESSARILY SURE THAT THAT
PROVISION IS. REQUIRED UP SO FOR
THOSE REASONS AND WE'RE HOPING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE TO RESOLVE OUR
MEANING REMAINING CONCERNS.
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
CHANGES RELATED TO FEES BUT WE
DO HAVE AN OVERRIDING CONCERN
ABOUT CONSTANTLY CHANGING THE
RULES.
FOR EXCESSIVE GROWING UNITS.
THANK YOU OTHER THAT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
CAPTION NOON ROUNDER ROSSI WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE FOR TODAY'S AMENDMENTS
WITH THEM WE SHOULD BE NEUTRAL
IN THE BILL.
IAN TO DEAL WITH THE COALITION
FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING WE
HAD ALSO HAD.
IN OPPOSE.
POSITION BUT WITH THE.
AMENDMENTS WE ANTICIPATE
REMOVING THOSE.
A MENTOR MEMBERS JASON RILEY
CALIFORNIA CITIES A WE ARE NOT A
AGAINST EIGHTY USING ITS
EXISTING LAW.
BUT WE CERTAINLY ALIGNER
COMMENTS WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
OVER AT C. SAKON AND SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS AND HOPE TO KEEP YOUR
WORK WITH THE WITH THE AUTHOR.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE UNABLE
AND SAY REPRESENT THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION A BUT ALSO
IN OUR COMMENTS WITH I'M SEE
SACK APPRECIATE THEM AS TAKEN
TODAY BY JUST DO WANNA ADD THAT.
WE ARE CONCERNED GIVE ANOTHER TO
SENATE BILLS MOVING THAT TOOK
VERY DIFFERENT AMENDMENTS TODAY
AND WONDER HOW THE BILL'S OWNER
ASKED AS THEY MOVE FORWARD SO
THANK YOU.
I'M SURE MEMBERS JOINED FOR SOME
BEHALF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
ALSO VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
MOMENTS BELLI OUR COMMENTS WITH
THE SOCK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER GIRL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER BEEN QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
SOME REMEMBER BLOOM COUPLE OF.
COMMENTS FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF FOR HAVING AUTHORED DEAD
TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
NINE.
ALONG WITH SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
GIZA BILL THAT TWO BILLS THAT
KINDA GOT THIS.
MOVING ALONG.
YOU MIGHT THINK FROM THE
COMMENTS OF SOME OF THE
PROPONENTS THAT HOUSING IS NOT
GETTING BUILT UNDER THE.
I REVISED EIGHTY YOU.
LAW.
AND THE FACT THAT MATTER IS
ANOTHER FORTY THREE HUNDRED
UNITS THAT ARE EITHER BUILT IN
CONSTRUCTION OR IN THE PERMIT
PROCESS. AT A ACROSS THE STATE
IT'S.
ACTUALLY AT A HOUSING BOOM WHEN
YOU COMPARE THAT.
TO THE TOTAL NUMBER OF HOUSING
UNITS THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED AN
AVERAGE YEARS BEFORE WHICH IS
SOMEWHERE.
A IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND OR
SO STATEWIDE WHICH IS A.
TERRIBLE NUMBER WE NEED FAR
MORE HOUSING BUT FORTY THREE
HUNDRED UNITS AIN'T BAD WHEN.
YOU'RE CONSIDERING ITS
INDIVIDUAL UNITS.
I INTERSPERSED TO MANY PLACES
IN IN ADDITION.
CITIES LIKE SANTA ROSA AND TO
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES ARE AND
I THINK A SAN FRANCISCO AS WELL
COMING UP WITH CREATIVE WAYS TO
UTILIZE A EIGHTY USED IN THE
CASE OF SANTA ROSA TO.
HELP RECOVER FROM THE FIRE
PROVIDE TO A BADLY NEEDED
HOUSING BECAUSE THESE UNITS CAN
BE BUILT FAR MORE QUICKLY THAN
THE. THAN OTHERS THAT ARE.
AGO THROUGH THE.
LARGER PROJECTS ECHO THROUGH
THE PERMITTING PROCESS IN LOS
ANGELES.
OF THEIR.
IS A VERY VERY SMALL PROGRAM
BUT AN INTERESTING PROGRAM TO.
ENCOURAGE.
FOLKS TO USE.
EXCEPT DWELLING UNITS TO HOUSE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
.
I FOR A A SPOKEN WITH THE AUTHOR
I SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
FOR. OF FOLKS WHO ARE.
SPOKE PARTICULARLY THEA AND OF
FOR. OF FOR THE PART OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. OF THEM AND THE
AUTHORS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON. ON ALL OF THESE ISSUES
ON.
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
AND IT.
HOPE THAT THOSE SANTA. ANA
ISSUES THAT ARE OUT THE RESULT I
I I I WOULD SAY THAT I. AND.
SOMEWHAT CONCERNED THAT OF THE
THE POINT WAS MADE EARLIER AND
IT'S IT. A CONCERN THAT I SHARE
THAT.
EVERY CITY HAS JUST GONE
THROUGH A PROCESS OF REVISING
ITS ORDINANCE HIM. ENOUGH.
WE GOT A LOT OF FEEDBACK FROM
CITIES THE.
A ABOUT TWO MINUTES OF THEIR
EXPERIENCE GOING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS BECAUSE NATURALLY THEY
IDENTIFIED ISSUES BUT TO ASK
THEM TO NOW GO THROUGH.
AT ANOTHER A SIMILAR PROCESSES.
IS A LOT TO ASK I THINK GUM OF
BUT THAT SAID I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND. SEE WHERE IT
LEADS US.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
ANY OTHER.
MANY COMMENTS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY.
I JUST WANT SAVINGS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL AND I'M MORE. I
AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF TODAY I
THINK ONE OBSERVATION I HAVE
CONCERNING THIS IS.
AND I SEE THIS WAR THROUGH THE
LENS OF OIL ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
WHERE THE AVERAGE AGE IS
CONSIDERABLY HIGHER THAN. THAT
OF THE LOCAL SOME ISSUE OR SIT
HERE.
YOU SEE MORE AND MORE FAMILIES
WHERE THE KIDS ARE AWAY THEY'VE
SETTLED. MOM DAD OR IN THE HOME
AND THEN. MOM OR DAD GOES TO A
SENIOR LIVING ARRANGEMENT OR
THEY BOTH CALLED WAS SENIOR
LIVING ARRANGEMENT.
AND THEN YOU START SEEN OUR
RESTAURANTS AROUND THE COMMUNITY
THAT HAVE BEEN THERE A LONG TIME
IN A PART OF THE FABRIC
COMMUNITY.
YOU START SEEING RESTAURANTS
CLOSE BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
LOCAL TRAFFIC TO KEEP THEM OPEN.
I SEE THIS IN THE NORTH COUNTY.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL THAT.
I JUST WANT TO STATE THAT I FEEL
THE.
GREATER USE OF OF THIS TYPE
UNIT.
IS ACTUAL WAY TO HELP SUSTAIN
ECONOMIC VITALITY OF A LONG
ESTABLISHED COMMUNITIES.
AS SORT OF PEOPLE GO THROUGH THE
AGE.
AGING PROCESS.
I KNOW THAT I HAVE LOCAL
CHAMBERS THAT A A BIG ISSUE ON
THEIR RADAR SCREEN IS THE LOSS
OF.
.
RETAIL AND PEOPLE OUT IN THE
COMMITTEE SPENDING MONEY AT
SHOPS AND RESTAURANTS AS A BY
PRODUCT OF JUST A FACT IT'S AN
AGING COMMUNITY.
SO I THINK THIS TYPE OF.
THIS TYPE OF PRODUCT ACTUALLY.
IT IS GOOD TO GET PEOPLE IN A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEAD.
BUT I THINK IT CONSERVE SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW DENSITIES AND.
IN A COMPATIBLE WAY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY AND THAT RELEASES A
LOT OF POSITIVE ENERGY.
THAT SUPPORTS OPENLY PROPERTY
VALUES.
RATHER THAN WELL YOU KNOW.
THESE RESTAURANTS ARE CLOSING
THE AMENITIES THAT WE ARE CUSTOM
TOUR SORT OF DIMINISHING. I SEE
THIS IS KINDA HELPING PULL AIR
IN THE TIRES WHO DOESN'T JUST.
GO FLAT.
SO I THINK IT'S VERY POSSIBILITY
THAT THERE'S DEFINITE ECONOMIC
ARGUMENT THAT'S BIGGER.
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED.
AND.
.
SUPPORTING INDIVIDUAL PROPER WHO
MIGHT WISH TO DO THIS I THINK
FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR SOME
MEMBER COOLEY ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
OKAY WE STILL MOVED IT BILL
OKAY.
SOME WOMEN OKAY WE HAVE I'VE.
MOTION AND A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CABALLERO.
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
WHAT IS GONNA BOTH AGREE WITH
FOR?
OF COURSE IT'S NOT SURPRISING I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM.
SANTA MONICA AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM METRO CORDOVA I DO GET A
CHANCE TO READ LIKE YOU'D
MENTIONED THAT THE GOOD ACTORS
YOUR UPS RIGHT SAN FRANCISCO.
SANTA BARBARA CINEMA HAVE
ACTUALLY PASSED
IN ADOPTED LOCAL ORDINANCES TO
RELIEVE.
EXPAND THE ADOPTION OF ANY YOU
ARE THE ONE EXAMPLE THAT COMES
SPEAKS DIDN'T MENTION WAS THE
CITY OF ARTESIA. THEY WENT THE
OTHER WAY AND THEY.
PASSED A LOCAL ORDINANCE THAT
ONLY ALLOWS LOTS OF TEN THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET OR GREATER TO BUILD
AN EIGHTY YOU.
WHICH
PRETTY MUCH I BELIEVE BANDS
ALMOST.
ARM THE ENTIRE CITY FOR BUILDING
EIGHTY OR SO TO TALK THIS
LEGISLATURE'S MORE IN REACTION
TO THE CITIES.
THAT REACTED POORLY NOT THE
CITY'S WHO REACTED WELL AND IT
REALLY DID WHAT WE WERE HOPING
SO I THINK WE WE ARE TRYING TO
THREAT THAT NEEDLE. IN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. YOUR COMMENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH SENATOR
SKINNER AND Y. KOWSKI ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE COME TOGETHER AS
ONE.
THANK YOU I LOVE HEARING THAT
LET'S COLLABORATE LOW THAT.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR PARTICULARLY
SPENT SO MUCH TIME WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AND GOING OVER
VARIOUS.
LOOKS OF THE AMENDMENTS.
AND I'M HOPING THAT OF SOME THE
OPPOSITION WILL WORK WITH YOU TO
GET THINGS CLEARED UP THAT WE
HAVE I THINK.
EVERYBODY MADE REALLY GOOD
COMMENTS
SO WITHOUT ALL SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY.
TAKE A BUNCH OF.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WE ARE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM I CABALLERO.
COVER YOUR AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
STONE.
STONE IVU CHO.
THANK YOU BILLS AT SIX ZERO.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO DO OF WE
HAVE LITTLE HICCUP HERE WHICH IS
MINOR.
LOT OF COMMITTEES ARE GOING ON
TODAY SO WE'RE GOING TO DO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT
FIFTY THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
MEDINA SPELL. AND WE'LL HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM PRESENTING
.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBERS. BLOOM
BLOOM NOT MEDINA TOM BUT THEY.
IT'S NOT OBVIOUS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY I'LL
GIVE THIS MY BEST SHOT ON BEHALF
OF OUR.
A COLLEAGUE GOT MR MEDINA THIS
BILL SEEKS TO EXPAND ON CURRENT
LAW AND INFORM THE PUBLIC BY
REQUIRING THAT LOCAL GOVERNING
AGENCIES PROVIDE SPECIFIED
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC.
BEFORE APPROVING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SUBSIDY FOR
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION CENTER.
DEVELOPMENT OF WAREHOUSES IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND AROUND THE
STATE HAS GROWN TREMENDOUSLY IN
RECENT YEARS. IN LARGE PART TO
THE SUBSIDIES PROVIDED BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE BUILDING OF MULTIPLE
WAREHOUSES CAN BE SEEN AS A NET
BENEFIT TO THE JOBS CREATED AND
TAX REVENUE GENERATED. HOWEVER
RESEARCH IS SHOWING THAT
WAREHOUSES AREN'T BENEFITING TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THEY ARE BUILT
TO AND.
THAT'S WHERE THIS BILL COMES IN
IT'S A MODEST BILL. OF BUT VERY
IMPORTANT WILL INCREASE PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY. AND HELP ENSURE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS MAKES SENSE
BOTH ECONOMICALLY AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY BEFORE APPROVING
AN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TAXPAYER
FUNDED SUBSIDY. FOR WAREHOUSE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL WITNESSES
IN HERE TO WELL PORT WITNESSES.
PLEASE.
FEEL FREE TO START.
I'M HIGH I'D GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ANGIE RIKEN.
AND I HAVE WORKED FOR ELEVEN
YEARS AT THE KMART DISTRIBUTION
CENTER RURAL MORE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY.
I WORK IN THE APARTMENT A
UNLOADING TRAILERS. I'M AND I
CURRENTLY SERVICES CHIEF SHOP
STEWARD.
OF THE UNION IN MY WORKPLACE.
MY TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
COWORKERS AND I ARE MEMBERS OF
WORKERS UNITED SEIU.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A UNION ARE
WORKING CONDITIONS ARE VERY
DIFFERENT FROM MOST WAREHOUSES
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE A VOICE AT WORK.
I WHEN I NEGOTIATE LIMITS ON HOW
MANY TEMPORARY WORKERS THE
COMPANY CAN EMPLOY WHICH MEANS
MORE FULL TIME JOBS.
A WE HAVE A WAY TO ADDRESS
SAFETY CONCERNS INTO RAIN AND
MANAGERS WHO WANT TO WORK AS
FASTER THAN HUMAN POSSIBLE.
AND WE HAVE ONE BETTER WAGES AND
MORE PAID TIME OFF.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST WAREHOUSE
WORK.
WAREHOUSES WORKERS MORTARS MOST
WAREHOUSE WORKERS EXCUSE ME IN
OUR COMMUNITY. FACE A DIFFERENT
REALITY AT THE TYPICAL
DISTRIBUTION CENTER MOST WORKERS
ARE HIRED STAFFING AGENCIES BUT
NO GUARANTEES. THAT THEY WILL
STILL HAVE A JOB THE NEXT WEEK.
THE COMPANIES PAY MINIMUM WAGE.
FOR NEAR MINIMUM WAGE WITH
LITTLE OR NO BENEFITS OR PAID
TIME OFF I WORKERS HAVE NO VOICE
TO ADDRESS SAFETY CONCERNS OR
PULLING FROM THEIR MANAGEMENT.
MANY OF THESE BIG CORPORATIONS
AND ENJOY TAX INCENTIVES FOR.
FROM OUR CITIES BUT THERE IS NO
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT THE JOBS THEY
CREATE. ONE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
GIVES GIVEAWAY HUGE AMOUNTS OF
PUBLIC MONEY WE SHOULD KNOW HOW
MANY JOBS THEY WILL CREATE AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL BE GOOD
JOBS OR FULL TIME JOBS.
AS A TAXPAYER.
I BELIEVE ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
A RIGHT TO DEMAND TRANSPARENCY
AND GOOD JOBS FROM ANY
CORPORATION THAT BENEFITS FROM
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS PUBLIC
MIGHT.
THAT'S WHY WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY
EIGHT VICTORY.
UNION MEMBERS HAVE PROVEN THAT
WAREHOUSE JOBS CAN BE GOOD JOBS.
THERE IS NO EXCUSE WE MUSCLE
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE TO CREATE
GOOD JOBS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THINKING.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHERRY ARE COST YOU
I'M THE CO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE
CENTER. FOR NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION BASED IN ONTARIO
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE LIVES
OF WAREHOUSE WORKERS THROUGH.
ADVOCACY ACTION EDUCATION.
MERIT MAJOR WAREHOUSES BEEN
DEVELOPED.
IN A HUGE WAVE IN THE RECENT
YEARS ACROSS CALIFORNIA. THEIR
OVER THREE HUNDRED MAJOR
FACILITIES IN INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALONE AND GROWING
CLUSTERS A CENTRAL VALLEY AS
WELL AS THE EAST BAY.
WELL OVER THREE OR THOUSAND
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE IN
THIS AND RELATED SECTORS NAM AND
THAT WAS IT SECTOR OF THE
ECONOMY IT'S RAPIDLY GROWING.
UNFORTUNATELY COMMUNITIES ARE
OFTEN PITTED AGAINST EACH OTHER.
IN COMPETITION FOR TAX
ABATEMENTS OF SUBSIDIES OR TO
HAVE A WAREHOUSE DEVELOPED AN
OPEN IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ALL THIS BILL WOULD DO IS
REQUIRE THAT THESE OPERATORS
DISCLOSE THE NUMBER OF JOBS AND.
THE QUALITY OF JOBS ARE BEING
CREATED IN THESE COMMUNITIES.
AND DIFFERENT METRICS OF
COMMITTEE BENEFITS AND THEN HAVE
SOME SORT OF ABILITY TO HAVE AN
ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND THAT. IN
THE YEARS AFTER THE WAREHOUSES
DEVELOPMENT.
CURRENTLY TOO MANY OF THESE JOBS
ARE TEMPORARY AND PAY A LITTLE
MORE THAN MINIMUM WAGE.
THIS WILL THIS BILL WOULD GIVE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND POLICY
MAKERS WHO BELIEVE TO KNOW WHAT
IS COMING INTO THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND TO HOLD A DEVELOPERS AND
WAREHOUSE OPERATES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR WHAT IS PROMISED.
SOME EXAMPLES OF THE KINDS OF
SUBSIDIES THAT EVER OCCURRED IN
CALIFORNIA.
FRESNO IS PROVIDING AMAZON WITH
OVER THIRTEEN PUT WITH THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO BUILD A
WAREHOUSE IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
WITH THE PROMISE OF OUR TWO
THOUSAND JOBS.
AMAZON THE COMPANY OWNED BY THE
RICHEST MAN IN THE WORLD WHICH
PAY NO FEDERAL TAXES LAST YEAR
PARTLY DUE TO DEPRECIATION ON
THESE VERY WAREHOUSES.
IN ONTARIO QVC IS RECEIVING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN TAX
ABATEMENTS FROM THE CITY. AND
OVER A MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA COMPETES
THE CALIFORNIA COMPETES PROGRAM
OF STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE NO IDEA OF THE QUALITY
OF THE JOBS THAT WOULD BE
CREATED BY THIS FACILITY BOMB
BUT WE KNOW THERE'S NOT NEARLY
AS MANY JOBS AS THEY'VE PROMISED
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
JUST AS IMPORTANT.
IS THAT THIS BILL WILL GIVE US
THE ABILITY TO HOLD EMPLOYERS
AND DEVELOPERS ACCOUNTABLE.
TOO OFTEN WAREHOUSES ARE
APPROVED BECAUSE OF THE PROMISE
OF JOBS.
BUT AFTER APPROVAL
JOBS DON'T MATERIALIZE ARE
TEMPORARY.
SOMETIMES EMPLOYERS
MISCLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES HASN'T
BEEN A CONTRACTORS.
OTHERS DON'T PROVIDE DECENT
WAGES
THIS FOR ALL THESE REASONS THAT
WE ASK YOU TO MOVE AB TWENTY
FIFTY THREE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF OTHER
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
NAME AND.
THAT I'M CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WHERE THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL I'M HERE IN SUPPORT TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OTHERS INSOFAR.
MADAM CHAIR MAT PRANA HERE ON
BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS IN SPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE OTHER IN SUPPORT SAYING NONE
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAVALLERO.
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
MISS EGGMAN THERE THIS ACTUALLY
IS A.
I THINK A VERY IMPORTANT BILL
BECAUSE IT SPEAKS TO CHANGES
THAT ARE OCCURRING IN A DAILY
BASIS ON OUR ECONOMY. AS BRICK
AND MORTAR A STORES CLOSED DOWN
AND THE WAREHOUSE ECONOMY PICKS
UP THERE'S A A A A.
AND AS OTHER CHANGES TAKE PLACE
IN OUR ECONOMY.
OF WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
NATURE OF THE JOBS THAT HAVE
BEEN LOST. AND THE JOBS THAT ARE
BEING GAINED.
A ONE OF THE CENTRAL QUESTIONS I
THINK WE FACE AT THE CURRENT
TIME IS THE DISAPPEARING MIDDLE
CLASS.
OUT WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
DYNAMICS THAT ARE AT WORK IN
SOCIETY SO THAT WE CAN
APPROPRIATELY LEGISLATE. OUR
AROUND THOSE ISSUES AND FOR THAT
REASON AND THE OTHER STATED HERE
TODAY I RESPECTFULLYASK HER
ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
APPRECIATE YOU STANDING IN TODAY
MISTER BLOOM THOSE WERE GREAT
CLOSING COMMENTS HOW BUT I'M NOT
GOOD AT PERMITS FOR ANYTHING.
THAT.
AND I TO THINK THOSE WHO THESE A
GOOD POLICY CHANGES AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
US SECRETARY CULTURAL THE MOTION
AS DO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY I
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABALLERO COME HERE I
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
SO SIX ZERO THANK YOU.
WHO?
WE'RE GONNA DO A LITTLE BIT TO
CLEAN UP BEFORE WE START BECAUSE
WE UNDERSTAND OF SOME REMEMBER
STONE MAY HAVE TO LEAVE SOLIS TO
THAT. BRENDA CLEAN UP RIGHT NOW.
OKAY.
OKAY THE BILLS ARE ON CALL.
A. B..
SO WAS ITEM NUMBER IN AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE BLOOM.
VOTERS FOR TO.
NOW YOU NEED TO. HAVE YOUR.
YEAH I KNOW YOU LIKE IT OUT HERE
WE ARE NOT GOING.
CURRENT VOTERS FOR TO TO COPY
EURO.
COVER YOUR AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
ROOM.
BILLS OUT SIX TO TWO.
OKAY LET'S DO AB TWENTY SIX
ANYONE DOES AREA.
HER VOTE IS FOR TWO.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
BUT SIX TWO BOTH THE I'M OF THE
BILLS OUT.
LET'S MOVE ON TO AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY TWO GLORIA FIRM VOTES FOR
TWO.
CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE STONE.
STONE I'VE OPPO.
BUT SO SIX TO.
AB THIRTY THIRTY SEVEN CHIU
CURRENT VOTES FOR TWO.
CABALLERO.
COVER YOUR AYE.
STONE.
STONE AYE BOCA.
BILLS OUT SIX TO.
ALRIGHT
SEVERAL CABALLERO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO DO TWENTY FIFTY.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AND THEN
FOLLOWED BY SIXTEEN RICHES AB
THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN.
SALUTE TO HIGH HAMMER ON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY FIFTY THE SMALL SYSTEM
WATER THIRTY ACT OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU.
BOB THIS STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED WATER SYSTEM STATEWIDE
THAT CHRONICALLY SERVED
CONTAMINATED DRINKING WATER A
CANNOT PROVIDE THE RESIDENTS A
RELIABLE WATER SOURCE. THE
SYSTEM SUFFER INADEQUATE
INFRASTRUCTURE OR LACK LOCAL
FINANCIAL MANAGERIAL AND
TECHNICAL RESOURCES BUT A VAST
MAJORITY OF THE SYSTEMS ARE
SMALL RURAL SYSTEMS THAT
TYPICALLY SERVE LESS THAN TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE. SO BASICALLY
WHAT WE WOULD DO IS SET UP AS I
AM INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO.
HELP THESE WATER SYSTEMS TO
CONSOLIDATE EVEN THOUGH
GEOGRAPHICALLY THEY MAY BE.
ALL OVER THE STATE SO THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE POTABLE WATER.
IT IS A.
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US
THAT'S BASICALLY HOW IT WOULD
WORK AS THE STATE BOARD WOULD
NOTIFY THE CHRONICALLY
NONCOMPLIANT SYSTEMS.
AND THEY WOULD BE PROVIDED WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DEVELOP A
PLAN.
IF A PLAN IS AN APPROVED THEN
THE STATE BOARD WOULD NOTIFY.
LITTLE HALF GOES AND THE LAUGH
GOES WOULD BE ABLE TO HELP TO
FACILITATE THE CONSOLIDATION
WITH ME IN SUPPORT TODAY IS JOHN
GILBERT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL. UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND PAUL JONES
GENERAL MANAGER OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
WELCOME SOMEONE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR STANDING
AS BEST I CAN FOR DON GILBERT
JASON I OCCURRED.
WITH IDLE STINK GILBERT ROPES
AND SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION.
I'M VERY PROUD TO BE HERE AS A
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY FIFTY AND
LIGHT OF HOW LONG YOU'RE HEARING
HAS GONE AND AND HOW LATE IT IS
AND HOW EAGER I'M SURE EVERYONE
HAS TO BE DONE AND I'M GONNA TRY
AND BE BRIEF.
SEE ANYWAYS MEMBERS PROVIDE
WATER SERVICE TO SEVENTY PERCENT
OF CALIFORNIANS.
THEY ARE IN THAT IS THEIR
MISSION THEIR MISSIONS PROVIDE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND THAT'S
A MISSION THAT SHOULD BE SHARED.
BY THE THE LOCAL WATER SYSTEMS
THAT ARE FAILING TO DO THAT THE
SMALL COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE FAILED TO DO THAT WITH
THEIR PRIVATE SYSTEMS. OR PUBLIC
SYSTEMS.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT A LOT IN THIS BUILDING FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS NOW NOT ONLY
THE CAPITAL BUT ALSO IN THE
WATER COMMUNITY.
THE STATE HAS SOME OF THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
BUT NOT ALL THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM. AND BY
CONSOLIDATING SYSTEMS AS
PROPOSED IN AB TWENTY FIFTY
WE'RE GONNA CREATE ECONOMIES OF
SCALE AND ALLOW OF THESE
DISTRICTS TO HAVE THE TECHNICAL
MANAGERIAL AND FINANCIAL
CAPACITY. TO ACTUALLY PROVIDES
THE SERVICE THAT THEY SHOULD BE
PROVIDING ARE READY TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND FOR THOSE
REASONS AGAIN WE'RE PROUD TO BE
A SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND.
WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TRAVAUX.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR OF
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE ON PAUL
JONES GENERAL MANAGER OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT FOR AN
AGENCY THAT PROVIDES WATER WASTE
WATER RECYCLE WATER TO EIGHT
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT COMMITTEE
FOR TAKING A UP AB TWENTY FIFTY
TODAY AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KEVIN EUROPE FOR
BRINGING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION FORWARD. ALSO LIKE
TO RECOGNIZE HIM YOU A FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP ON THE BILL UP OVER
THE PAST COURSE THAT PASSOVER
YEARS I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE INVOLVED IN SEVERAL. WATER
AGENCY CONSOLIDATIONS THAT HAVE
RESULTANT SUBSTANTIAL
IMPROVEMENTS IN WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE RELIABILITY AND
SERVICE HAVE ALSO BEEN PART OF
THE DISSOLUTION AND
CONSOLIDATION OF A PRIVATE WATER
SYSTEM. THAT HAVE BEEN SERVING
CONTAMINATE WATER TO SEVERELY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY UP FOR
NEARLY TWO DECADES AS NOTED BY
THE AUTHOR THE VAST AJORITY THE
SYSTEM SERVING CONTAMINATED
WATER VERY SMALL SYSTEMS. AND
REALLY LIKED THE CAPABILITIES
AND THE CUSTOMER RATE BASE TO
OPERATE A EFFECTIVELY.
FOR THE STRUGGLING SYSTEMS
CONSOLIDATION IS AN OPTION AND
IT HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE IN SOME
CASES BUT EVEN CONSOLIDATIONS
BETWEEN WILLING AGENCIES.
WITH WILLING PARTNERS CAN BE
VERY DEATH THE DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING ANTI A TIME
CONSUMING TO UNDERTAKE.
AB TWENTY FIFTIES UNIQUE IN THAT
PROVIDES A VERY INNOVATIVE
CONSOLIDATION TOOL WERE MULTIPLE
CHRONICALLY FAILING SYSTEMS ARE
SIMULTANEOUSLY DISSOLVED IN THEN
REFORMED INTO NEW LARGER MORE
TECHNICALLY AND FINANCIALLY
COMPETENT AGENCIES WITH REDUCED
OVERHEAD THROUGH ECONOMIES OF
SCALE.
SINCE THIS BILL IS REALLY.
FOR US A TOP PRIORITY IN SAFE
WATERS TRUCK PRIORITY THE BRILL
UP PROVIDES A VERY STRICT
TIMELINE AND STEP BY STEP
PROCESS TO DISSOLVE THOSE
FAILING SYSTEMS INTO CONDUCT THE
PROCEEDINGS FOR FORMING THE NEW.
COMPETENT WILL WATER AGENCIES IN
A REASONABLE TIMEFRAME AND
FINALLY TO ENSURES
ACCOUNTABILITY THE BILL.
BUILDS IN A POST FORMATION
OVERSIGHT PROCESS WITH AN
INDEPENDENT REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE START UP IN
FINANCIAL HEALTH OF THOSE
SYSTEMS. WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT
THROUGH THIS BILL THERE'S GOING
TO BE A SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN
THE OVERALL NUMBER OF THE SMALL
FAILING SYSTEMS IN THAT THE
NEWLY FORMED SMALL SYSTEM WATER
AUTHORITIES WILL VERY OFFICIALLY
DELIVER SAFE AND RELIABLE WATER.
TO VERY MANY COMMUNITIES IN NEED
AND IT'S FOR THESE RISKS REASONS
THAT I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY FIFTY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BROWN JR US WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
SPORTS THANK YOU.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
AND CAN YOU ON HIS ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES REPRESENTING OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY WATER
SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
TALK MAINLY WITH THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE MORAL ME HAVE A THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES AND SUPPORT AND
ONE I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THE
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS.
LAURIE JOHNSON WE HAVE THE
MONTEREY PENINSULA WATER
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT OF SUPPORT.
MORRELL HEREIN ON BEHALF OF THE
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THAT'S A LOSS ON BEHALF OF
INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN THE SCENE AND A WATERSHED
PROJECT AUTHORITY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CAROLYN JENSEN WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
I JUST HAD A MONTH ASSEMBLY HAVE
THE REGIONAL WATER AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROSY THOMPSON
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CANDIDATES
AGO AT THE CLOCK A GROUP ON
BEHALF OF LONG BEACH WATER
DEPARTMENT ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M RUN
DAVIS AND I'VE I'VE BEEN
AUTHORIZED BY AND AND A POOR
SUBSTITUTE FOR MARYAM WARMER DAM
WITH THEIR RURAL COUNTIES.
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. EXPRESSING THEIR
SUPPORT.
WE HAD MISTER BLOOM TO MR MEDINA
THAT'S OKAY.
NOT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS STEVE BIG
WITH THEIR REDUCES ITS FOR THE
WATER FOUNDATION.
THE WATER FOUNDATIONS DEDICATED
TO MAKING SURE THE CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN AFFORDABLE
DRINKING WATER AND THEY AGREE
THE CONSOLIDATION COULD BE A
TOOL TO HELP DO THAT. THEY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR TO
ADDRESS ANY POTENTIAL ISSUES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR EXCUSE ME I AM NOT
IN OPPOSITION FOREIGN SUPPORT.
SO WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION
YET BUT WOULD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE BRIEF COMMENTS.
A PAMELA MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LAUGHED GOES I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF.
AND THE SPONSORS AND WORKING
WITH US WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATION WITH THE SPONSORS
SINCE EARLY DECEMBER.
SO AND THIS IS A A VERY A BIG
IDEA.
AND WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
INTEREST.
IN THIS WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THE INTENT. OF GETTING ALL
CALIFORNIANS A SAFE INADEQUATE
DRINKING WATER. AND SINCE LAUGH
CHO SO INTRICATELY INVOLVED IN
THIS OP PROPOSED PROCESS AND WE
WE HAVE A HUGE INTEREST IN THIS
AND WANTING TO MAKE SURE WE GET
IT RIGHT. I GET IT RIGHT THE
FIRST TIME.
I WERE MAKING A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF PROGRESS AGAIN WE WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US ON WHICH IS STILL HAVE A
COUPLE OF THINGS AND I'M NOT
GOING TO GO INTO DETAIL GIVEN
THE LATE HOUR.
BUT THEY THEY HAVE ARE OF VERY
DETAILED FEEDBACK BUT. THE
TIMING IN THE FLOW OF IN TERMS
OF OF FORMATION AND DISSOLUTION
OF IT IS STILL JUST A LITTLE BIT
OFF OF IT SO WE ARE LIKE TO WORK
WITH HIM ON THAT.
.
A WITH RESPECT TO THE
DISSOLUTION PROCESS WE AND MAYBE
IT'S IN THERE AND WE'VE JUST ARE
OVERLOOKED IT. WE DO SEE A
REFERENCE AND A PROCESS FOR THE
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM TO BE
DISSOLVED BUT NOT A PUBLIC
AGENCY TO BE DISSOLVED BY THE
LAUGH CHO.
OH WE WANT TO WORK WITH THEM
HONOR QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
MODIFICATIONS. THAT THEY'LL
LAUGH CHO HAS AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE THE FORMATION BUT WITH
MODIFICATIONS SO WE HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT PROCESS.
WE HAVE SOME GOOD SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT BY HAVING SOME OF THIS
CODIFIED IN THE.
C. K. H. IN THE ACT THAT GOVERNS
LASCAUX. ON JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE WERE VERY CLEAR AND
COVERED THEIR.
AND AS WELL AS THE THE FUNDING.
WE MADE IT VERY CLEAR TO THE
SPONSORS.
VERY EARLY ON. ABOUT LAUGH CHO
FUNDING IN THIS COMMITTEE HAS
PROBABLY HEARD ME AD NAUSEUM
ABOUT THAT. I AND SO WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR MAKING SURE THAT
THAT IS IN THERE WE DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE FULLY
COVERED FROM THE BEGINNING.
THROUGH ALL THAT VERY LAST
ANNUAL REPORT AND PUBLIC HEARING
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE.
AND SO WE'VE OFFERED SOME OF
SUMMER GENERIC KIND OF LANGUAGE
TO AFOR CONSIDERATION AS
OPPOSED TO THEM WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT A A DOLLAR
AMOUNT NOT TO EXCEED.
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY NEW PROCESS
UNCHARTED TERRITORY WE DO NOT
KNOW HOW MUCH THIS WILL COST.
WE COULD GIVE SOME ESTIMATES
BUT I THINK IT'S VERY DANGEROUS
TO HAVEN'T NOT TO EXCEED DOLLAR
AMOUNT SO.
AND THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF OUR
COMMENTS AND.
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR
HAVE AGREED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH US WE
APPRECIATE.
NEGATIVE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS YES GOOD
AFTERNOON DAVID WOLF I WITH THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
FIFTY BUT QUITE FRANKLY
REGRETTABLE OPPOSE.
MEMBERS WE DO RECOGNIZE WHAT'S
IN THAT THERE ARE AT LEAST ONE
MILLION PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
MAINLY IN RURAL AREAS MAINLY
DEALING WITH THE SMALL DISTRICTS
BUT DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER AND WE DO ABSOLUTELY
FUNDAMENTALLY BELIEVE THIS IS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
SOLVED. AND BY AND LARGE THIS IS
A GOOD MEASURE TO DO IT.
YOU KNOW I DO APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENT TAKEN BY THE AUTHOR TO
FIX THE STAND BY CHARGES.
THAT WAS HALF THE REASON WHY WE
WERE OPPOSED TO THE BELL AND I
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH RON
DAVIS EIGHT EASTERN.
T. TAKE CARE OF THAT SITUATION.
WHICH AGAIN RESULTED IN YOU
KNOW HALF OF OUR OPPOSITION BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL
POSTCARDS ON PHILOSOPHICAL
GROUNDS.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT.
.
YOU KNOW WHILE.
WE BELIEVE BASICALLY THAT YOU
KNOW ANYTIME YOU'RE GIVING YOU
WITH STORIES BOND AUTHORITY THAT
ANYTIME YOU'RE SHOWN LONG TERM
DEBT THAT SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO A
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE ASSURING THAT
THE COULD LAST FAR BEYOND. THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL FISH OFFICIALS
HE PUT ON THE BALLOT TO KEEP IT
IN PLACE.
AND SO GETTING VOTER APPROVAL
GETTING A SUPERMAJORITY
THRESHOLD WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT IS PHILOSOPHICAL
WE'VE HAD THE SAME POSITION FOR
ANY NUMBER OF YEARS SAU
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST REMAIN
OPPOSED BUT. YOU KNOW VERY
ANXIOUS TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR TO TRY AND ADDRESS
THIS BECAUSE LIKE I SAID IT'S A
SERIOUS ISSUE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
A PILE OF THAT OPPOSE.
SING NONE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
YES ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
I JUST WANT TO JUMP IN AND OFFER
A COMMENT ABOUT THIS BILL I.
I CERTAINLY SEE THE VALUE OF IT.
BUT I ACTUALLY FEEL I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT HOW WELL IT'S
DRAFTED.
I'M AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
BUT YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT FORTY
PAGES OF NEW AD MATERIAL THAT
I'VE KIND OF GONE THROUGH. THE
THING I CHOOSE TO FOCUS ON IS IN
THE FINANCING PROVISIONS.
I'M READING THOSE PROVISIONS
BACK ON PAGES THIRTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT THE BILL I CONSIDER
AT THIS POINT VERY MUCH. A
MODEL.
VERY CONFUSING TO READ.
WE ARE TALKING APPROVING
DISTRICTS OF COURSE UNDER THE.
UNDER THE CODE IMPROVEMENT
DISTRICTS START WITH THE TWO
THIRDS.
SIGNING ON A PROPERTY OWNER SO
THAT'S GOOD.
WE'VE BEEN EXEMPTED FROM THE
ELECTION PROVISIONS.
IN THIS BILL.
THE THE REVENUE BOND WE WE
ACCEPT THE BONDS FROM ANY
ELECTION PROVISION.
AT THE SAME TIME THE ACTION OF.
ESTABLISHED A SYSTEM IS
REFERENDUM ALL.
SO OKAY YOU'RE EXEMPT FROM THE
ELECTION PROVISIONS BUT IT'S
REFERENDA BOWL WHO'S GOING TO BE
DOING THE VOTING.
WE TALK ABOUT.
I CAN'T SPEND THE MONEY ACCEPT
ANY IMPROVEMENT DISTRICTS.
BUT ALL THE SERVICE AREA
INCLUDES ADJACENT AREAS.
ADJACENT AREAS THAT ARE THERE AS
OF THE DATE OF THE ELECTION.
DOES NOT APPLY.
SO I JUST FEEL THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME CARE LOOKING AT THOSE
PROTECTING PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL.
PA.
AND.
SO I AM ACTUALLY TALKING TO
SEVENTY EIGHT ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT ONE OH TO.
READ IT CAREFULLY AND JUST THINK
ABOUT WHAT ARE THE MECHANICS OF
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT.
AND IS IT CLEAR.
BECAUSE I CAN'T TELL FROM THIS
WHAT AREAS ARE GETTING THE
BENEFIT WHO'S VOTING.
IS THAT THE PEOPLE WITHIN THE
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT AS AT THE
PARCEL TO JASON THE SHORTER
EXTENDED SERVICE IN TWO.
IT'S JUST A VERY MODEL PROVISION
OF LAW AND IT'S YOUR.
FINANCIAL PROVISIONS.
S. WHAT THE FINANCIAL PROVISIONS
ARE THAT CONFUSED.
AND CONCEPTS ARE APPEARING AND
DISAPPEARING HAS EXPLAINS HOW IT
WORKS IT'S JUST VERY CONCERNING
TO ME SO I'M JUST I'M AN AYE
VOTE TODAY.
ARE BUT I.
I NEED TO SEE IMPROVEMENT.
AND I JUST ATTENTION TO DETAIL I
DO UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU TRY TO
CRAFT SOMETHING NEW.
THAT SHOULD DO THE BEST YOU CAN.
AND I RESPECT THAT THIS IS A A
WHAT THAT SORT OF EFFORT.
BUT I'M JUST SEEM WHEN I SIT
DOWN TO READ IT THERE'S THINGS
THAT ARE. INCOMPREHENSIBLE. AND.
ONCE IN THE FINANCIAL VISION
PROTECT FOR THAT SORT OF
CONCERNING. I DON'T KNOW HOW
THIS REFERENCE BRIGHT APPLIES
WHO HAS THE. RIGHT TO VOTE.
WHAT'S THE ELECTION THE TAXES
AREA TO THE IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT
WHEN THERE ISN'T ELECTIONS HOLE.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY I DO HAVE A A MOTION AND A
SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MEMBERS I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND.
ABSOLUTE WILL REVIEW THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR.
YOUR ATTENTION TO DETAIL ON THE
BOTTOM LINE IS SERVING
CONTAMINATED WATER.
TO.
RESIDENCES REALLY UNACCEPTABLE
IN THIS IS ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES.
THAT WE THINK WE COULD MAKE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA SO WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
OKAY.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD I'M WE STRUGGLE IN
MY COMMUNITIES.
GET MAKING SURE OF SAFE GOOD
QUALITY WATER. AND THIS IS
GIVING US ANOTHER TOOL TO DO
THAT.
BUT I WILL SAY IS THAT I DO
HAVE CONCERNS THAT.
MISTER COOLEY BROUGHT UP SOME I
I'M CONFIDENT HE'LL WORK ON
THOSE.
BUT I DO WANT TO SHARE THE CAL
OFF GOES A CONCERNS ABOUT
FUNDING ARE REALLY PRETTY HIGH
PRIORITY AS WELL.
I'VE BEEN ON THE CAL OFF GO BUT
THEN THE LEFT ABOARD FEEL COUNTY
BEFORE. A FUNDING HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A KIND OF AN ISSUE THE
PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT THEM. AND SO
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN CONTINUE WORKING ON
NEGOTIATIONS WITH CAL LEFT
THOUGH.
AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE AT THE
TABLE I'M ALSO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TOTALLY I LOVE
THIS BILL I THINK IT'S GOING TO
HELP A LOT OF OUR RURAL
COMMUNITIES. AND WHEN YOU'RE
TRYING TO SPREAD THE COST.
FOR A SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT ON TWELVE HUNDRED.
HOOKUPS IT JUST DOESN'T
PENINSULA.
AND SO WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES I'M ALL AND
STUFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD THINKING.
US SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ADWARE CURRY. AYE
WHERE CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM.
BLOOM I COME THE AERO COMEY EURO
AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING STONE. VOEPEL.
BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
RIGHT WE ARE UP ON A A. B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN.
AND WE'LL GET HER STUFF AND
EVERYONE APPEAR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA IS IS IN THE DEPTHS
OF A HOUSING CRISIS
MARKED BY A SEVERE LACK OF HOMES
AND APARTMENTS AFFORDABLE TO
VERY LOW LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES.
THERE IS MUCH TO DO TO EXPEDITE
THE PROCESS OF BUILDING HOMES
AND TO MAKE IT LESS EXPENSIVE TO
BUILD.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS TO
INCREASING SUPPLY AND
AFFORDABILITY IS THE IMPOSITION
OF EXCESSIVE.
EXCESSIVE IMPACT AND DEVELOPER
FEES THAT WERE NOT REQUIRED BY
THE CITY OR COUNTY IN INITIAL
COMMUNICATIONS AND THAT ADD
SIGNIFICANTLY TO THE OVERALL
COST OF THE PROPOSED HOUSING
UNITS. THAT'S WHY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT A. B. THIRTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN TODAY WHICH WOULD PROHIBIT
CITIES AND COUNTIES FROM
CHARGING OR ADDING NEW IMPACT
AND DEVELOPMENT FEES. TO
APPLICANTS FOR HOUSING PROJECTS
ONCE AN APPLICATION IS DEEMED
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE BY THE
JURISDICTION. THESE NEW IMPACT
OR DEVELOPMENT.
FEES ARE USUALLY REQUIRED AS A
CONDITION FOR APPROVAL OF ANY
PROJECT AND THE DEVELOPER HAS NO
RECOURSE BUT TO AGREE TO THEM IF
THEY WANT THE PROJECT APPROVED.
HOWEVER ALL TOO OFTEN THE FEES
ARE REVEALED LATE IN THE PROCESS
WHILE AFTER A DEVELOPER HAS
BUDGETED FOR THE PROJECT AND IT
STARTED TO SPEND MONEY ON
PROPERTY ACQUISITION THE
PROFESSIONALS BASED ON PUBLIC
FEE SCHEDULES.
I'VE SPOKEN TO MANY STAKEHOLDERS
STAFF AND MEMBERS ON THIS ISSUE
WHILE WE MAY NOT ALL AGREE ON
THE SOLUTION ONE THING REMAINS
CLEAR THERE IS A PROBLEM. IN
FACT ACCORDING TO A RECENT UC
BERKELEY TURNER CENTER FOR
HOUSING AND INNOVATION STUDY.
CERTAINTY FOR DEVELOPER FEES IS
A SIMPLE POLICY CHANGE.
THAT POLICY MAKERS AT ALL LEVELS
WORKING TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE SHOULD BEGIN WITH.
IT IS BECOME INCREASINGLY MORE
DIFFICULT.
AS A BUILDER TO BUDGET A PROJECT
THAT I'VE MISSED THE UNCERTAINTY
AS TO WHAT FEES EXACTIONS A
REQUIREMENTS COULD COME INTO
PLAY AT ANY STAGE OF THE
PROCESS.
WHEN DEVELOPMENT FEELS FEES ARE
NOT REVEALED NOT READILY
ACCESSIBLE REASONABLE AND
PREDICTABLE IT IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT.
A PLAN BUDGET AND BUILD WHICH
ONLY EXACERBATES CALIFORNIA'S
HOW'D HOUSING SHORTAGE.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF LOCAL
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
SUGGESTED BY THE COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER I CANNOT ACCEPT ALL OF
THE AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED IN
THE ANALYSIS.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SUGGESTS
REQUIRING CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
PUBLISH A FEE SCHEDULE ON THE
WEBSITE.
NOT ONLY IS THIS COSTLY BUT
THERE IS NO WAY TO ENFORCE THIS
PROVISION AND FRANKLY I'M NOT
WILLING TO IMPOSE REQUIREMENTS
WITHOUT ENFORCEMENT ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM IN HOUSING.
ARENA. AYE I'VE DONE THAT
BEFORE AND IT DOESN'T WORK
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ALSO SUGGESTS
FREEZING IMPACT IN DEVELOPMENT
FEES AT THE POINT THAT A PROJECT
IS ENTITLED. INSTEAD OF WHEN THE
APP APPLICATION IS APPROVED.
FREEZING THE FEES AT THE POINT
UP ENTITLEMENT DOESN'T WORK
PROJECTS CAN BE IN THE
ENTITLEMENT PROCESS.
FOR YEARS ALL THE WHILE FEES CAN
BE ADDED IN PROJECTS DON'T
PENCIL OUT.
AB THIRTY ONE FORTY SEVEN PASSED
OUT OF THE HOUSING ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE THIS MORNING
ON A SEVEN TO ZERO VOTE.
I WORKED WITH THE WITH THE
CHAIR.
AND WE NEGOTIATED A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS.
AND I IT IF THIS BILL PASSES
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY I
WILL TAKE THEM IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN OUT WRITTEN UP THEY
WERE.
READY AT QUITE SOME TIME AGO
THEY DEFINE IMPACT IN
DEVELOPMENT FEES AS DRAFTED IN
NINE BE OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WHICH STATES THAT THESE
THOSE FEES THAT ARE ESTABLISHED
BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SEPARATE FROM ITS ACTION ON A
SPECIFIC APPLICATION AND ARE
LIMITED TO FEES IMPOSED UNDER
THE FEE MEDICATION ACT IT'S IN
THAT IT'S IN OUR.
OUR ANALYSIS.
IT THEY THAT FREES THE FEES
WHEN THE APPLICATION IS
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE BUT ADD
THREE OFF RAMPS THAT PROVIDE
RELIEF FROM THESE REQUIREMENTS
IN RESPONSE TO THE SEQUENCE
ANALYSIS. IN RESPONSE TO HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE ISSUES AND
INFLATION COST ESCALATORS.
AND THREE THEY FREEZE THE FEES
FOR UP TO TWO YEARS INSTEAD OF
THE FIVE THAT WAS ORIGINALLY IN
IN IN OUR PROPOSAL.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND ONE
WE CANNOT IGNORE. I'M COMMITTED
TO WORKING ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. WITH ME
IN SUPPORT IS ALYSSA STINSON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND MARINO
WE AT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM.
SO JUST
JUST LIKE FOREVER FOREGO FOR THE
FOR THE COMMITTEE TODAY WERE
JUST DOING AS THE BILL THAT IS
WRITTEN UNDERSTAND AND WE'RE
TAKING AMENDMENTS TO TAKE THOSE
WHATEVER THEY ARE OVER IN
APPROPRIATIONS CORRECT OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ASSISTANCE AND
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY THE SPONSORS
OF EIGHTY THIRTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF
AND SECOND WHAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
HAS SO EXPERTLY STATED ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THIS BILL BUT ALSO
LIKE KILEY BEGAN THE NATURE OF
THE HOUSING CRISIS AND HOW THIS
BILL WOULD TAKE A STEP IN
ADDRESSING THAT.
WE'RE ALL WELL AWARE OF JUST HOW
DIRE THIS HOUSING CRISIS HAS
BEEN SINCE THE BOTTOM OF THE
GREAT RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE THIS IS BEEN THE SLOWEST
RECOVERY IN HISTORY AND WE ARE
STILL NOWHERE NEAR. A HEALTHY
HOUSING MARKET EVERYDAY WE SEE
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY WORSE AND WHILE
THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET WE CAN
TAKE MEANINGFUL STEPS TO ASSURE
TO ENSURING TRANSPARENCY IN
CONTAINING COSTS.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THOSE
MEANINGFUL STEPS BY SEEKING TO
PROVIDE CERTAINTY AROUND THE
CONSTANTLY CHANGING FEES THAT
ARE LEVIED ON HOUSING PROJECTS.
WHILE WE HAVE GROWN ACCUSTOMED
TO PAYING THESE IMPACT FEES AS A
CONDITION OF APPROVAL. THERE IS
ALSO A GROWING CONCERN THAT
THESE EXACTIONS ARE REVEALED
LATE IN THE PROCESS CAUSING
PROJECTS TO BE RECONSIDERED AND
DRIVING UP THE COST ON FUTURE
HOME BUYERS.
CREATING THE SURETIES AROUND THE
FEES INVOLVING INVOLVED IN A
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT ALLOWS US TO
PROVIDE HOUSING AT ALL AND
LEVELS THAT CITIZENS CAN
ACTUALLY AFFORD. EACH LATE HEAD
CANNOT THOUSANDS TOOK THE COSTS
AND IN CALIFORNIA EVERY TIME
THERE'S AN INCREASE IN THE COST
OF A HOME BY A THOUSAND DOLLARS
IF PRICES ARE OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND FAMILIES.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
THE UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTERS
FOR AFFORDABLE OR FOR HOUSING
FICTION RELEASED A STUDY LAST
MONTH. REGARDING THE OVERALL
COST OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENT FEES
BY DOING A CASE STUDY OF SEVEN
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
AMONG THEIR MAIN FINDINGS THEY
SUGGESTED THAT CALIFORNIA
ADOPTED FEE TRANSPARENCY POLICY
AND IMPLEMENT BEST PRACTICES FOR
CITING IN CHARGING FEES AND TO
DEFINE WHEN THE FEES CAN BE
LEVIED AND CHARGE DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS.
I WOULD AGAIN LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE I HAVE CBA GENERAL
COUNSEL NICK CAMMARATA HERE FOR.
WITH ME FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MARINO MIGHT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
AS YOU ARE ALL WELL AWARE. IT'S
VERY CHALLENGING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS TO BUILD THE
STATE BECAUSE OF THE MANY
DIFFERENT LAYERS THE FINANCING
THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO PUT
TOGETHER ANY OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE MORE CERTAINTY IN THE
PROCESS. AND THE COST IS ABOUT
MAKE THAT MUCH EASIER FOR THEM
TO DO THEIR DEVELOPMENT
AND SO WE URGE YOUR I'VE OF
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SO AS A MATTER NOT LIKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA'S WALLS CALIFORNIA
UNION SUPPORT.
MADISON Y. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
AND RIGHTLY HERE ON BEHALF OF
CAL CHAMBER ALSO IN SUPPORT.
JOHN LEWIS OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SAYING
NONE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ONE UP MY HAVE SWITCHED SEATS UP
HERE.
HELLO GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JASON RILEY CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
AND VIRTUALLY YES WE HAVE TO A
OPPOSE THIS MEASURE I THINK
EITHER A COUPLE.
A COUPLE OF. REALLY BIG ISSUES
HERE THAT WHEN IT COMES AND THE
FEES ARE ALL TALK ABOUT
MITIGATION FEE ACT. ON WHAT WE
ARE HIGHLY REGULATED HOW WE CAN
CHARGE FEES ON THOSE FEES ITO DO
VARY FROM COMMUNITY TO
COMMUNITY.
BASED ON A WHOLE HOST OF REASONS
I'M BUT THE ONE THING I THINK TO
MAKE VERY VERY CLEAR IS THAT.
THESE FEES ARE LAWFUL AND THESE
FEES ARE SUBJECT TO NOT ONLY
MITIGATION FEE ACT BUT ALSO
SUBJECT TO THE CONSTITUTION. AND
THESE FEES ARE OF TO PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR THE DEVELOPMENT TO
PAY FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE DEVELOPMENT TO PAY FOR THE
PARKS THE LIBRARIES THE POLICE
SERVICE. EVERYTHING THAT'S
NEEDED FOR THIS DEVELOPMENT HAS
TO COME OUT OF THESE.
FUNDS FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
AND MOST NOTABLY PROP THIRTEEN
AND WE CANNOT SPREAD THE COST OF
OF THIS DEVELOPMENT ON TO PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT GOING TO BENEFIT
FROM THIS DEVELOPMENT SO. THAT'S
WHY THAT THE FEES ARE WHAT THEY
ARE I'M IN IT IT IS A IT IS A
REAL STRUGGLE SO I I CERTAINLY
SYMPATHIZE WITH WITH THE
DEVELOPERS. ONE THING TO MAKE
CLEAR IS THAT WE'RE NOT HERE TO
PLAY A GAME OF GOTCHA WITH THE
DEVELOPERS AND WE CERTAINLY WANT
TO TELL THEM WHAT THE FEES ARE.
SOME OF THESE FEES WE DO NOT
KNOW AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THE PROCESS SO MAKES IT
DIFFICULT THEN TO A DETERMINE
WHAT THOSE FEES ARE ACTUALLY
GONNA BE. SO I MEAN IF IT'S
ABOUT TELLING DEVELOPER EXACTLY
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO
ADD IN A DEVELOPING GREAT WE
CERTAINLY CAN DO THAT. I'M BUT
TO FREEZE THESE FEES AND OUR
MINDS AT LEAST ESSENTIALLY
REWARDS ARE DEVELOPERS
DEVELOPING APPROVED PROJECTS WE
DON'T BUILD THE HOMES THE
DEVELOPERS BUILD HOMES SO IF
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW THEM TO TO
NOT DEVELOP FOR YEARS IN FREEZE
THOSE FEES. WHILE THE COST OF
PROVIDING THAT INS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE CONTINUES TO
ESCALATE SEEM COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
IN FOR THAT WE HAVE TO POST.
CITY JOYS OF SENDING AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION I'M AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH AUTHORS
OFFICE IN THE SPONSORS AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT. I WON IT THERE
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE AMENDMENT SO
WERE AT A DISADVANTAGE HERE AND
I THINK THAT'S PART OF OUR
CONCERN. BUT THERE'S TWO ISSUES
THAT ACTUALLY WERE BROUGHT UP
AND ONE IS THAT THE FEES WOULD
BE LOCKED IN. AYE OUT
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLETENESS.
THAT'S A BRAND NEW TERM WOULD
UNDERSTAND WHY THAT WOULD BE
PART OF THE DISCUSSION IT'S
EITHER COMPLETE OR IT'S NOT WE
WOULD DEFINITELY NOT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
FEES WHEN WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE
INFORMATION WE HAVE MADE THAT
DETERMINATION THAT'S. COMPLETE.
THAT'S A MAJOR PROBLEM FOR US
BECAUSE WE DON'T NOT WANT NEW
TERMS AND REQUIREMENTS IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PROCESS HAS BEEN.
THE SECOND IS THAT.
I THINK AS AS A LEAGUE NOTED.
WE WON'T KNOW THE EXACT.
PROJECT INTEL IT'S AT THE
ENTITLED STAGE ONES AT
ENTITLEMENT THEM WE KNOW HOW
MANY SQUARE FEET IS HOW MANY
UNITS THERE'S GOING TO BE ALL
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE BASE
OUR FEES ON. WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
GIVE AN ESTIMATE. AT THE TIME OF
THE COMPLETE APPLICATION.
BECAUSE WE DO STE DO A SCHEDULE
OF FEES WE KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
WHAT KIND OF UNITS WOULD APPLY.
AND THEY WOULD APPLY TO AND HOW
THEIR.
ASSESS WHETHER IT'S BY UNIT BY
SQUARE FOOTAGE BY OF OTHER
IMPACTS.
BUT IF THE PROJECT IS IS
CHANGED ASIDE FROM SECA.
IF IT'S CHANGED OVER THAT
PERIOD OF TIME WHETHER IT'S.
FORWARD DESIGN REVIEW OR
ANYTHING ELSE IS A GOES TO THE
PROJECT.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THE CHANGES OF YOUR IDENTIFYING
THE APPROPRIATE IMPACT AND THE
APPROPRIATE IMPACT FEES THEY MAY
GO UP OR DOWN.
BUT IN ANY EVENT WE DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION AT THE TIME OF
A COMPLETE APPLICATION.
BUT WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO GIVE
AN ESTIMATE THERE.
I THINK YOU'RE OTHERS THAT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN OPPOSITION.
TO ONE OF OUR SOME HAVE URBAN
CARRIES A CALIFORNIA ALSO HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTIES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESS ISN'T THAT
OPPOSE.
SING NONE ARE QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST A COUPLE
THINGS REAL QUICK AND WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT.
TO.
SOME TESTIMONY BY OPPOSITION.
SPEAKING AS A GENERAL
CONTRACTOR.
WITH THAT STONE ACTIVE LICENSE.
AS WELL AS A MAYOR OF A CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER CITY SOMEONE
THAT'S BEEN THROUGH THE PLANNING
PROCESS AS WELL AS POINT
PERMITS.
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLETE A
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE
APPLICATION IS NOT A NEW TERM.
BUT IS A TERM THAT'S BEEN USED
LEAST TEN.
JURISDICTION I HAVE BOTH HAD TO
PULL A PERMIT AND AS WELL AS
SERVING AND.
AS ELECTED OFFICIAL HAS BEEN
USED UP CONSIDERABLY.
AND SO HAVING NOT HAVING SAID
THAT.
APPLICATIONS DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO BE COMPLETE OR NOT
COMPLETE THERE IS A STAGE WHERE
THEY REACH SUBSTANTIAL.
COMPLETION
OF A NAP OF FOUR FOUR PERMIT OR
FOR A DEVELOPMENT. AND I DO HAVE
A QUESTION AND NOT SURE FROM
WHAT SOURCES GOING TO COME FROM.
HOWEVER I THINK I MIGHT KNOW
THE ANSWER IN MY HEAD BUT THERE
IS A TIME LIMIT. FOR WHICH A
CITY MUST REVIEW.
APPLICATIONS FOR DEVELOPMENT IS
THAT THE CASE.
WE HAVE THE PERMIT STREAMLINED
ACT APPLIES AND THEN YOU HAVE
YOU KNOW VESTED TENET AMOUNTS
INTO MEMPHIS ALL SORTS OF
TIMELINES AND. AND YOU KNOW YOU.
RIGHT SO THAT THAT TIME.
TABLE IS THERE SO I UNDERSTAND
THE CITIES HAVE TO CONFORM TO
THAT TIME TABLE.
HERE'S WHERE THE STRUGGLE
HAPPENS
IS WHEN A DEVELOPER COMES THEY
MEET THE DESIGN REVIEW BOARD.
THEN ONCE THEY PASSED THAT
DESIGN REVIEW BOARD BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING PUSHED BY THE TIME
LIMIT.
THEN THEY GET INTO THE PLANNING
COMMISSION STAGE ONCE WE GET
INTO THE PLANNING COMMISSION
STAGE.
PLANNING COMMISSIONERS OF OR
STAFF RECOMMENDING TO PLANNING
COMMISSIONERS MAY END UP SENDING
THAT PROJECT.
BACK TO THE DESIGN REVIEW WELL
IN ORDER TO GET THE PLANNING
STAGE IN HAVING GONE THAT FAR
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A PERFORMER
THAT IS DONE.
PROJECTS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
PRICED OUT BY THE TIME WE GET
SENT BACK TO DESIGN REVIEW TO
MAKE CHANGES THE DESIGN REVIEW
OR TAKES THE LIBERTY AT THAT
POINT TO GO EVEN FURTHER.
OR TAKE AWAY TO THE POINT THAT
IT DOES IMPACT THE COST OF A JOB
OR A PROJECT I I'VE RARELY EVER
SEEN IT GO DOWN.
EVER.
IS IN MY IN MY KNOWLEDGE.
BUT I HAVE SEEN IT MULTIPLE
TIMES INCREASE.
I EVEN TO THE POINT AND I WILL
TELL YOU THIS AS A.
AS A MEMBER ON THE COUNCIL
THAT.
PROBABLY ONE OF THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUES THAT I FACED A
COMPLAINTS.
WAS.
GOING THROUGH AND I THOUGHT I
FELT LIKE WE HAD A PRETTY
DECENT.
PROCESS
BUT EVEN THEN IT WAS GOING
THROUGH THAT PLANNING PROCESS
AND HITTING THOSE BOMBS AND THEN
ADDITIONAL COST COMING AFTER A
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE
APPLICATION.
SO I WOULD I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE ATTEMPT THAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO MAKE ALONG WITH YOUR.
WITH YOUR WORK ABILITY WITH
OPPOSITION
TRY TO COME UP WITH SOME TYPE OF
A A COMPROMISE AND I BELIEVE
YOU'RE ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS I
KNOW THEY'RE BRAND NEW. SO SOME
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO SEE IT.
SO IF I COULD IF I COULD DAM.
RESPOND TO THAT PART OF THE
CHALLENGE WAS THE.
.
THE EXPEDITED.
DOUBLE REFERRAL SYSTEM PRODUCT
UP FRANKLY.
MANY OF THE AMENDMENTS WERE
EXACTLY THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
REQUESTED. BOTH BY THE APA AND
BY THE LEAGUE OF CITIES AND SO
MY MY APOLOGIES IT IN IN TERMS
OF THIS PROCESS BUT. WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS THAT.
IS THAT SPECIFICALLY IN THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE THINGS THAT THEY
SUGGESTED THAT WE WORK ON THAT
WORK THE JOB ISN'T DONE YET. WE
WANT TO CONTINUE WORKING ON IT
BUT.
THERE'S WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
QUIBBLE WITH THE MITIGATION ACT
AND HOW THAT OPERATES THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO.
AMELIORATE AGAINST WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MILLION RATE AGAINST
ARE THOSE.
THOSE INSTANCES WHERE I MEET
SOMEBODY MENTIONED TODAY FOR
EXAMPLE A FIRE STATION IS
NEEDED.
YOU PLAN FOR THAT WHEN YOU
START.
YOU KNOW ADDING ADDITIONAL
RESIDENCES THAT'S ALREADY IN
GENERAL PLANS AND SPECIFIC
PLANTS AND SO. SO TO NOT HAVE
TOLD SOMEBODY UP FRONT THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY INTO
IT MEANS THAT THEY DIDN'T DO THE
WORK. NECESSARILY TO BE ABLE TO
GET THAT FEE IN PLACE AND SO TO
STICK IT ON AT THE END REALLY
BLOWS THE BUDGETS BUT NOT SO
ANYWAY THAT YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THERE MOST OF THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE IN RESPONSE TO
THINGS THAT WE HEARD.
AS DEAD AS THE BILL WAS WAS
WAITING IN THE FIRST COMMITTEE
AND IF I UNDERSTAND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO THAT.
THERE WAS ONE AMENDMENT THAT
YOU WERE SAYING.
WOULD NOT.
CONSIDERING THAT WAS THE ONE
ABOUT THE WEBSITE AND PUTTING
THE FEES UP THERE JUST JUST TO
STATE. THAT I AUTHORED A BILL
LAST YEAR THAT WAS IN THE
PACKAGE OF HOUSING.
AB EIGHT SEVENTY NINE THAT
CALLS FOR A STUDY.
FROM THE HOUSING AND.
REQUIRES THAT THERE BE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ACTIONS TO
BE TAKEN ON THE REASON ABILITY
OF OF FEES AND SO POSSIBLY THIS
AMENDMENT WOULD FIT BETTER IN
ANOTHER HOUSING BILL THAT WOULD
COME FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD. WHEN
THAT ACTUALLY HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED AND AND STUDIED OUT
SO I APPRECIATE THAT. AS AROUND
AS WELL AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME STRIFE BETWEEN
THE BILL YOU HAVE VERSES. THE
WHAT THE COMMITTEES ARE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH AND HOPEFULLY THAT
CAN GET WORKED OUT AS WELL. A
ONE OF THE THINGS A REAL QUICK
AND THE STATE WAS TALKED ABOUT
AS FAR AS THE FAIRNESS OF THE
FEES AND THE WAY CITIES.
THEM HERE'S A RESULT OF OF OUR
PROP THIRTEEN AND THAT WAS THE
ONLY FOR CITIES TO RECOVER FROM
THAT WAS TO INSTITUTE FEES.
RATHER THAN TAXES
AND.
I CAN GIVE YOU ANTIDOTE OF OF
IT OUGHT NOT ALWAYS BEING FAIR
BUT CITIES TAKEN ADVANTAGE. OF A
PROJECT TO.
CREATE REVENUE WILL RAISE
REVENUE WHEN IT REALLY WASN'T
NECESSARY.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY APPROVAL
PROJECT.
OF OVER THIRTY FIVE SQUARE FEET.
IN WHICH.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE HAD ALREADY
BEEN IMPROVED AT.
THE COST OF THE DEVELOPER.
AND YET THEY STILL CHARGED รณ
SAID FEES.
FOR THAT SAME INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WAS ALREADY IMPROVED.
ONLY BECAUSE THEY COULD EVEN IN
THE APPEALS PROCESS SO.
THERE THERE ARE.
THERE IS GREAT LIFT LEGITIMACY
TO THIS BILL AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE IT.
TODAY MOVE FORWARD AND SEE YOU
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH IT AND
THEN WE RE VISITED ON THE FLOOR
IF IT REACHES THAT FAR. AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT YOU ABLE TO GET
TO A PLACE WHERE IT'S PALATABLE
OF FOR ALL PARTIES.
SO WITH THAT I WOULD MOVE THE
BILL.
IT REMAINS.
GOOD.
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
.
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
I THINK YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION
AND IT'S BEEN VERY FEW FRUITFUL
I APPRECIATED AND AND MY GOAL IS
TO CONTINUE WORKING MOVE WHAT WE
WANT THIS TO WORK.
WE WORKED VERY HARD WITH THE.
THE CHAIR OF HOUSING AND AND I
THINK THAT'S A REASON IT WAS A
SEVEN ZERO.
.
YEAH VOTE OUT OF THE HOUSE
TODAY.
AND.
I APPRECIATE THE YEAR WORKING
ON THE BILL I'M GONNA PURSUE
LAYOFF THE BILL TODAY BECAUSE I
WANTED TO SEE THE AMENDMENTS IN
THEY'VE CHANGE FROM. WHAT I
HEARD IN HOUSING AND WATCH IT
TODAY AND I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
I'M CLEAR ON THE I RT JUST TO BE
VERY CLEAR IF IT THAT YOUR STAFF
HAS HAD THE AMENDMENTS? FOR
SINCE LAST WEEK AND THEY WERE IT
IT'S TRUE IT WAS A PIECE OF THIS
AND A PIECE OF THAT.
.
IT IN HOUSING BUT.
BUT THE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN IN
PRINT AND THEY HAVE HAD AND THEY
HAVE HAD THE ADVANTAGE OF
LOOKING AT THOSE JUST TO BE
CLEAR. WE RECEIVED THEM ON
THURSDAY WHINING AND ON MONDAY
BUT THAT'S NOT NEITHER HERE THAT
IS JUST A PROCESS. AND WE CAN
GET THROUGH THIS OKAY SO.
I WILL BE BECAUSE.
NOT VOTING TODAY WITHOUT WILL
THE SECRETARY TO.
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSING REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WE ARE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY NOT VOTING WALDRON.
WALDRON AYE BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CABALLERO CUMPLIR AYE COOLEY.
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
STONE.
STONE NO.
VOEPEL.
FIVE ONE BILLS UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WELCOME.
OKAY.
.
LET'S SAY THIS IS A FILE NUMBER
LET'S RETURN REAPPEAR.
AB THREE ONE ONE NINE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN WELCOME MS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
I THINK YOU KNOW.
AND I'M.
I JUST AS ALWAYS WANT TO START
BY THANKING YOU ARE AWESOME.
COMMITTEE STAFF WHO WILL.
ALWAYS HELP ME TAKE MY IDEAS AND
PUT THEM INTO ACTION SO I I I
NEED.
MUST SAY BESIDES MY OWN IT I
MOST LOVE WORKING WITH THE STAFF
TO.
WALKS ME THROUGH MY CRAZY IDEAS
THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME AND AB
THIRD THIRTY ONE NINETEEN WOULD
CREATE THE SAN DIEGO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT MOBILITY
AND SUSTAINABILITY COMMITTEE TO
EXAMINE ISSUES IMPACTING THE
FUTURE OF THE AIRPORT
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY IMMUNITY.
THE SAN DIEGO REGIONAL AIRPORT
THIRTY WAS CREATED BY STATE
LEGISLATION IS THE INDEPENDENCE
HAN AMISS ENTITY TO MANAGE THE
AIRPORT OVERSEE LAND USE
PLANNING FOR THE AIRPORT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY AND
INVESTIGATE.
POTENTIAL MOVE TO OF THE
LOCATION OF THE INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT.
AFTER FAIL APPEAL BALLOT MEASURE
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THE AIRPORT WOULD
REMAIN WHERE IT IS HOWEVER SINCE
THEN THE PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT BETWEEN THE AIRPORT
OTHER AGENCY HAS LACKED
COORDINATION LEADING TO PROBLEMS
FOR THE COMMUNITY. THESE ARE
PROBLEMS THAT DEAL WITH
CONGESTION PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
THE ENVIRONMENT.
.
TRY TO GET THROUGH THIS
IT'S PAST.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE? IS
CREATE UNDER THE AIRPORT
AUTHORITY BUT THE REFEREE WILL
CREATE. A COMMITTEE UNDER THE
AIRPORT'S RD WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE AIRPORT
THE PORT. DISTRICT THE SITTING
COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND THREE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES THE
COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE ONE YEAR TO
CLAP. COLLABORATIVELY CREATE A
PLAN REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE SINCE THIS WAS
CREATED LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES INCLUDING
ROAD CONGESTION UNMET TRANSIT
NEEDS AND ACCESS TO PUBLIC
TRANSIT ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
SUCH AS SEA LEVEL RISE.
WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE ON AND
AFTER A NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDER
MEETING THINKING WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE SUPPORT OF
BOTH THE PORT AND THE AIRPORT.
WELCOME.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
ROUGHLY ACROSS THE ANALYSTS I AM
THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD POOR
COMMISSIONERS OF THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO.
ON BEHALF OF THE PORT I AM HERE
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE NINETEEN THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO THE SAN
DIEGO BAY WATERFRONT CITIES
CONTRIBUTED THEIR WATERFRONT
LAND TO THE STATE'S NEWLY
CREATED. PORT OF SAN DIEGO TO
AVOID PROBLEMS CREATED BY LACK
OF COORDINATION AND COMPETING
INTERESTS.
THE LEGISLATURE'S FORESIGHT HAS
BEEN REWARDED WITH BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE
AND PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT.
WE JUST TURN THE PORT OF SAN
DIEGO INTO A MAJOR PART OF THE
NATION'S TRANSPORTATION AND
GOODS MOVEMENT NETWORK WHICH
CONTRIBUTES OVER EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR OF ECONOMIC
IMPACT. AND HAS CREATED OVER
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND JOBS.
THE SAN DIEGO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASSETS.
ON THIS STATE LAND.
TOGETHER WE ARE PROJECTING
MILLIONS OF ADDITIONAL AIRLINE
PASSENGERS
THREE BILLION DOLLARS A PROPOSED
DEVELOPMENT ON THE WATERFRONT.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
ADDITIONAL CRUISE PASSENGERS
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
COLLABORATION IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER IN THIS IS WHAT WE
NEED.
THIS BILL.
RECENT TRAFFIC STUDY SEEN BY THE
PORT THE AIRPORT THE CITY AND
THE COUNTY CHAU. GRIDLOCK.
IF WE DO NOT ENGAGE IN TRANSIT
PLANNING AND PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION TO REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED.
A KEY STRATEGY IDENTIFIED BY THE
STATE'S GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
GOALS.
CURRENTLY PUBLIC TRANSIT OPTIONS
TO THE AIRPORT ARE EXTREMELY
LIMITED WITHOUT ANY EASY OPTION
FOR LIGHT RAIL. AS IS THE CASE
IN MANY METROPOLITAN AREAS.
AND SEA LEVEL RISE THREATENS THE
LONG TERM VIABILITY OF THE
AIRPORT.
THOSE IMPACTS INCLUDING FLOODING
AND STORM SURGE MUST BE PLANNED
FOR IN ACCORDANCE WITH STATE
REQUIREMENTS.
IT'S NOT JUST A GOOD IDEA IT'S
THE LAW.
WE NEED TO FIND SOLUTIONS RIGHT
NOW THAT WILL ENSURE ACTION. AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO MANAGE THESE
ISSUES.
SO THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
IS TO HAVE A REGIONAL
CONVERSATION AND CREATION OF NOT
EXECUTED WILL PLAN AND THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW THIS.
IT WILL ENSURE THAT THE STATE
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSES MATTERS.
OF STATEWIDE CONCERN WHILE
MAKING SURE THAT LOCAL IMPACTS
ARE ADDRESSED.
THE PORT OF SAN DIEGO IS ALREADY
ENGAGED IN ADDRESSING THESE
TYPES THE PRIORITIES AND IS
PREPARED TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO HELP IN THIS
PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
MICHAEL COOLEST SOME THE
DIRECTOR OF INTERGOVERNMENTAL
RELATIONS FOR THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY REGIONAL AIRPORT
AUTHORITY. APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO.
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY.
OUR ALTHOUGH THE AIRPORT
AUTHORITY I WAS CONCERNED WITH
THE MARCH TWENTY SECOND VERSION
OF AB THIRTY ONE NINETEEN WE
HAVE SINCE HAD SEVERAL MEETINGS
AND DISCUSSIONS WITHOUT THE
AUTHOR. ON THIS BILL.
AS A RESULT OF THAT DIALOGUE IN
THE APRIL EIGHTEENTH AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL THE AIRPORT
AUTHORITY ADOPTED A SUPPORT
POSITION ON AP THIRTY ONE
NINETEEN.
ARE THE CURRENT VERSION OF THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE A FORMAL
STRUCTURE FOR SAN DIEGO'S
TRANSPORTATION AND PLANNING
AGENCIES TO MEET AND DEVELOP
COLLABORATIVE SOLUTIONS. TO OUR
TRANSPORTATION ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGES.
THE THE AIRPORT AUTHORITY
APPRECIATES THE THOUGHTFUL AND
POSITIVE CHANGES THAT HEAT
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CONSEILLERS
FLETCHER MADE TO THE HER BILL
AND WE LOOK FORTY FOUR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH HER
OFFICE.
TO DO SOME REVISIONS IN
CLARIFICATIONS AS A SOB BILL
MOVES FOR THROUGH THE PROCESS
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS OR
ANY OTHER WITNESSES SINCE APART.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB JR
ON WE HAVE THE NATIONAL UNION
HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN THE
PAINTERS UNION. I'D LIKE TO SAY
THAT.
AFFORDABILITY AND TRANSIT FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO RESIDE AND AND
OUR TOURISTS IN SAN DIEGO IS IS
VERY IMPORTANT IN SAN FRANCISCO
YOU CAN TAKE BART TO THE
AIRPORT.
PEOPLE LIVE IN AND AROUND SAN
DIEGO THEY LIVE IN THE SOUTH BAY
THEY LIVE IN NATIONAL CITY. THE
THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN SAN DIEGO
THAT OUR AVERAGE CITIZENRY CAN'T
PAY THE HIGH COST OF PARKING. ON
A DAILY BASIS THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO TRAVEL FREELY TO AND
FROM THE AIRPORT.
TO THEIR HOMES AND AND WHERE
THEY'RE AT THEY'RE GOING TO
RESIDE IN SAN DIEGO WE SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MAP BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
UC CATHERINE GREECE REPRESENTING
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES WHO JUST
WANTED TO. MAKE SURE WE PUBLICLY
MADE. CLEAR THAT WE HAVE REMOVED
OUR OPPOSITION AND WE CERTAINLY
APPLAUD THE FINE WORK OF THE
PARTIES AT THE TABLE AND
ENCOURAGE ET AL. WE'VE INVESTED
A GREAT DEAL IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO AND THE COUNTY AND REGION
AND SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
A NEW TERMINAL. THAT CAN BETTER
SERVE THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND
THE KIND OF COLLABORATION THAT
WILL RESULT IN THAT TRAFFIC
PATTERNS AND THE ISSUES THAT YOU
WISH TO ADDRESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
I JUST HAVE A QUICK COMMENT
JOURNAL CAN. ALSO LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY OF MY KUDOS FOR.
MOVING THIS BILL TO A STUDY.
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT THERE
CLEARLY TODAY AND. I LOOK
FORWARD TO EXAMINING THE DETAILS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE STUDY IS
LIKELY TO BE AN OBJECTIVE REVIEW
OF. ALL RELEVANT FACTS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS THEIR.
BROWN'S.
OKAY.
DO WE HAVE WE HAVE A MOTION THE
SECOND.
HAVE YOU HAVE THAT DONE OF
THAT'S RIGHT NEVER MIND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I'D I DO
WANNA.
CLARIFY BECAUSE OF COURSE IF
THIS WAS A STUDY BILL I WOULD
PROBABLY HOLD IT MY OWN
COMMITTEE.
SO THIS IS NOT A STUDY BILL AND
OTHER THANK YOU AYE IT REQUIRES
ACTION BY THE AIRPORT THE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES THE CITY
AND COUNTY AND.
THE PORT TO COME UP WITH A PLAN
THAT WILL BE IMPLEMENTED COM
WITHIN A YEAR THE PROMISED YOU
KNOW EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES
THERE'S PROBLEMS IT'S BEEN
STUDIED PROBABLY ALL OF THESE
THINGS WHETHER IT'S THROUGH ER'S
IN. AND OTHER ISSUES.
UNFORTUNATELY SAN DIEGO.
REMAINS AN AREA THAT IS.
DEMOGRAPHICALLY AND.
POLITICALLY IN TRANSITION AND SO
SOMETIMES TWO ACTUALLY. I. FIND
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY AND FOR SOME
CHANGES ITEM WE NEED TO TAKE
STATE ACTION SO I APOLOGIZE FOR.
ONCE AGAIN BRINGING OUR OUR SAN
DIEGO ISSUES TO THIS COMMITTEE
BUT.
I I THINK YOU I JUST WANNA BE
REAL CLEAR BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHEN
I SAY I HAVE TO HOLD YOUR STUDY
BILL AND. THIS GETS OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS I WANNA BE CLEAR
THIS IS IN A STUDY RAIL.
BUT I MEAN IF THAT HAPPENS I DID
I'M NOT SAYING YOU HAVE A STUDY
BILL THAT I JUST YOU KNOW ONE OF
REMAIN CONSISTENT IF.
SHOVEL IF WE'DTHAT PREPARATIONS
COMMITTEE DECIDES
THAT.
UP UP UP UP VERY WHICH STUDY
DISTINCTION IT'S A IT'S A
DISTINCTION.
I HAVE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I ABOUT.
pSIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE
THERE THAT YOU REMOVE THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE WE'VE HAD
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE COMING TO
VISIT US TO TRY TO FIGURE THIS
OUT. ABOVE YOU IT REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT ALL PARTIES WERE
TOGETHER I'M SURE THE BE SOME
LITTLE THINGS WE HAVE TO WORK
OUT BUT AGAIN.
THANK YOU WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TO THINK.
SECRETARY CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSING
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY.
LIKE.
HIS BIG.
SEVEN I APPLY OF THAT รณ ACT
WHERE. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE.
WALDRON.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CAN'T BE AERO CABBIE
AERO AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE A LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
STONE STONE I'VE HUPO.
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO.
FOR THOSE LISTENING AND YES MY
VOICE IS JUST SUDDENLY DROPPED A
COUPLE OF OCT.
IS THAT WE ARE CURRY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY ON BEHALF OF MR THURMAN I
WOULD LOVE TO.
OKAY WITH THANK YOU. CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL JUST NOT MINE.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY WHICH
WILL ALLOW VOTERS IN THE CITY OF
BERKELEY THE ABILITY TO DECIDE
WHETHER THEY WANT TO INCREASE
TAXES TO FUND CITY SERVICES.
IF PASSED BY VOTERS THE SALES
TAX THE SALES AND TAX INCREASE
WILL INCREASE NO MORE THAN FIVE
POINT FIVE PERCENT. TO ADULT A
TOTAL OF NINE POINT SEVEN FIVE
PERCENT.
THE CITY OF BERKELEY NEEDS
LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY FOR AN
INCREASE TO OF TO THEIR CURRENT
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAXES.
THE CITY OF BERKLEY FACES
CHALLENGES THAT ARE UNIQUE TO
THE BORDERS OF THE CITY.
BY PROVIDING THE CITY WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING A SMALL TAX
INCREASE BEFORE IT'S VOTERS THE
VOTERS CAN WEIGH IN WHETHER
FUNDING THAT WILL IMPROVE POLICE
RELATIONS.
THE PORT COMMUNITY POLICING.
RELIEF
TO RESIDENTS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS AND HELP ADDRESS
HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS IS NEEDED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY HAVE JUST SEE OUR
WHEN. I TO GAIN THAT'S BEAUTIFUL
OF FROM THE MEN OF THE MAYOR
BERKELEY. WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR. PRESENTING THE SPELLING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ON THE CITY BERKELEY
THE SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE TWENTY AND I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. ON THIS BILL
AS WAS NOTED ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE TWENTY WILL CRITICS
DUTCH WAY WAIVER OF THE CURRENT.
TRANSACTION AND USE TAXES
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE CITY OF
BERKELEY.
WHICH WERE BY OUR CITY THE
OPPORTUNITY BRING A CONSERVATIVE
TAX INCREASE BEFORE LOCAL
VOTERS.
THIS MEASURE IF APPROVED BY THE
VOTERS WILL GENERATE MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING.
TO IMPROVE OUR COMMITTEE
POLICING PROGRAM PROVIDE RELIEF
TO RESIDENTS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL ILLNESS AND HELP ADDRESS
THE CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS ON
OUR STREETS.
THE CITY OF BERKELEY IS CURRENT
TAX RATE IS NINE POINT TWO FIVE
PERCENT. WHICH IS EXACTLY TWO
PERCENT ABOVE THE STATEWIDE.
RATE OF SEVEN POINT TWO FIVE
PERCENT.
ALONG THE CITY OF BERKELEY TO
IMPOSE AN INCREMENTAL RATE OF NO
MORE THAN POINT FIVE PERCENT
ABOVE THE CURRENT CAP.
WILL BRING THE
CITIES CURRENT TAX RATE IN SALES
TAX RATE TO.
NINE POINT SEVEN FIVE PERCENT
THEM WITH THESE FUNDS AS WAS
NOTED. WE SEEK TO NOT ONLY.
ADDRESS.
WERE CRIMINAL TENSION OF OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS BUT EXPAND
OUR COMMUNITY POLICING PROGRAM
AND EXPAND OUR EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS OF
HOMELESSNESS.
AND SO WE NEED IS LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY FOR AN INCREASE THE
CURRENT TRANSACTIONS AND USE
TAXES.
AND AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY WILL
CREATE THAT WAIVER. WE'RE NOT
ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO RAISE
OUR SALES TAX
ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR IS A
STATUTORY WAIVER OF OUR SALES
TAX CAP. SAID THE VOTERS OF
BERKELEY CAN DEMOCRATICALLY
DECIDE WHERE THEY WANT TO
INCREASE THE SALES TAX OR NOT.
IN CLOSING BY PROVIDING THE CITY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRING A
CONSERVATIVE TAX INCREASE BEFORE
LOCAL VOTERS THIS WILL GENERATE
MUCH NEED OF FUNDING TO ADDRESS
OUR IN. A PUBLIC SAFETY NEEDS AS
WELL AS THE NEEDS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ITEM
THINKING.
THANK MAYOR.
NICCOLO DELUDE QUE HERE WITH
THE.
MAYOR JUST FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES OPPOSED
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ACT
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID WILL FOR
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED TO.
AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY.
AND MEMBERS JUST SO WE'RE CAR
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A TAX
AUTHORIZATION BILL. SAUDI SAY
THAT DOES ONLY REQUIRE A
MAJORITY VOTE WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WERE OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED
ANYTIME THERE IS A SALES TAX
EXEMPTION ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
TWO PERCENT BRADLEY BURNS RATE
YOU KNOW ON THIS HAVE SENT WOULD
CERTAINLY TAKE THE CITY OF
BERKELEY OVER THAT. IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT. YOU KNOW SHOULD
THIS GIVE VOTER APPROVAL ON PASS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THE NINE
POINT SEVEN FIVE RATE THE
BERKELEY WOULD HAVE ONLY TWENTY
FOUR THE MUNICIPALITIES IN
CALIFORNIA OR ABOUT FIVE PERCENT
OF THE CITIES IN THE STATE.
ACTUALLY HAVE A SALES TAX AMOUNT
THAT HIGH.
SEN.
PRETTY DRAMATIC AND ESPECIALLY
DRAMATIC BECAUSE YOU KNOW SALES
TAXES ARE OBVIOUSLY VERY
REGRESSIVE. OBVIOUSLY AND YOU
KNOW HURT MORE LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AS A GENERAL RULE.
YOU KNOW WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT
YOU PERCENT BRADLEY BURNS RATE
HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR DECADES
AND WITH GOOD REASON AS.
GUARDS.
TAX COMPLIANCE MOST NOTABLY.
THERE'S A NUMBER OF CITIES THAT
ARE AND HAVE TO DEAL WITH
DIFFERENT TAX RATES ACROSS THE
VARIOUS AREAS OF THE
MUNICIPALITY AND IT MAKES IT
HARDER TO CLICK CELLS.
SO THAT'S AN ISSUE TO USE IT FOR
BOTH OF THOSE REASONS ASK FOR A
NUMBER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GREAT. QUESTION.
THANK YOU MONITOR AND DODD JUST
OF. I THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING
THAT. TIME I THOUGHT I HEARD IN
TESTIMONY WAS A CONSERVATIVE TAX
INCREASE.
I GUESS THAT'S A RELATIVE TERM.
FOR MANY FOLKS.
ANYWAY YOU'RE KIND OF YOURS.
JUST FOR A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION TODAY'S VOTE IS
NOT AN ACTUAL VOTE OF FOR A TAX
INCREASE IT'S SIMPLY A VOTE TO
ALLOW THE CITY TO GO BEFORE
VOTERS.
FOR WHAT THEY WOULD CONSIDER A
TAX INCREASE.
CORRECT AREN'T SUPER THANK YOU.
STONE. A
TRUE AND JUST AND JUST TO FOLLOW
ON WITH PROP THIRTEEN WHICH THE
VOTERS ENACTED WHICH PUTS
ARTIFICIAL LIMITS ON PROPERTY
TAX WHICH HAVE CITIES HAVE
TYPICALLY FUNDED THEMSELVES.
CAESAR IN THE UNENVIABLE
POSITION OF HAVING TO GO OUT AND
DO REGRESSIVE TAXES AND. AND
THINGS THAT THAT HAVE REAL
SIGNIFICANT IMBALANCE IN IN HOW
REVENUE ULTIMATELY IS RAISED AND
THAT'S WHY WE'VE BEEN TALK ABOUT
FEES HERE WE WERE TALKING ABOUT.
SALES TAX INCREASE PARCEL TAXES
AND OTHERS.
SO I I THINK IT THE CITY OF
BERKLEY WANTS TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH ITS VOTERS.
THAT SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
THAT WE DEFINITIONS ALLOW.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
GRAYSON SECOND BY MISTER STONE.
AND THE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL WHO WERE
CUT IN THE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE WALDRON BLOOM AYE AYE BLOOM
AYE HAVE THE ARROW. COME BR I
COOLEY. COOLEY AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY NO
STONE.
STONE IVU CHO.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX TO ONE
TEMPORARY CHAIR BLOOM HELPED.
ALRIGHT IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE AT
THE POINT WHERE WE NEED TO DO ON
OUR ADAMS SO.
.
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU. BEGIN
THAT PROCESS ITEM TO A. B.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE CHAO.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
COMMITTEE.
CAB CABALLERO COVER YOUR AYE
STONE.
STONE I'VE OPPO.
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY FIFTY
CABALLERO.
DO PASSED TWO PROBES WALDRON.
STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
ADAM FOR.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
STONE.
STONE I CABALLERO. KABIR I'VE
VOEPEL.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
VOEPEL.
ITEM SIX.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE
FRIEDMAN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CUBBY ARROW.
COVER YOUR EYES STONE STONE I'VE
VOEPEL.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY THREE MEDINA
WALDRON.
LACKEY.
GO. BACK YOU KNOW PHOTO.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT MAYBE TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY HARPER TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS CABALLERO.
CUMPLIR AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
STONE. STONE I'VE VOEPEL.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY TING. TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WALDRON.
LACKEY. LACKEY NOVO PARA.
ITEM NUMBER TEN.
AB TWENTY NINE ELEVEN FRIEDMAN
DO PASSED APPROPRIATIONS.
CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
ITEM ELEVEN AB NINE TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THURMOND. DO PASSED TO
REVENUE AND TAXATION.
WALDRON PROPELLED.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B.
THIRTY SIXTY EIGHT.
SALLY.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON I STONE. STONE AYE
REPEL.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB THIRTY
ONE NINETEEN GONZALEZ FLETCHER
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WALDRON.
YOU KNOW.
STUDIO AND TING.
YEAH BUT I.
WATER NOT VOTING. FOLK HAVE.
ITEM SIXTEEN.
.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A B. THIRTY WHEN
SIXTY GRAYSON. DO PASSED THROUGH
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WALDRON.
ITEM SEVENTEEN.
WALDRON NOT VOTING. CABALLERO
COMPARE AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN MAYBE
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SEVEN CHรกVEZ.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WALDRON WALDRON AYE CUBBY AERO
CUMPLIR AYE STONE. STONE I'VE
OF.
KATE I THINK.
I THINK CABALLERO.
WE.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE AN AGING?
I HAVE YOU LISTEN I.
READ RELATED.
AND.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
FIFTY CABALLERO WALDRON.
NO WILL BRING US VOTE ON YOUR
BILL YEAH.
NO.
WALDRON NO.
HOW?
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT FIFTY THREE MEDINA.
WALDRON.
WALDRON NO.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY TING.
DO PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WALDRON. WALDRON
NO.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THURMAN DO PASSED TO THE
REVENUE AND TAX TAXATION
COMMITTEE WALDRON. WALDRON NO.
WE DON'T.
REDUNDANT.
TO LIBERATE GOD.
THIS CONCLUDES A BUSINESS FOR
THE DAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I LOST THE BET THOUGH. WE'VE
DONE A